it is it should be noticed as well that
the cases which the senator from
missouri referred to yesterday all
resulted in incarceration
of some magnitude in the one case the
hillary case i want to quote what you
said on the record
this family has been torn apart speaking
to the defendant by your criminal
actions you saw it on the faces of those
women you heard it in their voices and
the impact of your acts on those very
real victims who are still struggling to
recover this day makes your crime among
the most serious criminal offense this
court has ever sentenced
and you imposed a sentence of 29 and a
half years on that defendant
so the notion that you look at this
casually or with leniency as the senator
said
your record belies that and in fact what
we're dealing with here is an issue
which even this committee and members on
the committee have been loathed to
address again
the original law was written at least
nine or ten maybe longer years ago
and the quantity of material was
relevant to the sentencing and now that
we have
computer access to voluminous amounts of
material
is raised question has it not within the
judiciary as to the appropriate
sentencing in today's circumstances
this was a question that was raised
before the sentencing commission was it
not it was senator the sentencing
commission um has written
at least one report it did when i was
there
looking at the operation of this
guideline as you said the guideline was
based originally on
a statutory scheme and on directives
specific directives by congress at a
time
in which
more serious child pornography
offenders were identified based on the
volume
based on the number of photographs that
they received in the mail and that made
totally total sense
before
when we didn't have the internet when we
didn't have distribution but the way
that the guideline is now structured
based on that set of circumstances
is leading to extreme disparities in the
system
because
it's so easy for people to get
of this kind of material now
by computers
so it's not doing the work
of differentiating who is a more serious
offender in the way that it used to
so the commission has taken that into
account and and perhaps even more
importantly courts
are adjusting their sentences
in order to account for the changed
circumstances but it says nothing about
the court's view of the seriousness of
this offense
judge the
there have been several news
organizations that have taken a look at
the senator from missouri's charges abc
news cnn news the washington post and
others have concluded that they are
inaccurate
and unfair to you in their conclusions
in fact one writer has said they are
meritless to the point
of
unacceptable levels
nationally in 2019 only 30 percent of
non-production child pornography
offenders received a sentence within the
guidelines range
fewer than 30
between 2015 and 2020 in the dc district
court where you served judges imposed
below guideline sentences in
non-production cases 80 percent of the
time for the reasons you've just
explained
judges in missouri
the home state of the senator who has
criticized your record did so 77 of the
time
one particular judge whom the senator
supported to become a federal judge by
appointment of
president trump
uh unfortunately
has a
77 percent record if i'm i'm sorry let
me make sure that this is accurate
here it is
in the united states versus class trump
appointed judge sarah pitlink
the senator's choice for the eastern
district of missouri sentenced an
individual convicted of possession of
child child pornography to 60 months
well below the 135 to 168 month sentence
recommended by the guidelines
she appears to have run into the same
issue same challenge that you have
described here
so going forward
in terms of this issue
it seems that we at least share the
burden by your interpretation
as to define this statute in modern
terms in terms of technology as it
exists today is that the way you see it
senator
congress
is tasked with the responsibility of
setting penalties
congress
tells judges
what we're supposed to do when we
sentence
and what i'd say is that congress has to
determine
how it
wishes
for judges to handle these cases but as
it currently stands
the way that the law is written the way
that congress has directed the
sentencing commission
appears to be not consistent with how
these crimes are
uh committed
and therefore there's extreme disparity
as you pointed out there are judges who
are varying because our ultimate charge
from this body is to sentence
in a way that is sufficient but not
greater than necessary to promote the
purposes of punishment
judge jackson we've heard criticism from
some about your previous work
representing detainees at guantanamo bay
in fact for years we've heard criticisms
leveled against lawyers who have
provided guantanamo detainees with legal
representation
this criticism misses one critical point
the right to counsel
is a fundamental part of our
constitutional sense sentence system
even for the most unpopular defendants
i want to thank senator graham
who served as an air force lawyer for
decades for offering his perspective
yesterday he said and i quote the fact
that you're representing gitmo detainees
is not a problem with me senator graham
said
everyone deserves a lawyer you're doing
the country a great service when you
defend the most unpopular people
and then judge roberts said during his
confirmation hearing it's it's a
tradition of the american bar that goes
back before the founding of the country
that lawyers are not identified with the
positions of their clients the most
famous example probably was john adams
chief justice said who represented the
british soldiers charged in the boston
massacre
this sentiment is shared by lawyers
across the political spectrum
i want to give you an opportunity to
address this issue because it applies
not just to gitmo detainees but to your
work as a public defender
uh in terms of the
wisdom
if acceptability of providing counsel in
those cases and what impact it's had on
you personally in terms of your rulings
on the bench
thank you senator
september 11th
was a tragic attack on this country
we all lived through it we saw
what happened and um
there were many
defenses
important defenses
that americans undertook
there were americans whose
service came in the form of military
action
my brother was one of
those americans those brave americans
who um decided to join the military to
to defend our country
there are others of you in this body
who
have military service and i honor that
to protect our country
after
9 11 there were also
lawyers
who recognized that
our nation's values were under attack
that we couldn't let the terrorists win
by changing who we were
fundamentally
and what that meant
was that
the people who were
being accused by our government of
having engaged in actions related to
this
under our constitutional scheme we're
entitled to representation
we're entitled to be treated fairly
that's what makes our system
the best in the world
that's what makes us exemplary
i was in the federal public defender's
office
when the supreme court
excuse me right after the supreme court
decided
that
individuals who were detained at
guantanamo bay
by the president
could
seek a review
of their detention
and
those cases started coming in
and
federal public defenders don't get to
pick their clients
they
have to represent
whoever comes in and it's a service
that's what you do as a federal public
defender you are
standing up for the constitutional value
of representation
and so i represented uh as an appellate
defender some of those detainees
in the early days the legal landscape
was very uncertain
uh this had never happened before not
only the attack but also uh the uh use
of executive authority to detain people
in this way and there were a lot of
questions that the court was asking the
supreme court had taken a series of
cases
to try to understand what are the limits
of executive authority which is
important all of our liberty is at stake
if we don't get it right in terms of
what the executive can do
the supreme court has recently
reaffirmed that the constitution does
not get suspended in times of emergency
and so lawyers were trying to help the
court to figure out
figure out what the executive's
power was in this circumstance and as an
appellate defender
i worked on the habeas petitions
of some of these detainees my petitions
were
virtually identical because we had very
little information part of the issue
at the very beginning of these cases was
that
most of the
factual information was classified
so defense counsel were appointed to
represent these defendants we had no
facts
and i was making legal arguments about
the circumstances
that is
what gave rise to my representation and
i
would just emphasize that
that's the role of a criminal defense
lawyer
criminal defense lawyers make
arguments on behalf of their clients in
defense of the constitution and in
service of the court
judge jackson
those of us who read about the workings
of the supreme court realize it's a
close relationship among the justices
you've seen it personally as a clerk and
as an attorney yourself
uh i'm going to close with one question
here that
comes to my mind
i was in the house of representatives
when the war on drug
measure was passed
30 years ago or so
it was at the advent of crack cocaine
it scared the hell out of us the notion
of a cheap narcotic
highly addictive destructive to
mothers and their fetus
led us to
impose a sentencing disparity between
crack and potter cocaine it was
unprecedented a hundred to one
our notion was to come down hard make it
clear that it was a federal standard
impose that standard and stop the
advance of crack cocaine
we failed from the outset
the price of cocaine crack cocaine on
the street went down and i'm
up instead of down
the uh i'm sorry i did that wrong down
instead of up
and the number of users went up instead
of down
and we found ourselves in a position
where we were filling the federal
prisons
with violations primarily for possession
of crack cocaine
hundreds of thousands being incarcerated
at the time
i came here to this committee in an
effort to try to change it negotiated a
revision of that measure from 100 to one
to 18 to one with senator jeff sessions
it was passed by the committee by the
senate and by the house of
representatives and signed into law by
president obama
then you on the sentencing commission
had to consider what to do with these
new guidelines coming from congress
and you achieved a consensus i think
most people don't realize the sentencing
commission is a pretty diverse group and
very transparent
could you close in the last minute or so
and tell tell me about that effort to
find consensus on an issue that
controversial
yes senator um as you mentioned the
sentencing commission uh is a
very diverse
group of people who've been appointed by
presidents of different parties by law
and at the time that i was on the
commission we had a range of uh of
people
um
judges from different
backgrounds
who had different views about the
criminal justice system but we had a
directive from congress in so far as
congress had changed the penalties as
you mentioned related to crack cocaine
and so
um
we work together
to make a determination about whether or
not the guidelines needed to change and
if so whether or not to
impose those changes retroactively
in light of
all of the evidence that you point out
all of the
um
the congress's changes
and um
[Music]
the need to
avoid unwarranted sentencing disparities
which
is exactly the charge that this body has
given to the commission
and we worked together
we reached unanimous agreement
that the change in the guidelines that
was necessitated by the change in the
statute should apply retroactively
to people who had been
convicted and sentenced under the prior
regime and then congress followed
shortly thereafter by making it a
statutory change to to apply
those changes retroactively
thank you to jackson
senator grassley thank you mr chairman
welcome again to our committee
i got home last night about eight
o'clock the first thing i heard was my
wife's opinion that you did very good in
your opening statement thank you
she didn't have anything to say about my
state
also
besides the fact that we might have some
votes on the united states senate just
so you know i'm not being rude to you i
may have to go across the hall to the
finance committee on some issues with
tariffs and down to the agriculture
committee for some issues on rural
health care
do you
believe
well let me ask it this way
do the first amendment free speech
protections apply equally to
conservative
and liberal protesters
yes senator okay
do you believe
the individual right to keep and bear
arms is a fundamental right
senator the supreme court has
established
that the individual right to keep and
bear arms is a fundamental right
could you tell me how you might go about
deciding
what a fundamental right is under the
constitution
well senator um i don't know that i can
tell you that in the abstract in the
sort of way that that you may have posed
the question
um
there is
precedent in the supreme court
related to
um
various rights that the court has
recognized as fundamental
the court has some
precedence about the standards
for determining
whether or not something is fundamental
the the court has said that
um
the 14th amendment
substantive due process clause
does
support some fundamental rights but only
things that are
uh implicit in the ordered concept of
liberty or deeply rooted in the history
and traditions of this country
they're the kinds of rights that relate
to
personal
uh individual autonomy and they've
recognized a few
things in that category
and that's the tradition of the court
for for
determining whether something is
fundamental in that way okay
on another subject kind of personal me
over a long period of time and about
half of this committee but it's a
controversial issue with even within
this committee
i favor allowing supreme court hearings
to be televised
what's your view on this how would you
feel about cameras in the courtroom uh
which
about 40
50 or
40 or 45 of our states allow
well senator i would want to
discuss with the other justices
their views and and understand all of
the various um
potential issues related to
cameras in the courtroom before i took a
position on it
i think that's a fair answer at this
point
uh i'm going to ask you about a bill
that i got passed a long long time ago
and it's something that at some level of
course sometimes the district court
sometime at the
circuit court and even if
once or twice at the supreme court
they tend these courts tend to do damage
to a bill
called the false claims act
this bill has brought 70 billion dollars
of fraudulently taken money back into
the federal treasury since it's been
passed
and courts if we couldn't it and then
senator
leahy and i usually find ourselves
having to pass legislation to say to the
courts you got it wrong in fact there's
a very controversial bill right now
before the united states senate on that
very subject
it's fought fraud in the department of
defense health care industry the
pharmaceutical industry
70 billion dollars is pretty important
so when you get
if you're approved to be on the supreme
court
and the issue of false claims comes up i
hope you think of chuck grassley
it's it's one of them well in lahey
the false claims act is one of the best
tools that we have to fight against
government fraud and to recover
taxpayers money i've worked for decades
to protect whistleblowers who shine a
light on fraud waste and abuse in the
government so i'd like to ask you a
couple questions
and i'm going to start with a former
attorney general unnamed once suggested
that ketam's suits were
in his words patently
unconstitutional and another word he
used was dangerous he argued that it
violated the appointments laws
so
understanding that you may get a case
before you on the false claims act but
maybe this appointment clause is uh
sound enough you could answer do key tam
suits violate the appointments clause
so senator i'm i am not familiar with
that um
representation and writing then
well i i'd be happy to do whatever i'm
just trying to assess um i'm sorry i
shouldn't have interrupted you no no
that's all right
sorry um
i am trying to
i'm not familiar with the quotation or
what the uh attorney may have said
about them i know that the supreme court
has
considered
um
various key tam actions and has
issued opinions in the area and
has not at least today found them to be
unconstitutional but i don't know if
that issue has been squarely presented
to the court and i um
would be loathed to comment on it um
just because if if it's being litigated
it's something i will be able to address
let me uh
on the same subject
also
this former attorney general also argued
that ketam suits also violate a broader
separation of power principles
are the
can you tell me whether you think the
president's constitutional powers are
violated when private citizens
are allowed to sue in the name of the
united states and that's what key tam
suits are all about private citizens
going to court
um well senator it's a it is an
important concern there are statutes
that do
allow for
the kinds of
lawsuits that you
are articulating
[Music]
i
am not aware of impediments to those
but again you know this is the kind of
thing that
be litigated and
i would have to look as i do
consistent with my methodology
at any arguments that are raised
about
the constitutionality or lawfulness of
those actions
remember in about all of these suits
that involve the courts in making
interpretations of false claims act
most of them are brought by
whistleblowers and remember the
government would not even know about
these fraudulent use of taxpayers
without whistleblowers coming forth and
they ought to be given some credit for
wanting the government to do
what the laws say it ought to do and
spend the money the way that the
constitution or the the congress implies
that that money be spent
i want to move on
at an event
at the university of chicago school of
law in 2020
you quoted
martin luther king jr
who dreamt of a time when quote
the sons of former slaves and the sons
of former slave owners
would be able to sit down together at
the table
of brotherhood end of quote
you talked about how quickly things in
the country then changed
including the civil rights laws over the
next few years because of civil rights
movement
you added that quote less than a decade
after dr king's words
that was the world
that you inhabited
dr king
hoped for a country where we would all
be judged by the content of our
character rather than our race
do these quotes still reflect your views
on this very important topic today
yes senator
in that speech
i talked about
my
background my upbringing
the fact that
my parents when they were growing up in
miami florida
attended and had to attend racially
segregated schools
because by law
when they were young
white children and black children were
not allowed to go to school together
in my reality
when i was born in 1970 and went to
school
in miami florida
was
completely different
i went to a diverse
public
heist junior high school high school
elementary school
and
the fact that we had come that far was
to me a testament
to the the hope and the promise
of this country the greatness of america
that in one generation
one generation
we could go from
racially segregated schools in florida
to have me sitting here as the first
floridian
ever to be nominated to the supreme
court of the united states
so yes senator that is my
that is my belief and i think it's good
that the country had an opportunity to
hear
what you just told us about your
experience
i'm going to go to something that
the chairman brought up
and i i've written down the 3.3 steps
you go through
uh
no
another question
but also one that he brought up
on court packing and your opinion i
heard what you said and you said it
should be a policy question but i want
to go to something in 2013 during your
hearing to be a district court judge
senator coburn asked you whether you
believed in the theory that the
constitution is a living document
whose meaning evolves over time you said
no in 2021 however during your circuit
court nomination hearing you declined to
answer the same question when asked why
the answer
uh
when asked why the answer to your
question of 2013 and not in 2021
in in written questions you noted that
you weren't a sitting judge so please
explain to me or describe for us
the difference between ethical rules for
sitting judges versus judicial nominees
who are not already judges
senator i don't know that there are
ethical rules that
are different what what i'll say is with
respect to my
approach to judging
there
is not a label i think that
fits what it is that i do
and and how i've approached
my role
as i
mentioned to the chairman
i'm very acutely aware of the
limitations on the exercise of my
judicial power
and
those limitations
come in the form of adherence to the
text when you assuming you even get to
that stage of the process that you have
you have
subject matter jurisdiction you can
reach the merits
then you are looking at the text and i
do not believe that there is uh
a living constitution in the sense that
it's changing and it and it's infused
with my own policy perspective or
you know the policy perspective of the
day
um instead the supreme court has made
clear that
when you're interpreting the
constitution you're looking at the text
at the time of the founding and what the
meaning was then
as a constraint on
my own authority
and so i apply that constraint
i look at the text to determine what it
meant
to those who drafted it
on this same subject
i want to point out a difference between
you and a couple people that have sat on
the supreme court
justice breyer said
that a structural alteration of the
supreme court motivated by perception of
political influence can only feed
the
perception of political influence that's
my parenthetical
further eroding that trust
justice ginberg also cited court packing
as being quote unquote a bad idea
court packing is creating new seats for
political purposes for a president to
appoint more judges
uh
do you agree with justice breyer and
justice ginberg that court packing is a
bad idea before you respond i'd like to
say that
you say this question should be left to
congress is a policy issue i'd reiterate
that sitting supreme court justices have
spoken on that matter so i don't think
it'd be inappropriate for you to do if
other people sitting there have said
that it's a bad idea
well respectfully senator other nominees
to the supreme court have
responded as
i will which is
um that it is a policy question for
congress and
i'm particularly mindful
of of not
speaking to policy issues because i am
so committed to staying in my lane of
the system
because i i i'm just not willing to
speak to issues that are properly in the
province
of this body okay
uh
then i would interpret your answer
and you don't have to respond to this
but i think you're saying breyer and
ginsburg should not have stated their
views on that issue
during his opening statement yesterday
one member of this committee suggested
that the supreme court has been bought
by dark money groups
do you agree that the supreme court has
been
bought by dark money groups
senator i don't have any reason to
believe
that that's the case i have only the
highest esteem for
the members of the supreme court whom i
i hope to be able to join if i'm
confirmed
and for all of the members of the
judiciary
thank you for that answer
i'm going to go to international law
during an aba panel on international law
last year
justice breyer said that as a federal
judge quote
you can't do your job properly under
quote without considering international
law
and vote again in some cases
and it's a growing number end of quote
and i assume a growing number of
opportunities use international law
in 2018 op-ed justice breyer said that
quote the best way to preserve american
values
may well be
to take account
of what happens abroad end of quote
under what circumstances is it
appropriate to consider international
law when interpreting our constitution
thank you senator um i have nothing but
the highest uh esteem and respect for
um my former boss who i've
spent the better pass better part of the
past couple decades calling my justice
having clerked for him
um
but i do think that uh the use of
international law is very limited
um in in our
scheme and in our judging
um there are
certain
cases in which it is
rely upon
um
where congress directs or where the
standards are such the case involves a
treaty for example and you have to
interpret international law in order to
be able to
address it
but there are very very few cases i
think in which international law plays
any role and certainly not in
interpreting the constitution
i'm i think you probably have answered
my next two questions but if you say you
have nothing to add i would still want
to ask the questions do you think it's
appropriate to look to international law
when interpreting enumerated and
unenumerated constitutional rights
uh no senator
which specific
again i think you've answered this but i
want to ask it anyway which specific
constitutional causes or rights has the
supreme court held that can be
interpreted by looking to international
law
i'm not aware of any
that um are
properly illuminated by reference to
international law
uh
now i want to go to a question that
senator durbin asked i'll probably
go a little more but i
remember when this is about your
judicial philosophy
and you made three points three steps
you take to go through a case and apply
the law
and uh
and and you say your
methodology is limited power
and stay within your lane
i'd like to ask you uh
well you've served on the district court
for several years
and spent eight months on the dc circuit
during yesterday's opening statement we
heard a lot about the importance of
judicial philosophy
in your own words you've described that
so you don't have to go through that
again with me
but if congress writes a law
that does not explicitly allow private
parties to sue
do you believe that the federal courts
have the authority to create implied
causes of action and i'd like to have
you elaborate if you say yes to that
i would say that as a general matter no
senator i mean our
our obligation as judges is not to
create policy
and if congress has enacted a statute
that establishes a cause of action or um
restricts causes of action
then as a general matter i don't think
that courts can impose one now you know
i'm saying generally because
um
there may be circumstances that i'm not
thinking of there i know that the
supreme court has in very
narrow circumstances at times
uh discussed implied causes of action
but i think the
charge of the judge is to
impose the law as written
there's 115 justices that serve before
you if you are approved by the senate
is there any of them
now or in the past
that has a judicial
policy that most closely resembles your
own
you know i haven't studied the judicial
philosophies of of all of the prior
justices i will say that um
i come to
this
position to this moment as a judge who
comes from practice
that i was a trial judge and my
methodology has
developed in that context i don't know
how many other
justices other than justice sotomayor
have that same perspective
but it informs me with respect to what i
understand to be my proper judicial role
uh
what aspect of your record as a judge do
you believe have been the most important
for the good of the country
well um
i think
that
all of my record
is important to some degree because i
think it clearly demonstrates that i'm
an independent jurist
that i am
ruling in every case consistent with the
methodology that i've described
that i'm
impartial
um i don't think that anyone can look at
my record and say that it is pointing in
one direction or another that it is
supporting one viewpoint or another
um
i am
doing the work
and have done the work for the past 10
years that judges do to rule impartially
and
to stay within the boundaries
of our proper judicial role
let's go to immigration
um congress gave the attorney general
quote unquote sole and unreviewable
discretion to decide
whether expec expedited renew removal
would apply to quote an alien who has
not been paroled or admitted to the
united states
you decided a case
called make the road new york
where you seem to agree that congress
gave the department of homeland security
sole and unreviewable discretion
to decide which illegal immigrants would
be
subject to
expedited removal
but you still went on to review the
department's decision in fact you issued
a nationwide injunction blocking
a department of homeland security from
removing
illegal immigrants who had been in the
country for less than two years
in that hearing
you told us
that if the text was clear that entered
the question
the law specifically says
that homeland security not the courts
was responsible for making the decision
could you please explain why you
believed a federal court could review
something congress called unreviewable
thank you
senator for allowing me to address that
opinion and my analysis with respect to
it
as you said make the road was
a
case involving a challenge
to expedited removal which was a
um
a way in which
congress had given the authority to
homeland
to the department of homeland security
to make a decision about how to deport
people
who are non-citizens
prior to the challenge that i heard
the department of homeland security
since it received that authority several
decades ago had decided that people who
were in this country for up to 14 days
and are
found within 100 miles of the border
are subject to expedited removal
the challenge that
i heard
involved the department's sudden shift
to a determination
that expedited removal would be applied
to anyone who was found anywhere in the
country and who had been here up to
two years
importantly
the challenge
was
not
about the actual determination
the challenge was about the procedures
that the agency undertook to make that
determination
and so the statute said as you
rightly pointed out
that the agency had sole and
unreviewable discretion to decide
and in interpreting that
i took into account
the language of that statute and
the language of
another statute that congress has
enacted to direct agencies with respect
to the manner in which they exercise
their discretion
so i said and i believed
that seoul
meant that the department of homeland
security
was the only agency who got to make this
determination as to how many months a
person should be in the united states
and unreviewable meant it was final
once the agency decided
um
then there was no ability to review
substantively their determination and i
should say
that importantly the statute
that congress enacted
gave the agency the discretion to make
this determination between zero and 24
months
there is a limit in the statute it says
congress you i mean excuse me department
of homeland security you get to decide
where between zero and 24 months
uh a person
who's been in this country can be
subject to expedited removal
so i read the statute
dhs gets the sole ability to make that
decision
dhs
makes that decision and it's final
what wasn't clear to me based on that
language
was whether congress intended to
preclude
its procedural requirements for the
exercise of agency discretion and in the
dc circuit there was precedent that
indicated that even when
congress gives a great deal of
discretion to an agency
procedural requirements may still apply
it is presumptive that the apa applies
meaning that an agency can't act
arbitrarily and capriciously when it
undertakes to exercise discretion it has
to do certain things in order to make
the determination that congress has
given it
i looked at those statutes oh i'm sorry
i looked at those statutes
and i
considered
the canons of construction that say that
statutes should be read harmoniously
that you're that as a court you're
supposed to understand that congress has
directed sometimes in more than one
statute what is supposed to happen and
so i read them together
to mean
that the court could still do what it
all
almost always does uh in a case
involving
a challenge to the manner in which an
agency makes its decision and in fact i
thought
as i say in my opinion
that congress intended for the apa to
imply because it had not excluded it
which it had done expressly in other
parts of the of the ina it had not
excluded it here
and
it made sense
to
uh require the agency to use its
expertise if congress wanted the agency
to act arbitrarily in picking a number
congress could have done that
congress said you can do it up to 24
months it could have randomly picked a
number
but it was giving it to the agency i
thought and reasoned precisely because
it wanted the agency to use its
expertise to do its research and to
figure out
what
amount of time
is sufficient
and so it was important i thought
to lay that out in the statute
and
i determined
that both of those statutory directives
of congress should apply
thank you senator grassley senator leahy
thank you chair german
judge congratulations again on your your
nomination to our nation's highest court
you're an impressive jurors
i hope the broader public sees that and
enjoyed the opportunity to meet your
family here yesterday and uh
uh
i thought before i begin my questions i
was going to respond to something the
junior senator from
texas said yesterday
he suggested democrats exactly the
political agenda by opposing the
nomination and then judge gorsuch to the
supreme court
i kind of chuckled at that because
along with others i and
others repeatedly and clearly
stated substantive concerns with justice
scorcher's nomination
i explained my votes on the record
there's no political agenda
i contrast that with republicans
treatment then judge merrick garland
we're still
waiting today
for republicans who explain on the
record what kind of substantive concerns
they had with merrick garland
that they blocked him
uh for over a year and would not allow
even allow a vote
uh on his nomination
uh
apparently
because of a politically driven agenda
all i'm saying is let's make history
this week well let's not rewrite it
this is a historical time
judge jackson one of the topics we
discussed in our meeting was
our respective experiences uh
you as a former
federal public defender myself as a
prosecutor
as a federal public defender here in
washington you were assigned to and then
represented clients who couldn't
otherwise afford a lawyer
one of the valuable lessons i learned as
a prosecutor was this
for a criminal justice system to
function properly you have to have
skilled dedicated lawyers on both sides
of the issue both the prosecutor and the
defense attorney
it's equally essential for judges
to have a nuance and a balanced
understanding of our criminal justice
system if we're going to have justice
done
now
it's really concerning
[Music]
it's confusing that some
feel your background as a federal public
defender some kind of a liability
those of us who have spent time in
courtrooms know
you have to have both the
skilled prosecutor and a skilled
defender
i believe that
in fact i don't think of it as a
liability i think it's going to be a
major asset to you
and i think it should be welcome uh
on the supreme court the fact that if
you're confirmed to the court as i look
back over you're going to be the first
former federal
public defender
on the court
you're going to be the first nominee
since justice's third good partial
with a significant
background
in criminal defense
that's pretty impressive
so
all of us should want that
representing the supreme court
because
decisions on the supreme court can have
a lasting impact on our criminal justice
system
my question is this
i believe that your experience as a
federal public defender has made you a
better judge help you maintain impartial
and balanced perspective and criminal in
other cases
and i assume you would agree with that
yes senator um
i i think that experience in the
criminal justice system
um
whether as you say on on the prosecution
side or the defense side having actual
experience
is an asset as a judge you understand
the way the system works
and as a defense counselor you have
interacted
with defendants in a way that as a judge
at least as a trial judge
i thought was very
beneficial
one of those ways
is
it helped me to develop
a sense of the need to communicate
directly with defendants
um and
you know it didn't change i think in any
way the outcomes
of the cases when i was a trial judge
but
i understood from my time as an
appellate defender
that a lot of defendants go through the
system and don't really understand it
and the problem with that from our
society's standpoint is that when people
go through the criminal justice system
and don't have a good understanding
they tend to not take responsibility for
their own
actions
they tend to be bitter
and feel as though the justice system
has wronged them and so while they're
doing their time rather than reflecting
on the fact
that this is the consequence that they
have to face for
actually
um
committing a crime instead of
doing the work to rehabilitate
themselves
they're you know focusing on how wronged
they are how victimized they feel and so
what i decided
as a trial judge was that i was going to
make sure that everyone who was in my
courtroom and especially the defendant
understood
all of the
procedures that we were going through
all of the steps
i spoke directly to them
i asked them do you understand what's
happening because i wanted them to know
and then even perhaps more importantly
as i said about my my child pornography
cases i focused
on the harms
of the behavior that was at issue when i
sentenced a defendant i made clear in
every case
here is the problem
this is what you've done
here is the damage to our society
and i don't know that i would have done
that um if if i had not been
a criminal defense lawyer well and
that's sort of what you know i was
getting to the fact that you have that
experience i
also it's obvious you don't get as a
public defender you don't get the right
to you don't get to choose your clients
it's not like you're going out there
picking and choosing you're told you're
going to defend this person but
they're given that right under the sixth
amendment
and we
uh
we all
carry a
member of the bar or judge or public
defender you take an oath
to uphold the uh constitution
and the sixth amendment's a pretty
important part of it wouldn't you say
absolutely senator
and
it's also a pretty important part
for indigent
defendants is that not correct
that is correct especially for indigent
defendants because they are determined
to not be able to afford counsel and as
you said senator
for a judge
it is crucial
that you have arguments that are being
made and presented on both sides of the
issue
that is what allows for judges to
reach
just results in cases and it's what
makes our system
so exemplary it also guarantees that our
constitution is going to be fall
i
you know i i think it's
important you went around with uh
senator doug jones who's highly
respected
uh in the center on both sides of the
aisle
but you got to meet um
other other senators i i was glad you
came to
uh
to spend time in my office and
you noted in your public remarks at the
white house when you were nominated that
you've been
your parents are married for 54 years
uh and both public servants in their own
right
they are proudly watching you
uh being announced by the president and
i must admit watching them to uh the
last couple of days they're probably
watching you here as have other members
of your
family
your younger brother became a police
officer detective in baltimore before
serving the army
two
two
tours of duty in the middle east
two uncles who served as police officers
so i'm not really surprised
that you understand law enforcement the
national fraternal order police
has expressed strong support for your
nomination
in fact the letter dated february 25th
2022
they said you have considered the facts
and applied the law consistently and
fairly on a range of issues
and they went on to say there's little
doubt
do you have the temperament intellect
legal experience
and family background earnest
appointment
and they added
we are assured
reassured that should she be confirmed
to approach her future cases
an open mind treat issues related to law
enforcement fairly unjustly
a chair german hadas consent that the
letter from the fraternal order please
be included in the record this objection
now
that's a statement from the largest law
enforcement
labor organization in the united states
what do you say to people say you're
soft on crime
or even anti-law enforcement because
you accepted your duties as a public
defender
thank you senator i i would make um
i'd make three observations in response
to
those critiques
the first is that as
someone
who has had family members
on patrol and in the line of fire
i care deeply about public safety
i know
what it's like
to have loved ones who go off to protect
and to serve
and the fear
of
not knowing whether or not they're going
to come home again
because of crime in the community
as you said my brother
my brother patrolled the streets of
baltimore
and i had two uncles who were career law
enforcement including
one who became the chief of police of
the city of miami police department in
the 1990s
so crime
and the effects on the community and the
need
for law enforcement
those are not abstract concepts or
political slogans to me
the second
observation that i would make is
that as a lawyer and as
a citizen
i care deeply about our
constitution and about the rights that
make us free
as you say criminal defense lawyers
perform a service
and our system is exemplary throughout
the world
precisely because
we
ensure that people who are accused of
crimes are treated fairly
it's very important to me
in that capacity as a lawyer and as a
citizen
oh i'm sorry i was just going to say the
third thing i would say is is as a judge
as a judge i care deeply about the rule
of law
i know
that in order for us to have a
functioning society
we have to have
people being held accountable for
committing crimes
but we have to do so fairly under our
constitution
as a judge
who has to decide how to handle these
cases
i know it's important to have arguments
from both sides to have competent
counsel and it doesn't mean
that lawyers condone the behavior of
their clients they're making arguments
on behalf of their clients
in defense of the constitution and in
service of the court and it is a service
well i i know in our conversation i
i'd mentioned
my own experience as a prosecutor i want
the best defense attorney on the other
side
because you want to make sure that
the trial went on everything was done
properly
and
let's talk about guantanamo bay
it's been controversial
and we've had two presidents one
republican one democratic who
said they wish it could be closed
but the fact is
individuals were detained there
the whole world was watching this
we i i know
i heard from
people i respect
uh throughout the world
asking questions about guantanamo
and
that's precisely
the situation we want our best and our
brightest lawyers
to step into the fray however
politically controversial we have to
make sure that we do not become uh
unmoored from our core commitments to
the rule of law
but that also both in our own country
and outside our country
people can see that we're following
that so you
were in
private practice uh when you took on
these cases
uncharted legal waters
were
uh
what principles drove you to get
involved
with cases in such a a difficult time in
guantanamo bay
well thank you senator and i i do want
to clarify when i first started working
on these cases um i was an assistant
federal public defender
um
the supreme court in 2004
issued two opinions
that began
this group of cases and these issues and
this was in the wake of
the tragic and terrible
attack on this country
uh in 911
and the executive's use of authority to
detain
uh enemy combatants at guantanamo bay
in 2004
the supreme court ruled
that
the executive did have the authority to
make those detentions
in one case and then in another case the
supreme court ruled
that anyone so detained
could file a legal challenge
they had habeas rights and as you know
habeas is in the constitution
in 2005 i joined the federal public
defender's office and those cases
started coming in
the requests from detainees asking for
legal representation consistent with our
constitution
to
help defile their habeas petitions
this was very early
in the days of these kinds of legal
actions there was a lot unknown
about what these petitions could look
like what the arguments could be made
and considered by the court and and
perhaps most importantly what the facts
were
related to any of these individuals
because almost everything was classified
so defense counsel was getting these
these
people in
with no information
i was in the appellate division of my
office
and as an appellate defender i worked on
legal issues i was paired with my i was
assigned by the federal public defender
i was an assistant federal public
defender
and i was paired with a trial defender
who
attempted to do the fact gathering who
traveled to guantanamo bay i never
traveled there or anything like that i
worked on the law
and as you noted the law was very
uncertain this was brand new
and people were trying to figure out
what are the limits of executive
authority in this context we knew
that the constitution was not suspended
even though we had this emergency so
what did that mean with respect to these
individuals
i filed as a federal public defender
i was assigned to work on four cases
and i filed almost identical petitions
because what you're doing especially
when you have no facts is just
preserving
legal arguments for your clients that is
consistent with what
lawyers do
and then
you mentioned private practice so i went
into private practice and i believe it
was 2007
and by that time lots of private
practices around the country had started
taking on these cases because there were
lots of people who needed representation
and so pro bono practices
were receiving requests
usually through non-profits
and
one of the individuals that i had
represented as a defender
ended up being assigned to my firm
unbeknownst to me
so i arrive at my firm
and the partners realize that this same
person
um
was someone that according to the docket
i had previously represented and they
asked if i would review some of his
materials and continue the
representation that was the only person
that i represented in the context of my
private firm who was a detainee
i worked on a couple of habeas briefs
for
judges and for um
a variety of ins of of nonprofits
including the rutherford institute the
cato institute and the constitution
project
um who were all interested in making
arguments to the supreme court that was
considering
these very novel legal issues
you know i
i sit here and i i think of the
20
supreme court nominees i've gotten to
vote on over
my years here and
i
think of the remarkable praise you got
from
former republican house speaker
paul ryan
whom most of us know well
he did mention his politics may be
different than yours but his praise for
your intellect for your character for
your integrity
is unequivocal
that's powerful praise and i i think it
goes to a really
fundamental point and that's this
one doesn't have to have the same
political beliefs or
ideologies
as a judicial nominee to recognize their
integrity and intellect
when i voted to confirm chief
justice john roberts of the supreme
court
i cast that vote knowing very well that
he and i would
disagree on many policy and political
issues
but
i voted yes because i believe they had
what it takes to serve
as an impartial
fair chief justice
who would uphold the rule of law
and i want to take it out of partisan
politics
now
what would you say to
people whose politics may be different
than yours
like speaker ryan who has
endorsed you
what would you say to those people about
your readiness
to serve as an even-handed unbiased
supreme court
justice thank you senator
i would say that
i am committed
to serving as an even-handed
supreme court justice if i'm confirmed
by this body and i have a record
over the past decade
that's precisely how i've treated
all of my cases
and i've been serving in the district of
columbia
both as a trial judge and as an
appellate judge and we see some of the
most
politically contentious
issues
my record demonstrates
my impartiality
well
along with that because uh
and i
i watched this court i
i i used to
go there as a young lawsuit and sit in
the back and just watch it i continue to
watch it i
see the chief
uh
judge of the federal district court
judge barrow howe who
i
i was privileged to have her
serve as my chief counsel
on on this committee
and
learned from her then i learned from her
now
but i also
as a lawyer i
i hear a lot of talk about reversal
rates
now
no judge has goes without being reversed
somewhere
if they
they never reverse they haven't heard
many cases
but your time in the district
d.c district court less than two percent
of your more than 550
cases were reversed
uh
consider the fact
that
the dc circuit reverses an average of 13
percent of the cases
it um
adheres
you get a pretty good record and uh
but
what is the judge who's been reversed
what do they take from that reversal
what are they what what do they or what
should they think about
it well you obviously look at it very
carefully um what it means is that um
a panel of judges who've reviewed
what you determined
for some reason has decided differently
and
there are times when
um panels of judges decide differently
because they are
making new a new statement about the law
or they're
establishing a standard that um had not
previously
been the case in the area
and so you learn oh this is a new
standard now that i need to apply there
are times when you
um
disagree that people can disagree about
the way in which the law works and
that's why we have panels
because people have different judges can
have different perspectives and in good
faith
reach different
results and so
obviously when you're on the trial court
the the court of appeals
uh is binding and they tell you
um in this case no we're going to
the result is something different and so
you learn
you know
anytime i had an opportunity to argue a
case of an appellate level
i don't think i ever thought about
who
nominated or appointed
the judge's eyes before i just want to
know what i would think about their
experience
and i would think about that when i made
the argument not
i don't think i've ever
had the opportunity to argue before
anybody had your breadth of legal
experience here
you served as a federal trial court
a federal appellate court
judge for almost 10 years
you courted all three levels
of the federal judiciary
you practice law as a federal
public defender in private practice and
i know we
uh confirmed you as
a member of the u.s sentencing
commission
this may seem like an easy question but
i just ask you
that you've had such products
experienced but they're all different
in a way how does that uh how's that
shape your approach when deciding a case
oh
thank you senator um
as i mentioned at the beginning um i
have um
a methodology that i apply
when i'm deciding cases and maybe
my various experiences helped me to get
to the point
of
understanding the importance of
impartiality
staying in my lane as a judge
because the prior experiences
were different roles in the system
because i saw the different
roles
i think i have a good appreciation of
what it
means to be a judge and the limitations
on my own authority
the sentencing commission
was a policy-making branch of the
judicial
branch
that the the commission
and the commissioners
develop sentencing policy
um
congress delegated that authority to
create the commission and so they're
doing the the policy work gathering data
making recommendations that is totally
different
than the work that i do
as a judge
advocacy
on behalf of your clients
making critical arguments the best
arguments you can come up with
is a service to the court but it's a
totally different thing
than operating as a judge
and so i think that having had those
various experiences i'm now
really mindful
of my role and limitations in the the
judicial branch
well and and the president referred to
you as a proven consensus
builder and i think he was
also thinking of
your predecessor
justice breyer in that regard
and i think uh over the years how
important that is even a body like the
u.s senate i see senator tillis here
he and i have worked together on ip
issues
uh senator cornyn
and i on
freedom of information issues senator
grassley
and i and other issues and graham and i
on various issues and
and
usually
in the senate at least if you work
across the ideological spectrum
you get better results
so let me ask you how would you describe
your approach to building consensus on
cases related to issues like
intellectual property
then are less likely to break up break
along traditional
ideological lines
thank you
um
thank you senator
one of the things that i
was able to do when i worked on the
sentencing commission
um
was work
with people who had very different
perspectives than i did about
the criminal justice system and
come to consensus
it's very important as you've said to
try to find common ground and justice
breyer was such a wonderful
model
a role model for that kind of um
ability
as a supreme court justice it's
something i learned from him and
um something i tried to model in my work
on the commission that i try to model in
my work as an appellate judge and that i
would model
or or
do
if i were confirmed to the supreme court
thank you chair thank you senator leahy
and now senator graham
thank you judge
again congratulations i want to talk to
you a little bit about family and faith
because in your opening statement
and the people who
introduced you to the committee
uh there was very glowing praise of you
as a person a good friend
you have a wonderful family you should
be proud and your faith matters to you
what faith are you by the way
senator i am um
protestant
okay um
non-denominational okay
could you fairly judge a catholic
senator i have a record of i think the
answer would be judging everyone i
believe you can i'm just asking this
question because
how important
is your faith to you
senator personally
my faith is very important
but as you know
there's no religious test in the
constitution under under article six and
there will be none with me and
um
it's very important to set aside one's
personal views yeah about things
in the role of a judge i couldn't agree
with you more and i believe you can
so uh on a scale of one to ten
how faithful would you say you are
in terms of religion you know i go to
church probably three times a year so
that speaks poorly of me
or dude do you attend church regularly
well senator
i am reluctant
to talk about my
faith in this way just because i want to
be
mindful
of the need for the public to
have confidence in my ability to
separate out my personal views well how
would you feel if a senator up here said
your faith the dogma lives loudly within
you and that's of concern
how would you feel if somebody up here
on our side
said you know you attend church too much
for me or your faith is a little bit
different to me
and they would suggest that it would
affect your decision
would you find that offensive
senator i'm i'm i would if i were you
i found the defensive when they said
about judge barrett the reason i ask
these questions is i have no doubt that
your faith is important to you and i
have zero doubt
that you can adjudicate people's cases
fairly if they're an atheist
if i had any doubt i would i would say
so but the only reason i mention this
judge you're reluctant to talk about it
because it's uncomfortable just imagine
what would happen if people
on late night television called you an f
nut speaking in tongues because you've
practiced the catholic faith in a way
they
couldn't relate to or found
uncomfortable
so judge you should be proud of your
faith i am convinced that whatever faith
you have and how often you go to church
it will not affect your ability to be
fair
and i just hope going in the future that
we all can
accept that
and that judge barrett i thought was
treated very very poorly
um so i just wanted to get that out
let's talk about family
uh do you know janice rogers brown
yes i do know her
how do you know her
she was a judge on uh the court that i
now serve we didn't overlap and i'm
struggling to remember whether i ever
met her but she was a judge on the
circuit court right and you were a
district court judge is that right
i was but i don't know whether she had i
think you were talking are they in the
same building they are in the same
building they are so you really don't
know her
i know of her yes what do you know of
her what's her reputation
um
i know that
she's
a very well respected judge on my
circuit okay
in terms of family she was the daughter
and granddaughter of
sharecroppers she was raised in alabama
under jim crow
despite this adversity she put herself
through law school as a single working
mother that's pretty impressive isn't it
yes senator your background is very
impressive seemed to have a great family
uh if family mattered
we would not have done to her
what was done to her here in the united
states senate do you realize that she
was filibustered for two years
when she was appointed the dc circuit
i didn't
know that did you know that joe biden
actively filibustered janice rogers
brown
i did not know that
did you know that he told face the
nation
if bush
nominates her for the supreme court i
can assure you that would be a very very
very difficult fight
and she probably would be filibustered
is that news to you too
yes okay
now that you know that how do you feel
about it
senator i can't speak to something that
i just learned two seconds ago in your
fair conversation with me fair enough um
you're in the black law school society
right
the
law students association okay black law
student association yes you're a member
at harvard
yes
and then sometime
the mr jeffries thing do you remember
that whole dust up
he got
only in
preparation for this and i think
i was in college at the time it was my
senior year of college okay so you were
actually in the group when he was
invited to speak
i don't know which group um invited him
to speak i was
a black student at harvard
both
in the harvard undergraduate black
students association and the harvard
law school black students association do
you remember going to a speech
given by mr jeffries i think he's the
uncle of king jeffries i did not go to a
speech okay given by mr jeff are you now
familiar with her press reports about
what mr jeffrey's views are just in
preparation for this okay and you do do
you associate yourself with those views
i do not senator as a matter of fact
he's been called by many as very
anti-semitic he called you skunk who
stink up the place
you don't agree with that do you i do
not senator and it would be wrong for me
or anybody else to hold his statement
against you because he spoke at some
group you're a member of right
senator i don't have
yes
it would be yeah that's right that's the
right answer i thought that was the
right answer with judge alito
when they made a big deal about some
group he was in
that had views that he didn't agree with
and tried to call him basically a racist
and found out the senator kennedy god
rest his soul who beat the crap out of
the guy
for being part of some supper club
that was actually in some organization
called the owl
that didn't admit women so i guess the
reason i'm bringing all this up
is it gives me a chance to remind this
committee in america there are two
standards going on here if you're an
african-american conservative woman
you're fair game to have your life
turned upside down to be filibustered no
matter how
qualified you are
and if you express your faith as a
conservative all of a sudden you're a
effing nut
and we're tired of it
it's not going to happen to you
but it just appalls me
that we can have such a system in
america that if a conservative woman
wants to stand out and say i love my
family just as much as you love yours
and my faith means just as much to me as
it does you that all of a sudden there
come some kind of weirdo
a guy like justice alito who's in the
same type situation you're in being in a
group doesn't agree with everything they
do or what people may say at a meeting
he didn't go to all of a sudden they own
it
you know this stuff needs to stop
our people deserve better respect and i
hope
this is over people will say you were
at least well treated even if we don't
agree with you
uh so now let's talk about
gitmo
being a
public defender
did you consider that rewarding
senator
yes um i did because
public service
is very important to me it is an
important family value
it is something that now i've dedicated
my career to
yes and do you think it's important to
the system that everybody be represented
absolutely it's a core constitutional
value you'll get no complaint from me
that was my job in the air force i was a
area defense counsel i represented
anybody that came in the door or i liked
them or not i did my best is that what
you did
yes sir
okay good now
so the american people deserve a system
where everybody's represented whether
you like them or not and anybody takes
up that cause
no problem with me you're just doing
your job and i think you make our
country stronger
but there's the other side of the story
that never gets mentioned when i talk
about gitmo the american people deserve
a system that can keep terrorists off
the battlefield
they deserve a system that understands
the difference between being at war
and a crime
do you consider 9 11 you said a terrible
tragic event would you consider it an
act of war
yes senator okay i would too i think it
was an act of war by al-qaeda and
associated groups against the people of
the united states
so as you
rightfully are proud of your service as
a public defender
and you represented get mo detainees
which is part of our system
i want you to understand in the nation
to understand
what's been happening
at gitmo what's the recidivism rate at
gitmo
senator i'm not aware it's 31 percent
how does that strike you
right i don't i don't know how it
strikes me over you know i really likes
me it strikes me it's terrible yes
that's what i was gonna say okay good we
found common ground of the 229 detainees
uh released from gitmo of 729 release
229
have gone back to the fight
here's some of the notables
uh
former gitmo detainee zakir
was named the interim defense minister
of afghanistan
i don't know exactly what his job is
today but during the transition they
made him the defense minister and he was
in gitmo
of the five men we released from gitmo
as part of prisoner swap for sergeant
bergdahl
here's what here's where they're at
mohammed fazal was appointed deputy
minister of defense
noor was appointed acting minister of
borders and tribal
affairs wauzeki was appointed as acting
intelligence director
care again acting minister of
information culture defense
omar was appointed as new governor of
the southeastern province of coast
these were five people that we had in
our control they're now helping the
taliban run the country would you say
that our system in terms of releasing
people needs to be re-looked at
senator what i'd say is that
that's not a
job for the courts in this way that um
as an american or does that bother you
well
obviously senator any um
repeated criminal behavior or
repeated attacks
acts of war
bother me as an american well it bothers
me while i will not hold it against you
nor should i the fact that you represent
gitmo detainees i think it's time to
look at this system new folks when 31 of
people are going back to fight to kill
americans and
now running the taliban government we
have gone wrong somewhere
are we still at war
um
so
the
aumf
the authorization for military force is
still in effect
congress has authorized uh the use of
force against
people in um in this way
but do you personally believe that
al-qaeda
isis-type groups are still at war with
us
i think
yes i mean i think we so we're still in
a state of war with certain elements of
radical islam to this very day
i believe that's documented yes okay
now
what's the process to determine whether
one's an enemy combatant under our law
well um i believe that the executive
branch makes an
assessment um of whether or not someone
is taking up arms against the united
states somewhere in the world related to
all of this
okay
so it's an executive branch function
to determine whether or not this person
qualifies as an enemy combat
well i believe that they make it current
law under current law
i believe that determination is made by
the executive branch and the person is
put into
is detained
um and then the question becomes
whether they
are able to bring some sort of
legal challenge to that they have that
right yes okay so the law is that the
executive branch determines if you're an
enemy combatant
and under our law
you can appeal that decision to a
federal court through habeas is that
correct i believe that's correct okay
is it your view that we can hold enemy
combatants as long as they're a threat
to the united states
i believe that's what the supreme court
has determined okay did you argue that
that should not be the case before in an
amicus breathe
i'm trying to think i had two amicus
briefs that i worked on or three
technically but two different cases
um we'll have another visit tomorrow yes
go back and check yes i'm pretty sure
that in your brief you argued that the
executive branch should not have the
ability
to hold an enemy combatant and
definitely you need to try them
through some process or release them yes
senator as you were
talking i my clients the cato institute
the rutherford institute and the
constitution project
made that argument
and asked me to draft their brief yes
well do you agree with that argument
senator my
responsibility was to make my clients
arguments and as a nominee in the
supreme court that's the kind of issue
this
court did not address that issue they in
fact
um the case became moot so did you
organize an effort to get 20 judges to
to file a brief the supreme court on
this issue
not on that issue no on another issue
yes senator okay did you actively go out
and recruit 20 judges
to help you file a brief on another
issue regarding world war detention
not technically
um what do you mean by that what i mean
is that
i was
at morrison and forster which was my law
firm in the supreme court and appellate
group
one of
the partners at morrison enforcer was a
former federal judge
who
wanted to make this argument and who
said
we
i have former federal judges who are
friends of mine who would like to join
with me to make this argument so i
worked with her
the partner at my firm who was a former
federal judge
to make it was her idea to get former
judges to write this yes yours
and you just helped in the
implementation of that idea
so senator as a member of the supreme
court and appellate group in a law firm
that is the practice right now
yes it wasn't your idea with somebody
else yes okay
uh
so
now
there are people still held at gitmo
today
do you do you understand that yes okay
what system is in place
regarding their future
i am not
aware of the system right now
um i'm not sure exactly let me tell you
what it is yes there's a periodic review
process
made up of an interagency
where they go through the files of these
folks
and they determine whether or not they
still present a threat to the united
states or the world at large
and i think it's six months maybe a year
but that goes on
at least on an annual basis
and if there's a determination that this
person
still represents a threat to the united
states
uh they're continued to be confined
that's the way the system works
are you okay with that
as a policy matter senator i'm i'm not
speaking to my views that that's my
understanding is that the periodic
review system is an executive branch
determination of whether or not they're
going to continue to hold people that
they
make sense to you as a way to deal with
these detainees senator i'm not in a
position to speak to the policy or the
discretion of the executive branch
regarding how they're going to handle
detainees the reason i mentioned it is
because in one of the briefs you argued
that the executive branch doesn't have
that option
that if we if you had had your way
the executive branch could not do
periodic reviews about the danger the
detainee presents to the united states
they would have to make a decision of
trying them or releasing them
is that not accurate respectfully
senator it was not my argument
i was filing an amicus brief
on behalf of clients including the
rutherford institute the cato institute
and the constitution project
who what when you when you sign on to a
brief does it not become your argument
it does not senator if you are if you
are an attorney
and you are representing a client in
america is that your position uh when
you were in private practice
i mean you you sign onto this brief
making this argument but you say
it's not your position i mean
why would you do that if it's not your
position
why would you take a client that has a
position like that this is voluntary
nobody's making you do this
oh senator i would i would refer you to
the same sorts of statements that chief
justice roberts made when he came before
the committee which is that lawyers
represent clients
i get that i'm not holding the client's
views against you the like that the
people you're representing get mo they
deserve representation but this is a
amicus brief where you
and other people
try to persuade the court to change
policy
the policy i described is a periodic
review
if the court had taken the position
argued in the brief that you signed upon
would have to release these people or
try them in some of them the evidence we
can't disclose because it's classified
you're putting an america in an
untenable position this is not the way
you fight a war if you tried to do this
in world war ii they'd run you out of
town
we hold enemy combatants as long as
they're a threat there's no magic
passage of time that you got to let them
go
so my question is very simple
do you support the idea did you support
then the idea
that indefinite detention of an enemy
combatant is unlawful
respectfully senator
when you are
an attorney
and you have clients who come to you
whether they
pay
or not
you represent their positions before the
court i i'm sure i'm sure
everybody get mo wants out now i got
that
this is an amicus brief and i i just
don't understand what you're saying
quite frankly i'm not holding against
you because you represented a legal
position i disagree with
i mean
that happens all the time i'm just
trying to understand what made you
join this cause and you say
somebody hired you
but
did you feel okay in adopting that cause
i mean
when you signed on to the brief were you
not advocating that position to the
court
senator as a judge now
okay in order to
determine
the lawfulness or unlawfulness of any
particular issue
i
need to receive
briefs and information making positions
on all sides
i got what a judge is all about i listen
i'm not asking you to decide the case in
front of me right here i'm asking me to
explain a position you took
as a lawyer
regarding the law of war and i am beyond
confused
i know what you said in your brief
what i agree with or not is not the
point i just want you to understand that
it's important for all of us to know
where you were coming from if that brief
had been accepted by the court
it would be impossible for us to fight
this war because there's some people
going to die in jail and gitmo and never
go to trial for a lot of good reasons
because the evidence against them is so
sensitive we can't disclose it to the
public that we're not charging them with
a crime what we're doing is saying that
you engaged in hostile activities
against united states that you are an
enemy combatant under our law and you
will never be released as long as you're
a danger until the war is over you're no
longer a danger that's the difference
between fighting a crime and a war
did you ever accuse in one of your
habeas petitions the government of
acting as war criminals
were holding the detainees
the holding of the detainees by our
government
that we were acting as war criminals
senator i don't remember that accusation
but i will say that
you believe that's true
that america was acting as war criminals
and holding these detainees
senator the supreme court held that
the executive branch has the authority
to detain people who are designated as
enemy combatants
for the duration of the hostilities
and
what i was
doing in the context of the habeas
petitions at this very early stage in
the process
was making allegations
to preserve issues on behalf of my
clients
a habeas petition is like
a complaint
that lawyers make allegations i've been
a lawyer too but i don't think it's
necessary to call the government a war
criminal in pursuing charges against a
terrorist
i just think that's too far i don't know
why he chose those words
that's just too far
but
we are where we are
so let's talk about
and the nomination process
have you ever had any interaction with a
group called demand justice
no
directly or indirectly no
uh have you ever had an interaction with
a group called american prospect
no do you know anything about uh our
our bella is that the right term
have you ever heard of a group called
arbella
i've heard of a group that i think is
arabella or something like that you're
right yes
yeah do you know anything about them
have you had any contact with them no
okay
uh in
your nomination did you notice that
people from the left were pretty much
cheering you on
a lot of people were cheering me on
something
that's true
did you know that a lot of people from
the left were trying to destroy michelle
chiles did you notice that
senator a lot of people were supporting
various people for this nomination
so you're saying you didn't know there
was a concerted effort
to
disqualify judge childs from south
carolina because she was a
union busting
unreliable republican in disguise
senator i
was i'm a sitting judge i was focused on
my cases no i didn't know that no i
didn't know that would it bother you if
sir
if that happened
senator
it is troublesome that
people
are or were doing things related to i
think that's the best way to say it
people have a right to speak out and
pick the person of their choice
but all i can say is it if you missed
the fact
that there was an organized effort well
here's president biden has only a
certain amount of political capital for
keeping his party united if he
needlessly angers progresses on this
scotus pick that could create all sorts
of problems for him down the line jeff
hauser revolving door
projects uh let's see
i just got so many quotes
it's difficult to imagine someone with a
record like judge childs winning votes
from criminal justice advocates like
senator cory booker even dick durbin
uh child's experience is nothing like
the diversity of experience that the
bible administration has championed
um
let's just let's see
taking her child's would demoralize the
base side with corporate america the
fact that lindsey graham is vouching
virus should give the white house pause
our revolution
joseph
jerivanji or whatever his name is i'm
sorry about that joseph he's bernie
sanders pac director
you didn't know that all these people
were declaring war on judge charles
senator i did not okay
well
no i'm i'm not saying you did and you
said you didn't know i'll take it your
word
but i am saying
that
what is your judicial philosophy
so i have a methodology that i use in my
cases in order to ensure that i am
uh ruling impartially
and that your judicial philosophy is to
rule impartially no my judicial
philosophy is to rule impartially and to
rule consistent with the limitations on
my authority as a judge and so my
methodology
actually helps me to do that in every
case so you wouldn't say that you're an
activist judge
i would not say that okay and so we'll
have a 20 minutes more later on but
here's what i would say
that every group that wants to pack the
court
that believes this court is a bunch of
right wing nuts are going to destroy
america that considered the constitution
trash
all wanted you picked
and this is all i can say
is the fact that so many of these
left-wing radical groups that would
destroy the law as we know it declared
war on michelle chiles and supported you
is problematic for me
thank you
thank you senator graham let me mention
a few points here
congressman jim clyburn was a strong
supporter of michelle childs and now i
believe he is publicly supporting your
nomination
and michelle childs has been nominated
by president biden
to be a circuit judge and she will be
considered by this committee as quickly
as possible
on the issue of guantanamo there are
currently 39 guantanamo detainees
remaining
the annual budget for guantanamo is
540 million dollars per year which means
each of these detainees
is being held at the expense of 12 or 13
million dollars per year
if they would be incarcerated at
florence colorado the super max prison
federal prison the amount would be
dramatically dramatically less
since 911 nearly 1 000 convicted in the
united states on terrorism charges
since 2009
with the beginning of the obama
administration the recidivism rate of
the guantanamo detainees released is
five percent
mr chairman according to the department
director of national intelligence is 31
somebody is wrong here if you're going
to talk about what i said i'm going to
respond to what you said if we close
gitmo and move them to colorado do you
support indefinite detention under the
law of war for these detainees i would
just say uh i'm giving the facts the
answer is no i want to make sure that
it's clear the 31 you referred to goes
back to the year
2009
what does it matter when it goes back to
we had them and they got loose and they
started killing people well i could just
say that uh if you're one of the people
killed in 2005 does it matter to you
when we release them just the president
of your own party released in i'm
suggesting the system has failed
miserably and advocates to change this
system like she was in
was was advocating would destroy our
ability to protect this country we're at
war we're not fighting a crime this is
not some passage of time event as long
as they're dangerous i hope they all die
in jail if they're going to go back and
kill americans it won't bother me one
bit if 39 of them die in prison that's a
better outcome than letting them go and
if it costs 500 million to keep them in
jail keep them in jail cause they're
gonna go back to the fight look at the
freaking afghan government it's made up
of former detainees and gitmo
this whole
thing by the left about this war ain't
working
let me also note that larry thompson who
served as deputy attorney general under
president george w bush oren kerr
special counsel
viet den who served as assistant
attorney general for legal policy in the
george w bush administration
john bellinger and former dc circuit
judge associate general and independent
council ken starr were also prominent
conservative lawyers signing a letter
defending attorneys who represented
guantanamo bay detainees
i don't believe that
we should associate uh that activity as
being inconsistent with our
constitutional values
we are going to represent are going to
this point recognize senator feinstein
and then take a break after she has
completed her questioning senator
feinstein thank you very much mr
chairman and i just would like to
compliment the witness i think you're
doing very well
and as you can see this is a bit of a
tough place
so
a judge
one of the issues that i often discuss
with nominees particularly to the
supreme court is the issue of abortion
i've asked the three most recent supreme
court nominees about this issue and so
i'd like to discuss it a bit with you
today
in 2017 i asked justice gorsuch about
this during his confirmation hearing i
asked him to expand on a comment he had
made about his belief that precedent is
important because it adds stability to
the law
in response justice court gorsuch
reiterated his belief that precedent is
important because and i quote once a
case is settled that adds to the
determinancy of the law end quote he
also stated that roe has been reaffirmed
many times
i also spoke with judge kavanaugh
about this issue in
2018
i asked him whether he believes that roe
was settled raw
and if so whether it was correctly
settled
justice kavanaugh said
that roe quote is settled as a precedent
of the supreme court end quote
he said that roe quote has been
reaffirmed many times over the past 45
years and most prominently most
importantly
reaffirmed in planned parenthood v casey
end quote
and he described casey as having the
value of a precedent on precedent end
quote i most recently spoke about this
issue with justice barrett in 2020
i asked her whether she agreed with
justice scalia's view that roe was
wrongly decided
she committed to quote
obey all the rules of starry decisis end
quote if faced with the question of
whether to overrule casey
she said she had quote no agenda to try
to overrule casey end quote so here's
the question
do you agree
with justice kavanaugh
that roe v wade is settled as a
precedent
and will you like justice barrett commit
to obey all the rules of starry decisis
in cases related to the issue of
abortion end quote
thank you senator
i do agree
with
both justice kavanaugh and justice
barrett
on this issue uh roe
and casey are
the settled law of
the supreme court concerning
the right to terminate a woman's
pregnancy
they have established a framework that
the court has reaffirmed
and
in order to revisit
as justice barrett said
the supreme court
looks at various factors because
starry decisis is a very important
principle
it provides and establishes
predictability
stability
it also serves as as a restraint in this
way on the exercise of judicial
authority
because the court
looks at
whether or not uh precedents are
relied upon whether they're workable
in addition to whether or not they're
wrong
and and other factors as well so i agree
with
both of those statements that you read
well let me add one to that and then
we'll move on
um
i'm particularly interested in the case
of roe v wade
um
roe was decided by nearly nearly 50
years ago
and it's been reaffirmed over a dozen
times since then
so my question is this
does roe v wade have the status of being
a case that is a super precedent
and what other supreme court cases do
you believe have that status
well senator
all supreme court cases are presidential
they're binding
and
they their principles and their rulings
have to be followed
rowe
and casey um as you say have been
reaffirmed by the court and
um
have been relied upon and reliance is
one of the
factors that the court considers when it
seeks to
revisit or when it's asked to revisit
um
revisit a precedent and in all cases
those
the precedents of the supreme court
would have to be
reviewed uh pursuant to
those factors because starry decisis is
very important
thank you
if you are confirmed you would be one of
only two justices who has also served on
a federal district court the other being
justice sotomayor
in your eight years as a trial judge on
the d.c district court you wrote nearly
600 opinions and presided over nine jury
trials and three bench trials
as you know from your service on the
district court it's important for
appeals courts and especially the
supreme court to be clear in their
decisions the clarity is necessary as
you well know for trial judges to
effectively do their job and properly
apply legal precedents that are fair and
consistent
as a district judge you were responsible
for applying precedent from the supreme
court and the courts of appeal to your
case and now as a judge in the d.c
circuit you're drafting those precedents
your experience as a trial judge
is one of your most significant assets
and i just want to add a personal
comment this is a tough place
and you are handling it very well
and
i appreciate your directness
and think that's important
here's a question i have two related
questions
how did you make sure
that you were properly applying the
relevant precedence as a district court
um judge and if you're confirmed to the
supreme court what would you do
to make sure your opinions are clear
so they could be applied correctly by
district courts
thank you senator
as you noted um
in my time as a district court judge i
had um the opportunity to
apply
precedents that
were handed down by the court of appeals
and the supreme court
the district court is bound by the law
as
stated
by those other uh tribunals and
i was
very uh focused on making sure
that i found the right precedence and
applied them
faithfully
as i mentioned uh with respect to my
methodology
part of the process is receiving
information from the parties
in a case and
the parties write briefs and uh in most
cases they identify
the precedents that they at least
believe are applicable
and then um the court does
its own legal research as well
to
determine
whether all of the relevant cases have
been identified
and then
you
look to see
whether there's anything that directly
controls and if it does that's your
answer
in many cases
the precedence might be
a little bit different in certain ways
and you are assessing the party's
arguments in determining within your
proper role
whether what the appellate courts have
said
provides the law of decision for the
case
but what's important as you've mentioned
is
the clarity by which
courts of appeals in the supreme court
um need to operate and so so that the
lower courts can actually follow
the precedence and i'm very conscious of
that as you said as someone who has
had to follow precedent
and i would
think
carefully about that and
use
use my communication skills to ensure
that
the precedents are clear so that lower
courts can follow them
thank you
um i'd like to discuss discuss quickly a
letter this committee received in
support of your nomination from the
international association of chiefs of
police
and as you know this is the world's
largest professional association of law
enforcement leaders and the letter
states
judge jackson has several family members
in law enforcement and we believe this
has given her a deep understanding of
and an appreciation for
the challenges and complexities
confronting the policing profession
during her time as a judge she has
displayed her dedication to ensuring
that our communities are safe and that
the interests of justice are served and
so mr chairman i'd like to put this
letter in the record if i may
without objection thank you
i understand that your brother served
with the baltimore police department for
several years
so here's the question
how if at all
has having several family members in law
enforcement
impacted your understanding of the law
or your approach to your judicial
service
thank you senator um
some of my
earliest memories in addition to
my father at the kitchen table with his
law books
were of my uncles two of my uncles were
career law enforcement
and
one was a detective
uniform detective one was
city of miami police department
officer patrol officer for a long time
before he became the chief and
i remember very well
we would go to my grandmother's house
on sundays and
she would make a big dinner for our
family and my uncles would sometimes
come
off of their shifts
so i see in my mind their uniforms
coming in
and they would always um they'd be
carrying their weapons and they'd take
them off and put them way up high on the
china cabinet so the kids couldn't get
to them and i remember
feeling very proud of them and the
service that they
provided and i think it's probably what
led my brother
who is 10 years younger than i am to
decide that after he graduated from
college he would want to also be in law
enforcement so i'm
very familiar
with
law enforcement the important service
that they provide
the perils
of
being
out on the street protecting and serving
and having a family that cares about you
and worries
about your
safety
um
and so this is not something that is
that is unfamiliar
and i'm very gratified by
the support of
the group that you mentioned in other
law enforcement groups
as i go through this process
i joined this committee in january of
1993
and a few months later we considered the
nomination of ruth bader ginsburg to the
supreme court
justice ginsburg's confirmation
made her only the second woman to ever
serve on the supreme court after justice
sandra day o'connor so we have come a
very long way since then though still
not far enough
women now make up
about 35 percent of active judges on the
federal district bench and 37 percent of
active judges on the federal appeals
courts
judge jackson if confirmed you would
become the sixth woman to ever serve on
the supreme court
you would join justices soda mayor
kagan and barrett on the bench
this would be the nearest we have ever
come
to gender equity on the supreme court
there would be four women on a court
with nine justices
so i have my own thoughts about why
gender balance is important on our
nation's courts but i'd really like you
to tell us all what are your thoughts
on what it means for our country to have
women serve in meaningful members
meaning meaningful numbers on the
federal bench and in particular what it
would mean to have four women serving on
the supreme court for the first time in
history
thank you senator um
i think it's extremely meaningful
um one of the things that
having
uh diverse members of the court
does is it provides
for the opportunity for role models
since i was nominated to this position
i have received so many notes and
letters and
photos
from
little girls around the country
who
tell me
that they are so
excited
for this opportunity and that they have
thought about the law in new ways
because i am a woman because i am a
black woman
all of those things
people have said have been really
meaningful to them and
we want i think as a country for
everyone
to believe that they can do
things like sit on the supreme court and
so having meaningful numbers of
women and um
people of color i think matters
i also think that it it
it supports public confidence
in the judiciary
when you have
different
people because we have such a diverse
society
well i just want to say thank you very
much
this is often a hard place
and how you go through those hard times
i really think
is
the most important thing
and it's pretty clear to me that you go
through hard times by holding your head
up high and doing well so i thank you
very much thank you senator
thank you uh senator feinstein we're
going to take a break uh let's see let's
take 15 minutes starting now and then
we'll return to more questions we'll
have a lunch break this later this
afternoon
in the earlier part of the afternoon
foreign
is
[Music]
wow
okay
[Music]
oh
every hour
are you happy
yes
right
like
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
yes
yes
check check one two one two three
crazy
right
[Music]
great
uh
[Music]
is
oh
okay
testing one two three four five six
seven eight nine ten
nine eight seven six five four three two
one
[Music]
[Laughter]
cheers
is
it is now
once again
um
that
yeah
okay
[Music]
[Music]
oh
hi are you stephen
senate judiciary committee will come to
order um
to have two senators ask questions and
then break for lunch
somewhere around an hour from now
senators cornyn and white house will be
recognized in succession first senator
cornyn
thank you mr chairman
judge i won't want you to do me a favor
um will you nerd out with me a little
bit
uh i will try something and we'll we'll
start with starry decisis yes and i've
never figured out why lawyers speak in
latin rather than in english
when described describing these concepts
by which judges apply precedent
but would you agree with me that um even
under an appropriate story decisis
uh
analysis that dred scott and plessy
versus ferguson were appropriately
overruled by the supreme court
well senator um
i'm not engaged in the actual analysis
but i think it is well established
now
um that the cases
um that overruled
uh dred scott and plessy were um
correctly decided
yeah i mean there is the means by which
the courts can correct their mistakes
correct by overruling
previous decisions
if the various considerations that the
supreme court has
uses to make that determination i'm
satisfied have you ever heard a federal
judge talk about super duper president
or super president
i have not i've never seen it either in
any opinion i've heard it here in the
judiciary committee on a number of
occasions when somebody has a favorite
case or outcome that they don't want to
see the supreme court revisit
um
let me ask a minute obviously your uh
nomination by president biden is
historic
and i congratulate you again
congratulated you previously and i think
it's been long overdue
when clarence thomas
the second african-american
who was nominated to and confirmed by
the supreme court
was nominated the court did you
celebrate that as a historic event
i'm trying to remember where i was at
the time i believe i did yes
when we're talking about staying in your
lane
uh and i appreciate
your responses to a number of the
questions even though i'd love to get
your answer to the question but where
you've deferred answering saying you
want to stay in your lane and not be
seen as a policy maker
would you agree with me that one of the
most important questions under our
constitutional form of government and
the separation of powers is
who decides
in other words some questions are
appropriately decided by judges who are
elected
unelected excuse me served for life
insulated from politics
and other decisions are appropriately
within the
left up to the legislative branch
because they are
we are accountable to the people who can
vote for us they can vote against us uh
if they don't like the policies that we
uh that we enact in legislation would
you agree with that who decides is an
important
question
in terms of determining the appropriate
role for both the judiciary and the
legislature
as a general matter i agree it rarely
comes
directly like that as an issue it's it's
it's usually not a jump ball between
um between the legislature and i get it
you don't get a lot of easy
easy questions
um but you as a general proposition you
won't uh disagree with me
what i'd say is that
the courts
are properly tasked with resolving legal
questions and the cases are
controversies right exactly in every
case and
congress is not similarly constrained we
can pass broad policies comprehensive
legislation
changing policy but
the difference is one of the differences
is the voters can unelect us if they
don't like what we're doing
that is true
i want to ask you what did you study
under lawrence tribe when you were at
harvard i did not
well as you know justice breyer your
mentor wrote a little book called active
liberty
and um
lawrence tribe
who uh was a formerly a law professor at
harvard wrote a review of that book in
the new york times review of books
and the title of it is politicians and
robes
are you familiar with that article i'm
not
well
in the article
professor tribe accuses
justice breyer of engaging in what he
calls a noble lie
and he said
he talks about the morality of resorting
to falsehoods
and delusions to conceal usually from
the masses
but sometimes from oneself the truths
whose revelation would wreak havoc or at
least do more harm than good
professor tribe goes on in criticizing
justice breyer's book
he says in his stubborn stubborn of a
vowel that the court
even with its current far-right super
majority remains an apolitical body
he perpetuates a lie
that is anything
but noble
you've talked about
staying in your lane not making policy
decisions not being seen as political do
you agree with justice breyer that
or with professor tribe
senator um
i believe that judges are not policy
makers that
we have
a constitutional duty
to decide only cases and controversies
that are presented before us and within
that framework
uh judges
exercise their authority to
interpret the law and not make the law
so you would you would agree with me
that judges should not be politicians
yes
let me talk to you a little bit about
some of the
decisions that have been made by the
supreme court over many years starting
perhaps with dred dredd scott
that
adopts the substantive due process
argument
to determine the constitutionality
of
various laws
perhaps the most recent
decision by the supreme court that was a
dramatic departure from from previous
laws in the states and in the nation
was the oberfeld case which
dealt with same-sex marriage
in the opinions that were written there
it was noted that here we are 200 at the
time 234 years
after the constitution had been ratified
135 years
since the 14th amendment had been
ratified
that the supreme court articulated a new
fundamental right
which is a right to same-sex marriage
you're familiar with that case aren't
you
i am
at the time it was noted that 11 states
including the district of columbia had
had passed laws
sanctioning same-sex marriage
but also at the same time there were 35
states who put it on the ballot and 32
of those states decided to maintain the
traditional definition of marriage
between a man and a woman
do you agree with me that marriage is
not simply a governmental
institution it's also a religious
institution
well senator um
marriages are often performed in
religious institutions
well when the when the
you agree with me that many of them the
major religions that i can think of and
their
christianity judaism
islam
embrace a traditional definition of
marriage correct
i am aware that there are various
religious faiths
that define marriage in a traditional
way
do you um do you see that when the
supreme court
makes a dramatic pronouncement about the
invalidity
of state
marriage laws
that it will inevitably set in conflict
between
those who ascribe to the supreme court's
edict and those who have a firmly held
religious belief
that marriage is between a man and a
woman
well senator
these
issues are being litigated as you know
throughout the courts as people
um
raise
issues and so it's i'm limited in what i
i can say about them i'm aware that
there are
cases
i'm not asking you to decide a case or
predict how you would decide in the
future i'm just asking isn't it apparent
that when the supreme court
decides that
something that is not even in the
constitution
is a fundamental right and no state
can pass any law
that conflicts with the supreme court's
edict
particularly in an area where people
have sincerely held religious beliefs
doesn't that necessarily create a
conflict between
what people may believe is a matter of
their
religious doctrine or faith and what
the federal government says is the law
of the land
well senator that is the nature of a
right that
when there is a right
it means that
there are
limitations on regulation even if
people
are regulating pursuant to their
sincerely held religious beliefs
do you agree with marriage is not
mentioned in the constitution is it
it is not mentioned directly no and um
religious
freedom and
is mentioned in the first amendment
explicitly correct it is
do you share my concern that when the
court
takes on the role of identifying
an unenumerated right in other words
it's not mentioned in the constitution
and creates a new
right
declaring that anything conflicting with
that is unconstitutional
that it creates a circumstance where
those who may hold traditional beliefs
like
something as important as marriage
that they will be
vilified
as unwilling to assent to this new
orthodoxy
so senator i understand that concern and
because there are cases that are
addressing these sorts of issues i'm
not in a position to comment about
either my personal views or whether i'm
not asking and i'm not asking you to um
i mean
justice alito in the
in the oberfeld
case
wrote he said i assume those who cling
to the old beliefs will be able to
whisper their thoughts in the recesses
of their homes
but if they repeat those views in public
they will risk being labeled as bigots
and treated as such by government
employers
and schools
so the overfed case we
to nerd out with you again
was
was decided under a doctrine known as
substantive due process correct
if memory serves
yes substantive due process and i think
there might have been equal protection
concerns and
the court the supreme court has uh
applied that some
how mis
fairly mysteriously
by saying it's
created by the confluence of the fifth
amendment
and the 14th amendment
to the united states constitution
but historically it's been applied
in ways that um seem to sanction
explicit policy making
by the courts
for example
the the lochner versus new york case
which i know you talked to senator lee
about in particular
which it was a new deal case which set
limitations on how long bakers could
work in new york the supreme court
struck that down and said it violated
the right of free contract
now lochner as you know was overruled
30 something years later but it's also
been applied in a number of different
circumstances
for example
it's been suggested that dred scott
which treated
slaves as chattel property
was a product of substantive due process
justice hugo black
has criticized the doctrine of
substantive due process
as the arbitrary fiat
of the man or men in power
or the court declaring a law invalid
because it shocked the consciences of at
least five members
of the court he went on to say this use
of judicial review
thus subverts the liberty of government
by the people
overturning laws and enacted by
legislators legislatures who are ansible
to the electorate
rather than a majority of the supreme
court
finally he said
finally for the purpose of my question
he said the adoption of such a loose
flexible
uncontrolled standard for holding laws
unconstitutional if ever it is finally
achieved
will amount to a great unconstitutional
shift of power
to the courts which i believe
justice black that
is and i'm constrained to say will be
bad for the courts and worse for the
country
judge justice jackson why is it
substantive due process analysis
just another form of judicial policy
making
what you've suggested policy making is
not
in your lane or
and you strive to be apolitical
something i i applaud but why isn't
substantive due process just another way
for judges to hide their policy making
under the guise of interpreting the
constitution
well senator
the justices have interpreted the due
process clause of the 14th amendment
to include a substantive provision the
the
um
the rights
to due process they have interpreted
that
to me not just procedural rights
relative to government action
but also the protection of certain
uh personal
um
rights related to
intimacy and autonomy they include
things like
um the the right to rear one's children
um
i believe the right to travel the right
to marriage
interracial marriage the right
to an abortion
contraception treating
treating slaves as chattel property
i'm i don't quite remember the basis for
the
dred stat opinion but but i'll trust you
that that's well the fact is is it not
that you can use substantive due process
to justify basically any result
well the court whether it's conservative
or liberal libertarian or
conservative whatever you would like to
call it's just a it's a mode of analysis
by the court that allows the court to
substitute its opinion for the elected
representatives of the people and um
and
would you agree
the court
has
identified standards for the
determination of rights under the 14th
amendment substantive due process and
who who gives them the right to to do
that
if it's not mentioned in the
constitution
where does the right of the court to
substitute its views for that of the
elected representatives of the people
where does that come from
well the court has interpreted
the 14th amendment to include this
component um the unenumerated
right to substantive due process and the
court has said that
um
that the kinds of things that qualify
are
implicit in the concept of order ordered
liberty liberty excuse me
or deeply rooted in our nation's history
and tradition
those are standards that identify a
narrow
set of
activities
well judge judge the
in the oberfeld case
justice roberts in his dissent noted
that
the court invalidated marriage laws of
more than half the states and orders the
transformation of a social institution
that has formed the basis for human
society for millennia
so
that was the
basis for the institution of marriage is
the practice
for millennia
and the recognition that
marriage was between a man and a woman
now don't get me wrong i'm not arguing
the merits or lack of merits of same-sex
marriage i believe the states and the
elect and the voters can choose what
they will and that's their prerogative
and i think that's legitimate but when
the court overrules
the decisions made by the people as they
did in 32 of the 35 states that decided
to
to uh to to
recognize only traditional marriage
between a man and a woman
that is a act of judicial policy making
is it not
senator the supreme court has considered
that to be an application of
the substantive due process clause of
the 14th amendment right and it doesn't
the scot the
constitution doesn't mention anything
about substance when it talks about due
process the fourth
14th amendment and the fifth amendment
don't talk about substantive due process
it talks about due process of law
correct correct
well
one of the things that concerns me is
here is an example
of
the courts finding a new fundamental
right
that is mentioned nowhere
in the document of the constitution
that's the product of simply court made
law
that we're all supposed to salute
smartly and follow because nine people
who are unelected who have lifetime
tenure
whose salary cannot be reduced while
they serve in office
they did they decide five of them decide
that this is the way the world should be
what other unenumerated rights
do you believe exist
and how
could we possibly anticipate what those
might be
for example
the ninth amendment
says the enumeration in the constitution
of certain rights shall not be construed
to deny or disparage
other rights
retained by the people which suggests to
me that there are
other as yet unidentified
rights out there and somehow some
someday
some court is going to tell us we've
identified an unenumerated right
and we're going to reject the right of
the american people to determine what
the policies ought to be
as regards that right because we
the nine people sitting on the supreme
court have decided
we've discovered a new unenumerated
right and it shall be the law of the
land and no legislature
can pass any law that conflicts with it
what other unenumerated rights are out
there
or can you say
senator i can't say
um
it's a hypothetical that i've
not i'm not in a position to comment on
um
the the rights that the supreme court
has
recognized
as
substantive due process rights
um
are established in in its case law
but
your honor this is not a trick question
oh i understand okay i'm just not i'm
just not in a position to speak to
them but can you understand why why
ordinary
folks wonder
who do these people think they are
and where does this authority come from
i think the authority comes
from
we the people that's the source of
legitimacy of government but when the
courts decide to identify an
unenumerated right and negate
anything that conflicts with it can't
you see how
they might just might feel that this is
illegitimate or
a
sort of policy making that you
that you have
disavowed
by saying that you don't want to make
policy you want to stay in your lane can
you understand the concern
absolutely senator i do understand it
and how do you
and how because i believe the court's
legitimacy is very important
that's why i agree with justice breyer
that notwithstanding what anybody else
says that that should be an aspirational
goal
of the judges because
we're all concerned about the legitimacy
of our institutions
and particularly i would say the
institution of our judiciary
so how do how do you as a judge when you
are approaching
your decisions
how do you
try to avoid
being seen as a policy maker by
embracing doctrines like
substantive due process which is
essentially gives judges carte blanche
to do whatever they want
well senator i've
not had that particular situation but i
do
i have a methodology that is designed to
avoid
my uh importation of
policy perspectives
the judges are constrained in our system
that's part of the constitutional design
and so
in all cases i am
looking
neutrally at the arguments of the
parties and presumably in a case like
this there would be arguments made on
both sides of the issue
your honor if you'll forgive me yes
one reason um i think the supreme
court's different
is because in your previous capacity as
a trial judge of course you were bound
by circuit court precedent
and on the circuit court you're bound by
the supreme court president but as a
member of the united states supreme
court you will be bound by nothing
you will be unaccountable
to the voters
and so
you said you can well respectfully
senator i mean
yes so
you're not going to be able to find the
answer in some law book somewhere you're
going to be presented with a case and
the argument's going to be made this is
an unenumerated fundamental right
and the voters
whatever they've said is irrelevant
because we five members of the supreme
court are going to decide what the law
of the land should be and anybody who
disagrees with us will be labeled a
bigot
or be accused of discrimination
even if those their beliefs happen to
flow from sincerely held religious
conviction like the definition of a
of a marriage between a man and a woman
but you've already told me that you
unders you see why the this is a concern
i see why it is a concern and i would
just say that although the supreme court
is not
you know
bound in the sense of having to
uh apply prior precedent there is starry
decisis in our system
there are now standards in the starry
decisis world that the supreme court
applies
well thank goodness
the supreme court has been willing to
revisit its precedent
or we'd still be living
with plessy versus ferguson
or dred scott
you know one of the things senator
whitehouse and i agree on is
he he and others frequently ask nominees
for the supreme court do you think
brown versus board of education has
settled law
and believe it or not some nominees
won't answer the question
i mean that's it boggles the mind
i tend to think that uh nominees from
both parties tend to be over coached
and not uh and told you can't be if you
don't answer the question you have a
better chance of being confirmed
but some of these things are
obviously settled
and i wish we had a more candid
conversation about the the source of the
power that unelected lifetime tenured
judges have to basically rule
rule america when they decide that
something is an unenumerated
fundamental right
let me uh
in the minute 48 seconds i have
asked you about a specific case
you remember us versus brown
um this was a guilty plea
and where you were asked to
assess a punishment
and at one point in you in the
proceedings you said i'm going to state
for the record however that this court
has a long-standing policy disagreement
with the criminal history guidelines
with respect to the application of the
two-point enhancement do you remember
when you said that
i don't remember that particular um
statement how is that policy
disagreement different from
other disagreements
where you said that you're not going to
get out of out of your lane you're not
going to get into the policy lane yes
senator um
the supreme court
in the sentencing realm
has
made the guidelines the sentencing
guidelines
advisory they used to be
mandatory judges used to have to
calculate the guidelines for sentencing
purposes and then
essentially apply a sentence within the
guideline range
in a case uh called uh
united states versus booker
the supreme court determined that the
guidelines were are advisory now so they
don't have to be
applied in every case you have to
calculate them
but judges have more freedom
to give effect to congress's
the various provisions in the statute
related to sentencing
in booker
and in the in its progeny the supreme
court made clear that judges at
sentencing judge i only have i only have
a limited amount of time so um let me
just close on one other question
and forgive me for interrupting you but
but
there's such a thing as a judicial
filibuster too sorry i was
trying to get to the point let me just
let me just ask you i don't know you
well but i've been impressed by
our interaction and you've been gracious
and charming
why in the world would you call
secretary of defense rumsfeld and george
w bush war criminals in a legal filing
it seems so out of character for you
senator you may have been talk are you
talking about briefs that i or habeas
petitions that
talking about when you were representing
a member of the taliban
and uh the department of defense
identified him as an intelligence
officer for the taliban and you referred
to the secretary of defense and the
sitting president of the united states
as war criminals why would you do
something like that it seems so out of
character well senator i don't remember
that particular reference and i um
was
representing my clients and making
arguments um
i'd have to take a look at what you what
you meant i did not
intend to
disparage the president or the
the secretary of defense
well wart being a war criminal has uh
huge ramifications you could be subject
to the jurisdiction of the international
criminal court and hall before
that international tribunal and tried
for war crimes so it's not a casual
comment i would suggest
thank you
thank you senator cornyn senator
whitehouse
thank you chairman judge jackson good to
be with you again great to be with you
um
i know that a
great many people are
extremely proud that you are here today
i don't know that there are a great many
who are prouder
than bruce celia
and so with your permission i'll take a
moment and offer into the record
some of his comments about you and then
maybe give you a chance to reciprocate
with a word about him but
yesterday in my opening remarks i
mentioned the boston globe article
in which judge celia said that
uh about you
she has absolutely everything you would
want in the supreme court justice she
has all the tickets in terms of her
intelligence her education her work
experience and her demonstrated judicial
temperament
i see some of the same qualities in her
that i saw in ruth bader ginsburg
humility the ability to inspire others
in a quiet way not at the top of her
voice
some people have the capacity to inspire
by example in the force of their reason
intellectually she is very smart very
well informed and she is very
hardworking and focused
she gets the big picture masculine arms
consent that the globe article be
admitted into the record without
objection but he didn't stop there your
honor he went on to wpri
a local station in rhode island and
said about you she's worked hard
she deserves it
and i literally don't think that the
president could have made a better
choice
i think she'll be a terrific addition to
the supreme court
she listens to what other people have to
say
but makes up her own mind she has a very
scholarly approach toward the law
she has a very winning
personality she's kind to the people she
comes in contact with
and she has a certain humility that i
find very attractive in people
we ask unanimous consent that the
statement from uh wpri be put into the
record without objection
um judge telly went on law 360
and said um
i sense that she you
she has the same sort of desire to
achieve consensus and a pragmatic streak
that has characterized some of justice
breyer's work
i think she will be quite balanced i
have not found her to be an ideologue
she understands what the job of being a
judge or being a justice is she wants
very much to do it in the right way
and she will bend her considerable
talents to that direction and won't get
distracted by any extraneous
considerations or side issues
i think the country will appreciate that
and will appreciate that this is a woman
who understands the importance of the
position
and will give 100 of her talents every
day to do that job in the right way
and in accordance with her oath of
office
unanimous consent that that be put into
the record without objection and then
finally the providence journal our home
state newspaper
uh katie mulvaney uh in an interview uh
heard
judge celia say
i think it's a terrific appointment
she's a very thoughtful person and
wonderfully well qualified i'm happy not
only for her
but for the whole country
she listens well she gets the whole
picture
has great respect for the rule of law i
think she's got
the whole package
unanimous consent that that article be
put in the record that objection
so
any reflections on judge celia oh
well um
that was very moving thank you
senator for reading his
lovely remarks
um it's exactly who i know judge celia
to be
always
eloquent always
insightful
um and i'm so flattered by his
um
by his admiration because he is someone
that i
have admired my entire
professional life
he taught me how to
look at issues
very carefully
how to write in a lot of ways because of
the way in which he's so fastidious with
his
opinions and he's been an extraordinary
mentor and role model for me well we are
very proud of him in rhode island as you
know he's on senior status and when he
went on senior status um we're able to
recommend the
uh rosary thompson
to succeed him
of whom i think rhode islanders are
equally proud and she has now gone on
senior status and mr chairman i hope
we'll be considering shortly an
equally impressive biden nominee for for
her position
on an unrelated subject and
it relates to yesterday's activities
you can relax a moment your honor this
will not be a question for you but a lot
was said in this room yesterday about
dark money
by our republican friends to the point
where
um one of the headlines about yesterday
read republicans hammer dark money
groups
and i'll be the first to concede that
there is dark money on both sides
and i hope very much we can get rid of
it on both sides shortly by legislation
but there is a difference i believe
between
a darkmoon interest rooting for someone
and right-wing dark-money interests
having a role
in actually picking
the last three supreme court
justices
now how do we know that they had a role
in doing that well we know because
everybody involved said so
it was pretty
straightforward stuff
president trump said we're going to have
great judges conservative all picked by
the federalist society
that's pretty plain
uh senator orrin hatch former chairman
was asked some of the was said some have
accused president trump of outsourcing
his judicial selection process to the
federalist society i say
damn right
the co-founder of the federalist society
said
that the administration is relying on
the federal society to come up with
qualified nominees
and then don mcgahn who ran the
operation for trump in the white house
said i've been a member of the federal
society since law school
still am so frankly it seems like that
role has been insourced
so
there's pretty clear and pretty broad
agreement that
that selection process
took place out of the public eye
and it appears to have been informed
heavily by dark money interests
they were not alone
in saying this here's
laura ingram on fox news
concerned about
abortion cases coming up before the
court we have six republican appointees
on this court after all the money that's
been raised the federal society all
these big fat cat dinners if this court
with six justices cannot do the right
thing and i think it's time
to circumscribe the jurisdiction of this
court that's the way to change things
finally
so we have people who are in a position
to know what was going on behind the
scenes describing the six republican
appointees on the court who got there
after all the money that has been raised
the federalist society
and all these big fat cat dinners and
threatening that they don't do what she
considers to be the right thing
they'll be punished by circumscribing
the jurisdiction
of the court
that's pretty big talk but it's backed
up by pretty big dollars
if you go back to before this enterprise
got underway
the uh money that came into the federal
society from
what's called donors trust
which has been described as the dark
money atm of the right a koch brothers
affiliated operation
back say in 2002 it got five thousand
dollars
no big deal
by 2019 when this operation was in full
swing
it got seven million dollars
we don't know who the real donor was
because that's the job of donor's trust
is to de-identify
the donor
to launder the identity off the donation
so you can't connect the dots any longer
but seven million dollars i think is
quite a lot of money
and unfortunately the federal society
was not alone
right down the hallway
is something called the judicial crisis
network its offices on the same hallway
of the federal society in the downtown
washington building
although jcn's website and text filings
list a mailing address at a different
location an address shared by multiple
companies
and right down that hallway at that
judicial crisis network there's even
more money pouring
and here's how much
poured into the last three nominations
via the judicial crisis network
21 million dollars related in time to
the gorsuch nomination 17 million
dollars to the kavanaugh
nomination 14 million dollars to the
barrett
nomination
and of course we don't know who the
actual donor is
could be the same donor who knows
and because we don't know who the donor
is we don't know what business they
might have had before the court
and i think it matters when people are
seeking to influence the makeup of the
court
that the public understand
what business they may have before the
court
and anonymity hides all of that
and they didn't stop
with
the
trump nominees
they got up on the air
a dark money group
using dark money
to accuse
biden's supreme court nominee
at that point a player to be named later
judge jackson had not been selected at
this point
of being a tool or stooge of
liberal activist dark money this is a
screenshot from their advertisement
paid for
by
the judicial crisis network
so it's worth understanding for a moment
what the judicial crisis network is and
where it lies
and it lies in a network of
organizations
the um
prevailing way that political mischief
is accomplished these days is with a
paired 501c3 and 501c4
organization the 501c3 gets the tax
deduction the 501c4 gets to participate
in political activity
and sure enough there's an 85 fund and a
concord fund that are twinned together
as a 501c3 and 501c4 organization
and they filed under virginia
corporation law to operate under what
they call fictitious names
that's the term of law under which
they file fictitious names and there's
the judicial crisis network
one of the fictitious names
of the concord fund it has a parallel
judicial education project
that is a fictitious name of the 85 fund
if you're interested in voter
suppression you can move down to the
honest elections project action
another fictitious name
and it's 501c3 twin the honest elections
project
and they've even got new ones that are
less active free to learn action and
free to learn so these are eight
organizations that are essentially one
organization
as lawyers we think from time to time
about piercing the corporate veil
that's corporate veiling that you could
pierce
with a banana
and it runs back and forth with three
groups
called crc advisors crc strategies and
crc public relations that take and send
money to these organizations
as part of the
sort of planning element
you might say that crc advisors crc
strategies and crc public relations this
trio
is the uh command center
and this is the operational torso of the
creature
so i show this all because it
shows considerable effort when somebody
goes to that much trouble
to create that many organizations
to hide how much money they've spent
to control
the nomination process to the court
and it's no small amount of money
in the original
washington post research
they pegged it at 250 million dollars
further research led to testimony in my
court subcommittee
that um the number was actually 400
million dollars
and we have a recent report that we have
in fact checked that the number is
actually even higher than that so i may
amend this number
upward once we're done with our
fact checking 400 million dollars
funding conservative activists
behind the scenes campaign
to remake
the nation's courts
that
operation
is a very different thing
than a group rooting for somebody
and i want to make sure that that
difference is clear
since
our friends on the republican side have
made dark money such a big focus of
their attention already
there is a
drastic difference
between rooting for somebody
and
controlling the turnstile
that decides who gets on the court
controlling the funding
of the political campaigns that pursue
the folks on the court
and actually once you get on the court
we're working now with the judiciary
itself
to try to clean up the mess of that same
anonymous money appearing before the
court
through phony front groups that file
amicus grips and little flotillas
or if it's an important enough case in a
full armada
of
dark money-funded front groups
so that bears not at all on
this nominee but because this is a very
public forum and because we've heard all
that so-called hammering
of dark money groups i wanted to make
sure that it was clear to everybody how
this game is played
and what the difference is
in the way the two sides play it
the um
so now
back to our business judge jackson
um
you
have served as a
um trial court judge
i have you have served as an appellate
court judge i have and with any luck you
are on your way to serve as a supreme
court justice
now
one of the things that is very different
about trial court judges
and appellate court judges
is
what their role is with respect to
fact-finding
it's my
belief from my time spent as a
practicing lawyer
that the role of fact-finding belongs at
the trial court level
that's where you can look the witnesses
in the eye that's where the evidence can
be
amassed that's where the trial judge has
the responsibility of sifting through it
if there's a jury then the jury of
course is the ultimate fact-finder but
if you're in a non-jury trial the trial
judge is the fact-finder
then the case goes up on appeal and it
comes up with a record
a record of fact
in the case
and in my view
that record of fact that comes up to the
appellate court
is actually a constraint
on the power of the appellate court to
go wandering off
the court is obliged
to consider the appeal based on the
factual record that was adduced
in the district court
so
you having lived in both of those houses
the trial courthouse and the appellate
court house
tell me a little bit about what that
change meant to you as you went from
being
a trial judge
to an appellate judge
thank you senator um it is a really big
difference
as you mentioned
at the trial court
you are on the ground level
have filed the case
you have all of the issues usually um at
the trial level because
you'll have the complaint if it's a
civil case and
um there'll be a lot of
litigation
about the development of the facts in
the case
in civil cases you have a period of
discovery in many cases that
is really about the development of the
record what actually happened
um
in this case
sometimes there's even a trial um and
that too is a part of the development of
the facts in the case because the jury
will be charged with the responsibility
of determining
what happened who's guilty for example
if it's a criminal case or who's liable
if any
if it's a civil case and sometimes there
are even
questions presented to the jury
that they have to determine the facts
at the appellate level as you said there
is
already a record and the court is
looking
primarily at the law the legal
principles that guided the decision
below
based on the factual record and
importantly at the appellate level
there are standards of review
that the court of appeals
applies when it decides
how to
review whether or not to reverse or
affirm
the judgment of the lower court
and i've
been very mindful especially as a trial
judge of the standards of review when i
was prepping lawyers for
oral argument before appellate courts
um i would often say please don't
quarrel with the facts
unless you have
a knock down case
because if you want to get the appellate
court to relitigate the facts you're up
against the harshest
standard review available the clearly
erroneousness test
and clear error is no small thing
um outside of that narrow finding by an
appellate court that somehow the
district court got it wrong
filtered through that clear error
standard are there other circumstances
in which
it's proper
for
appellate courts
to do their own independent fact-finding
outside of
the record of the case that they're
reviewing
i'm not aware of any uh there might
there may be but
in my experience
the fact finding is done at the trial
level the court of appeals only looks at
facts
under standards like clear error
um and so therefore the record is
usually
set and established by the time you get
to the court of appeals yeah
and i think that um it's actually one of
the constraints on the judiciary
that they don't get to go and do
free-range
fact-finding
they have to be tethered to the record
of the actual case before them it's
related to the case or controversy
requirement
that is correct senator
and in that regard um
civil juries are
i think um
something that americans have prided
themselves on for a long time
you go back to the colonial days
and the civil jury was one of the
immediate imports from england every
colony set up civil juries
when the crown tried to interfere with
the
civil juries in the colonies it became
castle's bellai for the revolution it
was in the declaration of independence
of what the king had done wrong that
offended
the colonists and caused the revolution
and the
documents around the founding
and around the creation of the
constitution all reflect
passionate belief in the importance of
the jury including the civil
jury
which as you may know from your
experience in
the
trial court
is getting to be a rarer and rarer
creature
and in fact there are trial judges who
have written about how do we serve how
do we keep the civil jury alive
and i'd like to hear your thoughts about
whether there's more to the civil jury
than just a fact-finding appendage
of the trial judge
whether it was seen by the founders and
whether it belongs in our constitutional
structure
as a part of the
responsible self-governance
that was established by our constitution
uh yes senator um
it
is
part of our ordered liberty it is
um a mechanism by which
citizens
can participate
in
governance they can
be called upon by the court to
[Music]
sit in judgment of other
people in the community
and it was something that
was a part of the democratic
vision
of the founders from from the very
beginning
blackstone was one of the
legal
experts
who the
early lawyers of the united states
relied on i suppose
there were lords who had nothing but
blackstone's commentaries in the bible
on their shelf
and blackstone described the jury as
having a role
to make sure that the
power and
clout
of
big and powerful interests
could be protected against
that it was a
refuge from the power of what he called
the more powerful and wealthy citizens
um
there was long experience in government
of corruption
whether it was getting to a chief
executive and getting them to
do things your way for improper reasons
or whether it was controlling
a legislature a legislative body
but the jury is fundamentally different
because they don't stick around they're
there for one case in one case only then
they disappear
you can't fix them so that they
decide your way over time
and if in that one case you try to fix
them you've likely committed a criminal
offense
tampering
with the jury is a pretty significant
thing is it not
it is if anybody tampered with the jury
of yours how would you respond oh very
seriously
so the jury lives in a protected
environment from a lot of the political
power
and the
danger of corruption
that
the elected branches
um often suffer
and
do you have thoughts about the
importance of the civil jury
in that regard
as the bastion where
people can go
where they'll get
a square deal from regular citizens
and can stand toe to toe with the
lawyers for however big or mighty an
opponent they may have
with
almost no danger let's put it that way
little danger lessen danger
of the fix being put in
well certainly the jury
system is designed in that manner
that citizens are brought in from
the community
when we
pick juries
we ask as judges do any of you in this
pool have any connection
to anyone
you know i've i've so you screen them
for conflicts of interest you screen
them
heavily that's part of the
what we call the void or the sort of
we don't do that with people who come to
congress
well in in the courts they come with
their conflicts of interest often right
on their lapels
sometimes hidden in their back pockets
but jury is not so correct not so and in
fact that would be a reason to exclude
someone from the jury and we even ask
um you know do any of you as judges we
say do any of you know me
um and if you do you'll have to let me
know and and be removed because the idea
as you've indicated is to get people
from the community who have no
connection to the case
and can
hear the evidence that's presented in
the courtroom and the arguments of
the lawyers and make a decision
that is unconnected to any sort of
personal interest they might have
protecting the jury
against the dangers of bias or
corruption
giving the parties before it a clean and
fair shot
yes senator
so
with any luck you will be on the
supreme court before long and i hope you
will
remember all of this
because it seems to me that the court
has been on something of a campaign to
deprecate and diminish
the
civil jury
including by allowing big corporations
to build into their
standard contracts buried way down in
the fine print
that
folks often don't read and even if they
do read it they'll never get through the
phone tree
to find somebody to complain about it
try to strike it out of the contract
it's a take it or leave it
adhesion proposition
and they build into that
that you've given up
your right to a jury
your seventh amendment right to a civil
jury it's right actually in the bill of
rights
and i cannot think of another right that
the court pays less attention to
or throws more readily under the bus
if you read
the mandatory arbitration cases
there's rarely a mention of the seventh
amendment
and it seems to me that it flies in the
face of the purpose of the jury
to allow the citizens of the greatest
power and wealth or today corporate
citizens
to actually be able to take on the
ability on their own through contracts
that the
customer has no chance
to negotiate the employee has no chance
to negotiate actually take away that
right
that was at the heart of our founding
without a squeak
of objection or even notice
by the court and i think it's created a
dramatic shift
in power towards big corporations
and i think it has harmed innumerable
employees
and customers so i'm
extremely happy that you have been able
to answer these questions with such
clarity
about the role and the history and the
value of the civil jury and its
importance not just as your
fact-finding adjunct but is an important
part of our constitutional structure
part of our structured liberty as
americans i wish you well i'll see you
again tomorrow and uh thanks so much for
your patience with all of us here today
thanks senator whitehouse and let me
just say a positive word to follow up
this committee
in the last few weeks has passed
legislation signed into law by president
biden
which in cases of sexual harassment
provide that individuals who are
complaining have the option of a jury
trial
despite
efforts to steer them into mandatory
arbitration it is the decision of the
complainant
the venue that they will seek
i think that is a step in the right
direction and with passed out of this
committee on a bipartisan basis and so
i'd like to ask everyone to consider
returning promptly at 1 30 for the much
anticipated senator lee of utah
yes
oh
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
i'm korean
okay
um
yes
[Music]
hi honey
[Music]
oh
bobby come on
thank you
[Music]
all right
okay
thank you
obviously
yes
that's what i'm saying
[Music]
y'all
yes
[Music]
there you go
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
um
[Music]
yes
yeah um
[Music]
here
[Music]
yes
sincere
is
okay
you know yes
yes
hello
now
you follow me
uh
let me do that right
yes
[Music]
all right
lily
lily
oh
um
okay oh just now
okay i just didn't want her to get
yeah
oh okay okay i thought you were going to
your seat
okay
um
here
um
just trying to get
um
hello
[Music]
i don't have a problem
oh
okay
i know
yes
okay
looks like
is
this one here
okay
okay
no
yes
oh
but i gave you
yes
all right
the trucker the trucking convoys
right now
yes
oh
oh
we're pretty sure
[Music]
[Music]
okay
oh
this is
anywhere
um
we're gonna get you later
yes
[Music]
five
yes
mike
[Music]
oh my god
thank you
[Laughter]
i wish you guys
yes
so the judiciary committee will resume
i would like to make a statement um
in terms of some research that was
undertaken during the break
judge jackson earlier senator cornyn
said that you had called former
president george w bush and secretary of
defense donald rumsfeld a quote war
criminal unquote
i noticed a little surprise in your
reaction and i was surprised by the
allegation
during your service as a public defender
you filed several habeas petitions
against the united states
naming former president bush and former
secretary rumsfeld in their official
capacities
you were advocating on behalf of
individuals who argued they were
civilians wrongly classified as enemy
combatants of the united states
and your filing was part of your
professional responsibility to
zealously advocate for your clients
in those petitions the individuals
raised more than a dozen claims for
relief
one of which was an allegation that the
government had sanctioned torture
against the individuals which
constituted war crimes under the alien
tort statute
the alien tort statute allows courts to
hear cases for alleged violations of the
law of nations or the treaties of the
united states apparently this is what
senator cornyn was referencing so to be
clear
there was no time where you called
president bush or secretary rumsfeld a
quote war criminal close quote
did you want to answer senator no thank
you that was correct thank you very much
we now recognize senator lee
thank you uh mr chairman thank you judge
jackson for being here
i want to talk uh
today about some things you you heard
about yesterday there was a lot of talk
uh from members of this committee about
judicial philosophy
i want to talk a little bit about what
that means and and why it's important
we'll start with
what it means at least to me
one of the things that you you heard
from a lot of members of the committee
uh whether they couched it in terms of
judicial philosophy or not
relates to the idea that justice
should be blind that justice properly
administered within our system is blind
and that therefore individual justices
and judges serving in article 3 courts
should should be blind in the sense that
they are able to see
and understand
and interpret the law understand what
the law
is
while understanding that
the idea of what the law should be is
left to other branches of government not
to the judiciary in this respect we
recognize that blind justice and blind
justices those who are blind to the
things they're supposed to be blind to
or those
willing to recognize that if there is a
policy flaw in the law
and if there's a policy change that
needs to be made it's not the role of
the court to change it that belongs to
two different branches of government
primarily to congress
this of course requires judicial
restraint it requires judicial humility
and it gets back to what i was
describing yesterday uh when i referred
to justice barrett
drawing on the analogy from the odyssey
of odysseus binding himself to the mast
of the ship
most of us refer to this judicial
philosophy as textualism
contextualism is neither liberal or
neither liberal nor conservative it's
neither republican nor democratic
it it uh it's just the approach that
says
what the law says matters and the job of
the jurist is to look at the text and
figure out what the text
means to ascertain
the original public meaning of the text
in question
well i doubt there are any members of
this committee who would disagree with
the idea that justice should be blind in
this respect and that policy changes
need to be made by the political
branches of government primarily by the
legislative branch and not by the courts
you did hear some statements that i
think are uh at least a little bit at
odds with that concept of justice
um
one one of my colleagues mentioned that
you should interpret the constitution in
a way that works for the people of today
fair enough you certainly don't want to
interpret the constitution in a way that
doesn't work but again that's not the
objective the objective is not to
ascertain good policy uh the objective
is to ascertain what the law requires
you were urged to consider the effects
of the court's actions on people's lives
uh there again and so far as this
relates to policy it's not really the
job of the courts
you were admonished that you must quote
be able to see the real people at the
other end of the court's rulings like
americans who are one supreme court
decision away from losing their health
insurance or one court decision away
from the ability
to make their own health care choices
and the list goes on and on
now that type of judicial philosophy
uh would would have you step into the
role of policymaker and decide what the
law should be rather than what the law
is
you also heard quoted a couple of times
yesterday quoted or paraphrased or
otherwise referenced
federalist 78 in which alexander
hamilton
refers to the difference between law
between will and judgment
will
as expressed by hamilton
refers to what the law should be
judgment pertains to what the law is
the judicial branch
has the latter power but not the former
the legislative branch as the former but
not the latter
judge jackson i'd love to get your your
thoughts on on this discussion about
what it means what blind justice is why
that's important let's start with with
this formulation of it though
does does the law determine the outcome
of a case or does the outcome of the
case determine
the law
thank you senator
the law determines the outcome of case
and so
anytime you're looking at a case and
you're looking at the outcomes for
ordinary americans for day-to-day
americans if you're looking beyond
the scope of deciding that case and if
you're looking even within that case
beyond
what the law says you would be stepping
into a province of a different branch
is that right i believe so the law and
the facts
of the case determine the outcome of
cases
i think that's that's an accurate
statement it's important to emphasize
this this is also something that
hamilton describes in federalist 78
where he goes on to say anytime you
start to see the courts start to
exercise will instead of judgment
the result is is supplanting the will of
the people as expressed through their
elected representatives uh through the
courts and that tends to undermine the
the whole system you see there's a
reason of course why we give life tenure
to
article three judges and justices and
that is because we want to make sure
that they have
the power the authority the discretion
and the confidence to issue a decision
that they might not be comfortable with
in fact a judge who always agrees with
and is always comfortable with his or
her own opinions is as justice scalia
used to say not a very good judge
so we wanted them you
all to have confidence in being able to
make the right decision even knowing
that you
and the public at large might be
uncomfortable with the result it
produces
congress makes laws that you won't
always agree with
congress
is accountable to the people at regular
intervals you can fire every member of
the house of representatives every two
years you can fire one third of us in
the senate every two years
we insulate
judges and supreme court justices from
that same accountability
precisely for this reason
it's because political accountability is
so important
this is born out in the judicial oath uh
uh one of the oaths that you'll take if
confirmed to this position as an
associate justice in which
you'll you'll swear or affirm that
you'll administer justice without
respect to persons and that you'll do it
faithfully and impartially i read this
to mean that you do it without
consideration of external
circumstances external considerations uh
policy considerations
or or otherwise
now
this relates to uh um some
interaction that you and i had when you
came before this committee for your
confirmation to the u.s court of appeals
for the dc circuit where you now said
in connection with that hearing i
submitted some questions to the record
uh in which i asked you um whether to
what extent the constitution protects
rights that are not
enumerated in the constitution itself
and and if so to specify uh what those
rights were you responded by citing a
number of cases including griswold
versus connecticut roe vs wade loving
versus virginia and a handful of others
you also suggested that the ninth
amendment uh uh uh
was something
was a source for such rights
unenumerated rights the ninth amendment
of course states
uh quote that the enumeration in the
constitution of certain rights shall not
be construed to deny or disparage others
retained by the people
judge jackson what specific rights has
the supreme court identified as flowing
from the ninth amendment and by that i
mean specifically from the ninth
amendment rather than
uh um in sort of an also ran list
of other features
of the constitution that might back up a
particular ruling
what rights has the constitution
identified as flowing specifically from
the ninth amendment
thank you senator um the supreme court
as i understand it has not um identified
any particular rights flowing directly
from the ninth amendment although as you
said the text of the amendment suggests
that
there are some rights
that are not enumerated right right it's
very it's very existence and its very
language uh suggests that which opens up
other questions as to how those are to
be resolved uh it's led to considerable
debate among uh scholars and jurors
alike as to whether to what extent in
what way
uh this is enforceable those rights are
enforceable by the courts
but
how would we go about deciding that how
would
how would
jurists go about deciding this question
appropriately
in other words
would it be would it be more appropriate
to say
um we will ascertain the existence of
rights protected
by the ninth amendment
based on the contemporaneous
understanding
at the time of the ratification of the
ninth amendment
or would it be more open-ended
to protect rights that we think are
important today
thank you senator
the supreme court now
um very clearly has
uh determined
that
in order to interpret provisions of the
constitution we look to the time of the
founding
and we ascertain
based on
what
the
original public meaning of the words the
constitution were at the time
sometimes that yields a
particular answer other times you may
have to look to practices historically
from that time
but that that is that would be the way
in which you would go about interpreting
the ninth amendment
could it also be that it leaves this
to be decided at the at the discretion
of the supreme court itself
in other words not not based on any
historical precedent but based on what
the supreme court justices themselves
deem appropriate at the moment
i don't think so um why and why is that
because
the
way in which the supreme court
interprets the constitution is with
reference to the meaning of the text at
the time that it is one of the
constraints as i mentioned um
in terms of my own way of
handling interpreting the law the one of
the constraints is that you're bound by
the text and what it meant to those who
drafted it
at the time got you yeah
now
on february 1st of this year uh
president biden said that he was he was
looking uh for a supreme court nominee
uh this was as i recall right after
justice breyer announced that he would
be stepping down and before he had
announced to
whom he might nominate
that he was looking for a nominee quote
with quote a judicial philosophy that's
more one that suggests that there are
unenumerated rights to the constitution
and all new members mean something
including the ninth amendment
um
so do you share the judicial philosophy
that president biden described in that
statement
senator i i haven't
reviewed that statement but i have not
discussed anything about enumerated
rights unenumerated rights with
with
the president yes
did uh so did president biden uh ask you
either about your judicial philosophy
more broadly separate and apart from the
ninth amendment or
or
ask you uh
uh about your approach to the ninth
amendment he did not
in a in a primary election debate
that he had as a presidential candidate
in nevada in 2007.
joe biden stated quote
i would not appoint anyone
who did not understand that section 5 of
the 14th amendment and the liberty
clause of the 14th amendment provided a
right to privacy that's the question i'd
ask them
if that is answered correctly
that that is the case
that it answers the question which means
they would support roe versus wade
i assume
uh his reference to the liberty clause i
assume he's referring to the to the due
process clause of the 14th amendment uh
in context that appears to be what he's
he's saying
did president biden ask you
whether you agreed with his analysis of
the 14th amendment
uh as it relates to
the right to privacy he did not
tell me this uh
when we look at any provision of the
constitution
um
one of the many reasons it's it's it's
helpful
to look at the original understanding in
addition to the
the fundamental reason that you
described
um
it can can help us understand
what motivated it and it can help us
understand
the actions of those who voted within
congress to propose
text
uh to be amended to the constitution and
those who voted to ratify it
um
we've got a number of amendments
including the amendment that he referred
to in that last quote i read
that that had a
an understanding at least um
an understanding that include included
certain thou shalt not for government
the equal protection clause i think is
is
a provision
of the 14th amendment that people
understood
among anything else it might do
restricts government's ability to treat
people differently on the basis of race
consistent with the equal protection
clause of the 14th amendment when is it
permissible
for government to treat a person
differently on the basis of race
thank you senator
the supreme court has
interpreted the equal protection clause
as you say to
generally prohibit
classifications on the basis of race and
it said says that
those classifications are to be
rigorously scrutinized
they
um
are strict scrutiny which is a standard
that applies that looks at the purposes
of the government and the means by which
the government
seeks to achieve any end related to such
classification
they the government would have to have a
compelling
interest in making that classification
and
the means that it selects would have to
be
narrowly tailored to achieve that
interest and so those compelling
interests
can't be for light or transient reasons
they it can't just be something like we
we feel like it in other words correct
and the reason for this is because um
well number one it's
bad
it's bad for anyone to treat another
person differently on the basis of race
it's especially bad when government does
it because
there's not exactly equal bargaining
power
when you're dealing with the
the relationship an individual has with
government uh
by definition
it's a particularly unfair form of
discrimination when it's government
doing it governments have
enforcement officers they have armies
they have um the means of enforcing
their will and their laws and that's one
of the reasons why it's so important
what about under under statute uh
consistent with title vii of the civil
rights 1964 was it permissible for an
employer
to treat an an
employee or a prospective employee
differently on the basis of his or her
race
by statute under title vii it is uh
generally impermissible
and and permissible only in very narrow
circumstances
i believe so and the statute itself has
some restrictions in terms of to whom it
applies right the employers some
exclusions in terms of uh religious
employers for example
uh uh not being able to discriminate on
the basis of race but it exempts
religious employers
within certain spheres in order to be
able to protect um
that
religious employer's
discretion to operate within its faith
and the rules of its faith
and by doing that it it makes that much
clearer by making that distinction it
makes that much clearer that um
discrimination on the basis of race and
employment is not something
that the law smiles upon nor should it
let's um let's talk about the commerce
clause for a minute if that's all right
now at the time of the founding
founding fathers
didn't foresee and
almost certainly could not have foreseen
the invention of radios televisions
airplanes the internet
and telephone networks
and yet
all of those things are governed
by federal law
by federal law
and not by state law
why is this constitutional
well senator
the
commerce clause
was
initially interpreted by the supreme
court to be very
broad to allow for
a
federal
regulation of interstate commerce
and the growth
of the economy in this country
um
but over time the supreme court has made
clear that the commerce clause
uh limits the federal government that
there is limited authority under the
commerce clause
the state of the law now is such that
the federal government through the
commerce clause is only permitted to
regulate
channels of interstate commerce
instrumentalities of interstate commerce
and activities that substantially affect
interstate commerce and with respect to
the third category the supreme court is
made clear
in the
lopez case and in morrison
that non-economic activities
are not covered by commerce clause
authority and in the
nfib case the
aca case
the supreme court made clear that
inactivity is also not covered
um
and not authorized under the commerce
clause right
in most of the most of the items that i
identified in in my question in fact uh
all of them i believe would fall under
the category
of um channels and instrumentalities of
interstate commerce we're dealing
with interstate airways airwaves
waterways uh
networks things like that
uh things that depend for their
existence for their effectiveness
on their operation
interstate
such that they couldn't
uh no one could effectively regulate
them and preserve their core function
unless that was federal
those fit into the category of the
channels and instrumentalities
with the the
the
third item that you describe the the
substantial effects interstate commerce
um
is there much of a limiting principle
there i mean with
you referred to lopez and morrison uh
and nfib versus sibelius uh to my
knowledge those are the only three cases
the supreme court uh has decided
since it its ruling in 1937 on lrb
versus jones offline steel which
essentially created the modern uh
substantial effects case at the the
modern substantial effects standard
the only three instances in which the
supreme court identified
as outside the commerce clause authority
something that congress had enacted
are these meaningful constraints in your
view or are they examples of congress
just getting reckless and sloppy in the
way it drafted things uh
some some have argued for instance that
uh as long as congress doesn't get
reckless and sloppy it can do whatever
it wants out of those do you have any
view on that
well um these cases come through the
courts so i'll be general um
the
fact that congress is limited in its
authority
under the commerce clause is established
law it is a
fundamental principle of our
constitutional
order
and
those
limits that the supreme court has
recognized do carve out
categories of
activity
that congress is not permitted the
federal government is not permitted to
regulate
non-economic activity is a category
inactivity is a category
now
the supreme court is also through the
commerce clause
establish rules for things that the
states may not do this is referred to as
the you know the so-called dormant
commerce clause
uh the dormant commerce clause
acknowledges the power of congress the
exclusive domain of congress as being
regulating interstate commerce there's
no federal cost of action to allow for
the invalidation of a state law
under the commerce clause it's been
something that's been adopted by the
courts
is that an appropriate exercise of of
the court's
judicial power or does that amount to
de facto legislation on the part of the
courts
well senator i wouldn't characterize it
i know that that's what
the supreme court has permitted the
dormant commerce clause is
um
is
a principle
that supports
the
interstate
nature and regulation and authority of
the federal government and so states are
not permitted
under that
doctrine
to discriminate against other states to
preference their own commerce in a way
that interferes with interstate commerce
i want to turn back for a moment to a
line of um
of inquiry you had with
with senator durbin earlier today when
you were talking about
your sentencing in these child
pornography cases i want to make sure
that i understand
your your
answer there
um
if i understand it you you were making
the argument
that your concern was that the the laws
in this area didn't adequately take into
account
the transfer of these materials
by electronic means
to be
re transmitted received and stored
through computers is that my
understanding that correctly
well senator my uh the point that i was
making was that the sentencing
commission back when i was
part of it and even since
tasked with the responsibility to
evaluate and make recommendations and
look at the data and information about
cases has looked at the operation of the
child pornography guideline
not so much the the statute but the
guidelines
which the congress has
tasked the sentencing commission
with developing and there are aspects of
the child pornography guideline
that congress and legislation has
required
it required certain enhancements to be
included in the guideline and some of
those enhancements
the data is now revealing
um
don't take into account
the the change in the way that that this
um horrible offense is
now committed
but the fact that it's easier to commit
the offense shouldn't diminish the
severity of the punishment should it i
mean any more than the
more widespread availability of certain
drugs the more widespread availability
of certain weapons might er
when you surely wouldn't argue for a
lower sentence
when certain things become easier in
other criminal contexts so why is this
one different well
the sentencing enhancements that are in
the guidelines are designed
to help courts differentiate
between
different levels of culpability
congress will say this is an offense
whatever it is and the maximum penalty
is x
and and in most cases the range is
between zero and something like 20 years
that congress gives when it establishes
a penalty
the point of the guidelines is to help
judges figure out where in that range
between 20 00 and 20 years
a particular defendant
should be sentenced
and the guidelines have gradations in
them
that relate to various aspects of the
commission of the crime
sorry so
so
the commission does data to it does uh
data gathering and research to figure
out how crimes are committed
and what
gradations should matter in terms of the
range of culpability because the problem
of not doing that or of getting it wrong
is that
you you are not able to adequately
assess and determine
the differences among offenders on the
on the scale i understand that and so
but in in these cases as i understand
all ten of the cases that we've reviewed
on on record where you've sent someone
to it for a child pornography conviction
in all 10 of those cases you you
departed from the guidelines uh and
deported downward
it's hard for me to understand departing
from those in every case you've got
because it's not supposed isn't a
departure supposed to be grounded in
uh a finding that it's outside the
heartland of of of cases
in that range in cases of that sort
yes senator and as i said before these
are horrible cases that involve
terrible crimes
and the court is looking at all of the
evidence consistent with
congress's factors for sentencing the
guidelines are one factor
but the court is told
that you look at the guidelines but you
also look at the nature and
circumstances of the offense the history
and characteristics of the offender
there are series of of factors
in the cases you are also getting
recommendations
and in most of the cases i haven't
pinned it all down but in most of the
cases if not all of the cases the
government is asking for a sentence
below the guidelines because this
guideline system is not
doing the work in this particular case
understood
section 230 of the telecommunication of
the communications decency act
provides
a degree of immunity for tech companies
operating in the space of being online
interactive service providers
it immunizes
them from certain causes of action that
would otherwise
apply against them
would it be within congress's authority
to condition
the receipt and
availability of
section 230 immunity
on those online interactive service
providers
operating
as a public forum
that is
not discriminating on the basis of
viewpoint or the
the viewpoint of those posting on them
would that be within our authority
senator i can't um comment on a
particular
issue about whether or not it is
um
constitutional or or not
but the
criteria that you identify
it would be relevant i think as to
whether or not the government is
seeking to regulate along
viewpoint lines under the first
amendment that is something that is
generally impermissible
thank you mr chairman
thank you very much senator lee senator
klobuchar thank you very much chairman
and senator grassley uh welcome again
judge a wonderful family
they all seem to be awake throughout
this entire hearing
um i um just wanted to before i start
wanted to uh get it something uh senator
lee was talking about it's not the
dormant commerce clause
um but i really appreciated early on how
you talked about these child pornography
cases a former prosecutor could totally
see where you were coming from
when you talked about looking at these
cases as a mom
and a judge
and would it surprise you at all that
other judges uh including a number of
them that were uh supported by our
uh colleagues on the other side of the
aisle uh have given out similar
sentences in uh child pornography cases
no senator it would not surprise me
because these cases
are horrific and
there's a lot of disparity
because of the way the guidelines are
operating in this particular area
but in every case in every case
um
that i handled involving these
terrible crimes i
looked at
the law
and the facts
i made sure that the victims um the
children's
perspectives were represented
and i also
imposed prison terms and significant
significant um supervision and other
restrictions on these defendants well
thank you and i just also want to note
and i know others have brought this up
the
letter of support from the fraternal
order of police in which they said from
our analysis of judge jackson's record
in some of her cases we believe she has
considered the facts and applied the law
consistently and fairly on a range of
issues there is little doubt that she
has a temperament and elect legal
experience and family background to have
earned this appointment we are reassured
that should she be confirmed she would
approach her future cases with an open
mind and treat issues related to law
enforcement fairly and justly and that
matters
a lot to many of us now
i want to go back to something i was
talking about yesterday and that is why
today's hearing is so monumental
including that it is occurring at a time
when we as americans have been reminded
again uh due to the courage of
ukrainians thousands of miles away that
we can never take our democracy or for
that matter or courts for granted
it is also happening at a time when we
are seeing each other for the first time
after a two-year pandemic connecting to
each other again
um and i hope this moment uh will be a
moment where uh we
see a renewed interest in our democracy
we respect each other's rights and views
and that we see that we are not a nation
of 300 plus million silos uh instead or
we are a nation committed to this idea
that what unites us as americans is much
bigger than what divides us
and so in that context you come before
us with this incredible strength legal
acumen
grace under pressure that you have
demonstrated today
and you also come before us as we've
noted as the first black woman to be
nominated following 115 justices uh who
have been confirmed and i will note uh
of the 115 justices 110 have been men
and i um actually once reminded a late
night show trevor noah of similar issues
in the u.s senate uh in fact in the
history of the u.s senate of the nearly
2000 people who have served only 58 have
been women and he responded that if a
nightclub had numbers that bad they'd
shut it down
but today judge we're not shutting
anything down uh not the court not the
senate and you are opening things up and
i think one of the things your
nomination presents is an opportunity to
address a decline in the public's
confidence
in our court
and
increasingly many if you see public
opinion polls see the court as
over-politicized or out of touch
at the same time we've seen an alarming
rise in threats targeting members of our
judiciary for just
doing their jobs how do you think we can
work to maintain the public's con
confidence in the court
what do you see a role in that
thank you senator
public confidence in the court is
crucial
as has been said here earlier
that the court doesn't have anything
else that that is the
the key to our legitimacy in our
democratic system
and
i am honored to accept the president's
nomination part
um because i know it means
so much to so many people
it means a lot to me
um
i am here
standing on the shoulders of
generations
of americans who never had anything
close to this kind of opportunity
um from my grandparents who had just a
grade school education but instilled in
my parents
the importance of learning
and my parents who i've mentioned here
many times already
who were the first in their families to
get to go to college
so this nomination
against that backdrop
is significant
to to a lot of people and i hope that it
will bring confidence it will
help inspire people
to understand that our courts
are like
them that our judges
are like them
doing the work being part of our
government
i think it's very important
very good i think along those lines your
wonderful mentor justice breyer
i quoted him about how he said
um
we can help maintain public acceptance
of the court and these are his words we
can do it best by helping ensure that
the constitution remains workable in a
broad sense of the term specifically it
the court can and should interpret the
constitution in a way that works for the
people of the day like as you know uh
it's i think section two article two
section two uh doesn't refer to the air
force because we didn't have an air
force back then
so are there things about the
constitution that of course
as we've gone along have been
interpreted to meet
the moments of our time what do you
think justice breyer means when he says
the constitution should be interpreted
in a way that works for the people of
today and you think a justice can be
both pragmatic and objective and respect
history
i do
and i think that the justices have
demonstrated that some of their recent
opinions
uh have had to deal with
modern technology technologies that did
not exist
at the time of the founding so
for example the
riley case
carpenter case these were
fourth amendment decisions
in which the court was asked to
determine whether or not
it violated the fourth amendment for the
police to
um search someone's cell phone without a
warrant
or for the police to use uh gps location
data to
determine where someone
had been without a warrant
and obviously those technologies did not
exist
but what the court did
was it looked back at
the time of the founding and determined
what the reasonable expectations of
privacy were
related to
uh the the term unreasonable searches
and seizures which appears in the
constitution
and having assessed what that meant
back then they could use those
principles
to decide
whether or not a cell phone is like
someone's home these days with all of
the information and all of the things
that are stored there and the court
determined
that it was a violation of
the fourth amendment
that the police officers needed a
warrant and they did so with reference
to what the constitution meant
in history
very good
uh you know you were
viewed as a judge and you talked about
this a bit yesterday that writes lengthy
opinions
that believes you should spell things
out and uh believes in being transparent
is that a fair characterization that is
that is okay good i'm sure your clerks
know that
um and
uh i want to talk about something me
that's a bit the opposite and that's
something that some have termed the
shadow docket
and that includes decisions that the
court makes on an expedited basis that
are usually unsigned and issued without
oral argument or full briefing in the
last few years we've seen the court
increasingly deciding cases in this way
often over the descent of maybe three or
four of the justices last term the court
granted 20 requests for emergency relief
a historically high number
10 years ago in the october term of 2011
the court granted only six requests in
an entire
year
um
when do you think it's appropriate for
the supreme court
to grant emergency relief use this
docket when are the circumstances
that warrant this
and
i think you know these decisions have a
profound effect on people's lives i'll
just use one example last fall in a one
one-paragraph decision a majority of the
court refused to stop the enforcement of
a texas law that severely restricts a
woman's access
to abortion in that case even chief
justice roberts objected to the court's
decision to let the law take effect
calling the statutory scheme not only
unusual but unprecedented
as someone who believes in transparency
could you talk in general about
when you think this shadow docket should
be used when emergency relief should be
given and how if it's overused it could
undermine public confidence in the court
thank you senator
well
there there's a balance that the court
has to
consider and that it
um
insofar as uh on the one hand
it has always had an emergency docket
the need for flexibility the ability to
get
answers to uh the parties at issue
is something um that's important
in our system
um
on the other hand the court has also
considered
the interest in
allowing issues to percolate
allowing other courts to
rule on things
before they come to the court
and
i am not privy at the moment
to
the justice's views and
why and how they're using
um
the emergency docket in these cases
if i was fortunate enough to be
confirmed i would
look at those issues
um but it's it's an interesting and
important
set of issues
okay
um
you know i think just another example of
this by the way is
um the day before wisconsin's primary
election and april 6 2020 uh right
um as the first um beginnings of some of
the health
orders that came out with the beginning
of the pandemic the court issued a 5-4
decision halting a district court's
order allowing voters extra time to cast
their absentee ballots um so that they
could avoid uh waiting in line to vote
and back then people literally got
covered with election workers and the
like because of this
and again i'm not going to
belabor this point but i think some of
this is these decisions that are made
that don't reflect some of the careful
consideration that you have made in many
of your
decisions as a judge but speaking of
voting i'll ask you one question on that
front since the supreme court
gutted the section 5 pre-clearance
regime of the voting rights act in its
decision in shelby county
the d.c circuit
has not seen
many voting rights cases however as you
know justice ginsburg dissented in that
case describing the right to vote as the
most fundamental right in our democratic
system do you agree that the right to
vote is fundamental
senator the supreme court has said that
the right to vote is
the basis of our democracy that it is
the right upon which all other rights
are
essentially founded um because in a
democracy there is
um
one person one vote and
um
and
there are
constitutional amendments that relate
directly to
uh the right to vote so it is a
fundamental right in our
democracy yes i know that's how justice
barrett answered that question as well
in her
uh recent hearing
i'm going to turn to an area that uh
senator lee and i uh we both chair the
subcommittee on anti-trust and so it's
near and dear to my heart so i thought
it'd spend a little time it usually gets
relegated to the second round but i'm
i'm putting it up on the docket here
u.s anti-trust law has been described as
a comprehensive charter of economic
liberty
and
i agree and effective antitrust
enforcement plays a critical role as you
know in protecting consumers and workers
promoting innovation ensuring new
businesses have an opportunity to
compete it actually
from really early on uh in our country's
history uh has been a very important
part of assuring uh the capitalism works
and
um in january uh for the first time
since the dawn of the internet
the senate passed a tech competition
bill out of the judiciary committee it's
a bill that senator grassley and i lead
many of the members of this committee
supported
the bill
16 to 6 vote it's called the american
innovation and choice online act it's
now headed to the senate floor i'm not
going to ask you about that bill
obviously but i want to put this in some
context
while tech monopolies have seized from
50 to 90 percent market share in major
parts of their business lines
uh it is clear to me when you look at
the plain language of the sherman act
clayton act
laws that are in place that these
monopolies are not okay
however court rulings for decades in
antitrust have created some major
obstacles uh to taking on these cases
and it's not just court rulings uh it is
on us uh with as i said the dawn of the
internet decades having passed it is on
us the senate and the house to update
our laws this year to give enforcers the
resources to do their jobs something you
if confirmed would
not have a role in but uh the role of
the courts is also very critical uh you
have been nominated to replace justice
breyer who came to the court with a
strong background in antitrust law i
know you handled a case you and i
discussed it in in my office i think it
got um i think it got uh decided the
merger was abandoned
so you didn't have to rule on the merits
of it it was back in
2017
a ftc challenge um but i'll just quote
something that justice breyer once said
he told this committee if you're going
to have a free enterprise economy then
you must have a strong and effective
antitrust law do you agree with justice
breyer's
statement and how would you characterize
the goals of our antitrust laws
well thank you senator
the antitrust laws protect competition
and as you said um therefore protect
consumers and
competitors and the economy as a whole
and the
um
sherman act and the clayton act are
broad in their
um
in the in their statements and their
protections and there's a lot of
precedent in this area
um if
i were
confirmed
i would use my methodology to
look at the precedence in these areas to
ensure that any legislation that i was
considering
is interpreted
according to the text consistent with
congress's intent
um
and
um
in the area of antitrust
that is
ensuring that there is
consumer
protections
very good um
and just to
play it out a little bit um
since the 1980s the court in cases like
trinco and credit suisse ohio the
american express has really made it
increasingly difficult to enforce the
antitrust laws
and protect competition
and during that same time and i know
many of my colleagues know this we have
seen a rise in
industry consolidation market power and
not only in tech
with companies like google and amazon
and facebook and apple but also across
our economy really in everything from
pharma uh to cat food to caskets
um
do you uh what role do you think that
congressional intent should play uh in
the court's interpretation of the
anti-trust laws and i i say that because
i think that
we're dealing with some cases where
justices have actually substituted their
own
ideologies for the intent of congress
in originally passing the laws
and i think it was justice suiter who
once said before this committee
when we are dealing with antitrust laws
we are dealing with one of the most
spectacular examples of delegation to
the judiciary that our legal system
knows
and he added this certainly a respect
for legislative intent has got to be our
anchor for interpretation
so what role do you think congressional
intent should play in the court's
interpretation of the antitrust laws
thank you senator
so i've interpreted a number of statutes
in my
near decade on the bench
and in every case
the text of a statute is what the court
looks at in order to ascertain
what the legislature intended
and
that is
important because as i've said courts
are not policymakers and judges
should not be importing their own
policy preferences it's
judges are
restrained in
our constitutional scheme
um in order to affect the will of
congress in terms of their
interpretation of the laws
okay thank you i'm going to turn to
another uh topic and that's freedom of
the press uh new york times v sullivan
1964 case
uh we have recently witnessed as you
know unprecedented attacks on
journalists and journalism
whether it's violence overseas recently
learning losing
sadly members of the press just in the
last month in ukraine
or threats and intimidation at home
this is very concerning to me given the
important role of the first amendment my
dad
was a newspaper reporter
so the issues hit home for me
can you talk about your view of the role
of journalists in our democracy
thank you senator
journalists and freedom of the press is
protected by the first amendment it is
about the dissemination of information
which is necessary for
um
a democratic form of government
the supreme court has held as much and
that was
the basis for the court's
uh determinations in protecting
the press from liability
in new york times versus sullivan and
and it's progeny
okay
um as you know that uh ruling was a
unanimous ruling in support of the first
amendment and the court held
that when newspapers report on public
officials are only liable for untrue
statements that are published with
knowledge or reckless disregard for
whether the statement was false
the court in sullivan based its decision
on our country's quote profound national
commitment to the principle that debate
on public issues should be uninhibited
robust and wide open
that's their quote and it recognized
that quote erroneous statement is
inevitable in free debate end quote and
quote must be protected if the freedoms
of expression are to have the breathing
space that they need to survive
do you agree that those principles are
just as relevant today as they were when
the supreme court first decided uh new
york times v sullivan
new york times b sullivan is the
continuing binding precedent of the
supreme court and it
does state the principles that
the court has determined are
undergirding uh the first amendment
right to
um free press okay and last summer
actually in
barisha v lawson the supreme court
declined to review a case in which the
11th circuit applied new york times v
sullivan justice thomas and justice
gorsuch each dissented from the decision
not to grant cert arguing that the court
should reconsider its holding in
sullivan how would you approach a case
that sought to limit or overturn the
central holding in new york times v
sullivan
thank you senator
any time the court is
asked to revisit a precedent
there are
criteria that the court uses to decide
whether or not to
overrule
a precedent
new york times versus sullivan is a
precedent and starry decisis
um is very important the principle that
um
courts that the supreme court should
maintain
its precedence
um
for predictability and stability in the
law
if the court is asked to revisit a
president
its
criteria what it looks at
are whether the president is wrong and
in fact egregiously wrong the court has
said
um whether there's been reliance on that
precedent
whether
the
there are other cases that are
similar to the precedent or that relied
on the precedent that have now shifted
so that the precedent is no longer
on firm footing
whether or not the precedent is workable
sometimes the the supreme court will
issue a ruling and determine later that
it's not actually doing what the court
intended
and whether or not there are new facts
or a new understanding of the facts
those
various criteria are what the court
looks at to decide whether or not to
overturn a precedent and they would be
what um i would look at if i were
confirmed to the supreme court
thank you i was recalling as you spoke
about starry decisis at one of your
first nominations hearing for the
district court and you actually um
in answer in response to one of my
questions you said starry decisis is a
bedrock legal principle that ensures
consistency and impartiality
of judgments and
um i think as you know by how you've
talked more broadly about this um
moving off of the first amendment
questions you throughout the court's
history um starry decisis
um has been so key and the court has
relied on it to maintain stability in
the law reform its impartiability
impartiality as a
former justice i know senator durbin
just read a very famous book about him
minnesotan
justice harry blackman
who actually justice breyer succeeded on
the court
said in his concurrence in planned
parenthood v casey about the court's
decision to uphold roe v wade he said
what has happened today should serve as
a model for future justices and a
warning to all who have tried to turn
this court into yet another political
branch
what role do you think that starry
decisis plays in protecting the
independence of the judiciary and
avoiding the perception
that the court is acting as another
political branch
i think it plays a very important role
um as a doctrine
that keeps
um
keeps shifts from happening in the court
that
as um
as i've previously mentioned it's very
important to have stability in the law
for the rule of law purposes so that
people can order themselves and predict
um
predict their lives given what the
supreme court has already said
and
if there were
massive shifts
uh every time a new justice came on or
every time new circumstances arose
there would be a concern
that public confidence uh would be
eroded and so starry decisis is a very
important doctrine
that the supreme court has established
and um
and it's one that furthers the rule of
law in this country
thank you very much uh well that's a
good way to end uh judge jackson and i
do see uh senator cruz awaiting in the
wing so by coincidence and it looks like
he has things he's putting up of charts
by coincidence i uh have a was going to
put on the record and since he's here it
makes a lot of sense from the judge that
you clerked for
senator cruz uh uh judge ledeck who's
now retired and i know you were very
close to him
and uh he actually submitted a letter on
on your behalf
um judge jackson and said in this letter
and he's an appointee of george h.w bush
um similar to uh judge griffith who
introduced you yesterday and i've been
very impressed by uh the support you've
had from
retired judges obviously not appropriate
for current judges but retired judges
appointed by both democratic and
republican presidents as well as the
bipartisan votes that you have gotten
through
the u.s senate for your other positions
but in this letter
the judge former judge ludwig
says that you are eminently qualified
to serve on the supreme court of the
united states
and then he actually says republicans
and democrats alike should give their
studied advice
and then their consent to the
president's nomination
and he adds republicans in particular
should vote to confirm judge jackson so
i thought that might be a good segue
center cruise
to your to your questions so i asked
chairman that the letter of support
from
former judge ludwig
who employed senator cruz as a trusted
law clerk be
admitted to the record without objection
thank you very much judge jackson thank
you
senator klobuchar finds a minnesota
connection to almost everything very
proud of the fact that justice blackman
was born in nashville illinois okay he
was a lawyer at the mayo clinic as we
know and spent a lot of time
a lawyer in minnesota when he was chosen
to the supreme court but thank you for
pointing that out
and now to the great state of texas
senator cruz
thank you mr chairman
judge jackson welcome uh congratulations
thank you
you and i have known each other a long
time we have uh we went to law school
together we were on the law review
together we were a year apart
uh happily so i hope senator
we were not particularly close but we
were always friendly and cordial we were
uh and you and i had a very positive and
productive meeting in my office uh where
we discussed a number of things
including you were there with with
former senator doug jones
uh and we discussed how he and i and a
number of other senators had for for two
different years
participated in reading aloud on the
senate floor
uh dr martin luther king jr's letter
from birmingham jail which is one of the
truly great
uh
advocacies for civil rights our nation
has seen and and you and i talked
together
uh about our shared admiration for dr
king
uh
when senator grassley questioned you
earlier he asked in particular about dr
king's
speech uh on on the steps of the lincoln
memorial
where he said most critically i have a
dream that my four little children will
one day live in a nation
where they will not be judged by the
color of their skin
but by the content of their character
do you agree with what dr king said in
that speech there
i do senator
as we were discussing it uh you
referenced in my office a speech that
you gave in january of 2020
uh at the university of michigan school
of law
uh and after our discussion i pulled a
copy of your speech and read the speech
in its entirety and there were elements
of the speech that i thought were really
powerful
and let me say your your
opening remarks yesterday were were
powerful and inspirational as well and i
think
you and your family the journey you have
taken to becoming a federal judge to
becoming a federal court of appeals
judge i think demonstrates the
incredible promise and the incredible
opportunity this nation offers all of us
as i read your speech at the university
of michigan law school however
there was a portion that surprised me
and in particular in that speech you
referenced the work of quote
acclaimed investigative journalist
nicole hannah jones and her and again
this is a quote from the speech
provocative thesis
that america was born
that the
provocative thesis that the america that
was born in 1776 was not the perfect
union that it purported to be
and indeed
ms hannah jones in her 16 19 projects
describes
the central thesis of the 1619 project
which the new york times laid out
as a revisionist look of history
revising american history and miss
hannah jones described her central
thesis as quote
one of the primary reasons the colonists
decided to declare independence
was because they wanted to protect
the institution of slavery
now that claim is a highly contested
historical claim
um
do you agree with miss anna jones that
one of the primary reasons the colonists
decided to declare independence is
because they wanted to protect the
institution of slavery
thank you senator
when i gave that speech at the
university of michigan
i was asked
to speak on martin luther king day
and
every year they have a martin luther
king day speaker
and i gave a speech about
black women in the civil rights movement
most of the speech if not all of the
speech was focused on african-american
women
their contributions to the civil rights
movement
unsung contributions in many cases
and then some of the more recent
african-american women
who have made claims who have
done things in our society
one slide was of
ms
a journalist as you say who made that
statement and i called it provocative
it is not something that i've studied it
doesn't come up in my work i was
mentioning it because it was at least at
that time something that was
talked about and and well known uh to
the students that i was speaking to at
the law school
so are you aware that that since the
1619 project came out that it has been
roundly uh refuted by very respected
historians including gordon wood of
brown university including james
mcpherson
uh of princeton university mcpherson
called it a quote
very unbalanced one-sided account which
lacks content and perspective
and indeed it was so thoroughly refuted
that the new york times quietly altered
the digital version to remove
references to 1619 as the year
of america's true founding and the
moment america began were you aware of
that i was not
so let me ask you
related to the 1619 project which i
believe is is deeply inaccurate and
misleading
um
1619 project is quote closely
intertwined with a movement that is
called critical race theory
uh
critical race theory as you know
originated at you're in my alma mater at
the harvard law school
uh
in your understanding what what does
critical race theory mean what is it
senator my understanding is that
critical race theory is
um
[Music]
it is an academic theory
that is about the ways in which
race interacts with
um various institutions it doesn't come
up in my work as a judge it's never
something that i've
studied or relied on and it wouldn't be
something that i would rely on if i was
on the supreme court
so critical race theory as you know has
its origins in the critical legal
studies movie movement which also came
from harvard law school
from a number of critical legal studies
professors crits as they were known when
we were in law school
who are explicitly marxists and they
find their origins in marxism although
critical legal studies frames
society as a fundamental battle between
socioeconomic classes
critical race theory frames all of
society is a fundamental and intractable
battle
between
between the races it views every
conflict as a racial conflict
um
do you think that's an accurate way of
viewing society in the world we live in
senator i
don't think so um but i've never studied
critical race theory and i've never used
it it doesn't come up in the work that i
do as a judge
so so with respect i find that a curious
statement
because
um
you gave a speech in april of 2015
at the university of chicago in which
you described the job you do as a judge
and you said sentencing is just plain
interesting because it melds together
myriad types of law criminal law and of
course constitutional law critical race
theory so you described
in a speech to a law school what you
were doing as critical race theory uh
and so i guess i would ask what did you
mean by that when you gave that speech
with respect senator um the quote that
you are mentioning there
was about sentencing policy it was not
about sentencing
i was talking about
the policy
determinations of bodies like the
sentencing commission when they look at
a laundry list of various
academic subjects as they consider what
the policies should be okay
vice chair of the sentencing commission
so let me ask again what did you mean by
because that was an official
responsibility of yours
what i meant by what you were doing was
critical what i meant was that there are
a number of that that
uh slide does not show the entire
laundry list of different
uh academic disciplines that i said
relate to sentencing policy but none of
that relates to what i do as a judge
so let me ask you a different question
is is critical race theory taught in
schools is it taught kindergarten
through 12th
senator i don't
know i don't think so i believe it's an
academic theory that's at the law school
level
okay um
as you may recall during the
confirmation hearings of justice amy
coney barrett there was a great deal of
attention paid to the fact that justice
barrett served as a board member in the
board of trustees of a religious private
school and and the press focused very
intensely
on the views of that school
in your questionnaire to this committee
you disclosed that you are similarly on
a board specifically the board of
trustees for the georgetown day school
and that you've been a board member
since 2019 and you're currently still a
board member is that correct that is
correct
uh in regard to the georgetown day
school you've publicly said
quote
since becoming a member of the gds
community seven years ago patrick and i
have witnessed the transformative power
of a rigorous progressive education that
is dedicated to fostering critical
thinking
interdependence
and social justice
when you refer to social justice and the
school's mission on social justice what
what did you mean by that
thank you senator for allowing me to
address
this issue
georgetown day school has a special
history that i think is
important to understand
when you
consider
my service on that board
the school was founded in 1945
in washington dc at a time
in which
by law there was racial segregation in
this community
black students
were not allowed in the public schools
to go to school with white students
georgetown day school is a private
school
that was created
when three
white families jewish families
got together with three
black families
and said that despite the fact that the
law
requires us to separate
despite the fact that the law is set up
to make sure that black children are not
treated the same as everyone else we
are going to form a private school
so that our children can go to school
together
the idea of equality
justice
is at the core
of the georgetown day school mission and
it's a private school such that every
parent who joins the community does so
willingly with an understanding that
they are joining a community that is
designed to make sure that every child
is valued
every child is treated
as
having inherent worth and none are
discriminated against because of race so
judge jackson all of us will agree that
that no one should be discriminated
against because of race
when you just testified a minute ago
that you didn't know if critical race
theory was taught in k-12 i i will
confess i i find that statement a little
hard to reconcile
with the public record because if you
look at the georgetown day schools
curriculum
it is filled and overflowing with
critical race theory
that that among the doc the books that
are
either assigned
or recommended
uh they include
critical race theory and introduction
uh they include
the end of policing and an advocacy for
abolishing police
they include how to be an anti-racist by
ibrahim kendi
they include literally stacks and stacks
of books and i'll tell you two of the
ones that were most stunning
they include a book called anti-racist
baby
uh by ibrahim kindy
and
their portions of this book
that i find
really quite remarkable one portion of
the book
says babies
are taught
to be racist or anti-racist there is no
neutrality
another portion of the book
they recommend to babies confess
when being racist
now this is a book that is taught at
georgetown day school to students in
pre-k through second grade so four
through seven years old
um
do you agree with this book that is
being taught with kids that the babies
are racist
senator
i do not believe
that any child
should be made to feel
as though they are racist or though they
are
not valued or though they are less than
that they are victims that they are
oppressors i don't
believe in any of that but what i will
say
is that when you
asked me whether or not this was taught
in
schools critical race theory
my understanding is that critical race
theory as an academic theory is taught
in law schools and
to the extent that you were asking the
question i understood you to be
addressing public schools
georgetown day school just like the
religious school that justice barrett
was on the board of is a private school
okay so you agree critical race theory
is taught at georgetown day school i
don't know because the board is not um
the board does not control the
curriculum the board does not
focus on that that's not what we do as
board members so i'm actually not sure
well and i'll note that the board is is
chaired by professor fairfax your
college roommate who introduced you
yesterday so the two of you serve on the
board together
um another book that is on the
summer reading for third through fifth
grade is a book called stamp for kids
again by ibram kendi
i read the entirety of the book and i
will say it is
an astonishing book
on page
33 it asks the question
can we send white people back to europe
that's on 33 that's what's been given to
eight and nine years old
it also
on page
115 says the idea that we should pretend
not to see racism is connected to the
idea that we should pretend not to see
color it's called color blindness
skipping ahead here's what's wrong with
this it's ridiculous skin color is
something we all absolutely see
skipping ahead so to pretend not to see
color is pretty convenient
if you don't actually want to stamp out
racism in the first place
now what this book argues for is the
exact opposite of what dr king
spoke about on the floor of the lincoln
memorial and and
are you comfortable
uh with with these ideas being taught to
children
as young as four and in respect to the
first book as young as eight and nine in
respect to the second book
senator i have not reviewed any of those
books any of those ideas they don't come
up in my work as a judge
which i'm respectfully here
to address
in my work as a judge
which is evidenced
from
my near decade on the bench okay good i
am then then let's go back to your work
as a judge
as was noted
in the first slide
you discuss sentencing as being related
to
critical race theory
and earlier there's been some back and
forth as democratic senators have tried
to address your sentencing patterns as
it concerns child pornography
and i'll confess judge jackson as look
as i listen to your testimony i believe
you are someone who is compassionate i
believe you care for children obviously
your children and other children
but i also see a record
of activism and advocacy as it concerns
sexual predators
that stems back decades and that is
concerning
wrote your note on the harvard law
review
on
sex crimes
uh the your note is your major academic
work on the law review and yours is
entitled prevention versus punishment
towards a principled distinction
in the restraint of related release six
sex offenders
and in it
you argue and i quote
a recent spate of legislation purports
to regulate release sex offenders by
requiring them to register with local
law enforcement officials
notify community members of their
presence undergo dna testing and submit
to civil commitment for an indefinite
term
although many courts and commentators
herald these laws as valid regulatory
measures others reject them as punitive
enactments that violate the rights of
individuals who have already been
sanctioned for their crimes
under existing doctrine the
constitutionality of sex offender
statutes depends upon their
characterization
as essentially preventative rather than
punitive and what you go out go on to
explain is if they're viewed as punitive
they are unconstitutional if they're
viewed as preventative
they are not
and throughout the course of your
note you argue they should be viewed as
punitive and therefore
unconstitutional indeed in the second to
last page you go through each of those
four categories
you say requirements that sex offenders
register
may or may not be unconstitutional
depending upon whether quote
sex
in which sex offenders have no privacy
right and registration information or
blood samples so you suggest that may or
may not be constitutional you raise
doubts about it
and then you raise very significant
doubts
about community notification
and you heavily suggest that civil
commitment for sexual predators is
unconstitutional
do you still agree with the sentiments
you expressed in in your law school now
respectfully senator those are not the
sentiments that i expressed in my law
school note
my law school note
was about
sex offender registration laws which at
the time were relatively new
as uh you know from our time in law
school one of the things that law school
students do is they look for new
developments in the law and they try to
analyze them that's something that makes
for good fodder for a law school note
my note
which came out in 1996 was shortly after
there were
new megan's laws
and the point that i was making was not
that the laws were
bad that the laws were wrong i was
trying to assess
something that is
sort of fundamental in terms of the
characterization of the laws
i didn't say that they were
unconstitutional one way or the other
what i was trying to assess
was how they are characterized some
some
courts would look at those laws and call
them preventative and that has a certain
set of
consequences
some courts would call them punitive and
that has a certain set of consequences
and what i was trying to do is figure
out
how to make the determination whether
they were punitive
or preventative
well your note argued that they were
punitive and i would note that that view
uh there have been some on the bench
that have advocated that uh the supreme
court in 1997 decided a case called
kansas versus henrik's in which it
upheld kansas's civil commitment statute
that was a 5-4 vote this has been a
question that has been
close at the supreme court
and
i would note beyond that that in terms
of the prevalence of these statutes all
50 states in d.c have registry
requirements
47 states have community notification
requirements
all 50 states have dna or blood banks
for sex offenders requirements
and 20 of the states the federal
government and dc have laws that allow
for the indefinite detention of sex
offenders
i would note in the state of texas a
street state court of appeals relying on
very much the the same sort of reasoning
you advocated in your note struck down
texas's sexually violent predator civil
commitment law at the time i was the
solicitor general of texas i personally
argued that appeal in the texas supreme
court and the texas supreme court
unanimously reversed the court of
appeals
and upheld our statute and and if the
views you advocated in law school
prevailed
civil commitment laws
across the country would be struck down
releasing sexual predators
and under the argument community
notification and dna bank laws could
well be struck down as well is that
is that an outcome that that should
concern people
senator my note wasn't advocating for
the striking down of those laws
my note
was trying to identify criteria that i
thought could be applied consistently
to determine whether the laws were
punitive or preventative but with
respect either character you argued that
they were punitive and you further say
in the note if they're punitive they're
unconstitutional i was looking at four
different kinds of laws and not all of
them did i say we're punitive okay so
let's take civil commitments laws
uh
if you look at civil commitment laws
right now the ucla school of law
williams institute estimates more than 6
300
sex offenders are currently detained in
civil commitment programs
if the view you advocated prevailed
presumably those six thousand three
hundred sex offenders would be released
to the public
is that an outcome that should be
concerning
senator
in law school when i was writing a note
i was looking at a brand new set
of laws that had not previously been
enacted in any jurisdiction they were
new
and i was assessing at the time as law
school students do
what
criteria i thought might be used by
courts to make a determination in the
future as to whether or not they should
be treated as punitive and therefore not
unconstitutional but as therefore
um
ones that come carry with them certain
rights
versus
excuse me preventative
those okay
jeff jackson so you've you've pointed
that these were reviews in law school
and listen i will recognize that all of
us when we are students may have views
that that as
time and maturity
passes on we may change but what
troubles me is this was not just
a law school view it's one that has
continued so when you were vice chairman
of the sentencing commission you
expressed significant concerns
that the white house has argued that
your quotes were taken out of context so
i want to provide the full context of
your quote because
you said
yes i want to ask you about the means by
which we can distinguish more or less
serious offenders i know that all of you
have sort of touched on that mr futrell
you talked about going from singular to
one-on-one to group experience i'm just
wondering if there's some sort of
inevitable and natural progression from
one stage to the other such that you
could say that the least serious
offenders are in the singular experience
stage i guess my thought is in looking
at some of the testimony that other
people will have later in the day i was
surprised at some of the testimony with
respect to the motivation of offenders
and we're talking about child
pornography offenders and that there are
people who get involved with this kind
of activity who may not be pedophiles
and who may not be necessarily
interested really in the child
pornography but have other motivations
with respect to the use of technology
and being in the group and you know here
are lots of reasons perhaps why people
might engage in this and so i'm
wondering whether you could say that
there is a that there could be a less
serious child pornography offender who
is engaging in the type of conduct in
the group experience level because their
motivation
is the challenge or to use the
technology they're very sophisticated
technologically
but they aren't necessarily that
interested in the child pornography
piece of it
now now i find that a
pretty remarkable argument that people
in possession of child pornography
are not actually interested in the child
porn they're not pedophiles they're just
interested in technology is is that
i wanted to provide the whole quote
because the white house said that
portions of this were used out of
context so this is your entire quote
um
do you agree with that sentiment that
there is some
meaningful population of people who have
child pornography but but are not in
fact
pedophiles or getting
getting satisfaction from it
thank you senator for allowing me to
address
what appears to be a question
that i was asking in the context of a
hearing on child pornography you've
provided the entire quote and it looks
as though i was asking that of someone
not taking that position and the
position that i've taken in all of my
sentencings involving
child pornography offenders
is to ensure
that despite
the
attitude and um
view of many of the offenders who came
before me when i was a trial judge that
they were just lookers that they weren't
really harming anyone that they were
curating their collections and they
never touched a child
i made sure that they understood
that notwithstanding their
uh collecting behavior that they were
causing significant harm so judge
jackson all right you you raise your
actual sentencing and i think that's
very productive let's let's take a look
at your actual sentencing
and you've had 10 different cases
involving child pornography
um
these are the cases that there are two
us versus battery and us versus
can
for which the government did not make a
recommendation and you said
earlier when when chairman durbin was
trying to preempt this line of attack
you said it's a sickening and egregious
crime which i very much agree with
um and you said the guidelines lead to
extreme departures okay
uh let's look at what the prosecutors
are asking for and i would note that
this was in the district of columbia
where prosecutors are far more liberal
than many of the prosecutors in this
country
and in every case in which so united
states versus hess there was a mandatory
statutory minimum of 60 months and you
imposed 60 months because you had no
discretion
uh in united states versus nickerson
there was a mutual agreement of the
parties to 120 months and that's what
you imposed
in every other case
united states versus chasin the
prosecutor asked for 78 to 97 months
you imposed 28 months 28 months
is a 64
reduction
in united states versus cooper the
prosecutor asked for 72 months
you imposed 60 months that was a
17
reduction
in united states versus downs the
prosecutor asked for 70 months you
imposed 60.
that was a 14
reduction
in united states versus hawkins the
prosecutor asked for 24 months you
imposed three months that was an
88
reduction in united states versus savage
the prosecutor asked for 49 months you
imposed 37. that was a 24
reduction in united states versus
stewart the prosecutor asked for 97
months you in post 57 that was a 41
reduction
every single case 100 of them when
prosecutors came before you with child
pornography cases
you sentenced the defenders to
substantially below not just the
guidelines which are way higher but what
the prosecutor asked for on average of
these cases
47.2 percent less now you said you made
sure
the voice of the children
was heard do you believe in a case
like united states versus hawkins
where the prosecutor asked for 24 months
and you sentenced the offender to only
three months do you believe the voice of
the children is heard when a hundred
percent of the time
you're sentencing child pronoun those in
possession of child pornography to far
below what the prosecutor's asking for
yes senator i do
could you explain how i will
a couple of observations one is that
your chart does not include
all of the factors that congress
has told judges to consider including
the probation office's recommendation
in these cases judge jackson we don't
have those probation the committee has
not been given the probation officer's
recommendation we would welcome them i
would look mr chairman i would love to
see those
the second thing i would say
is that
i take these cases
very seriously as a mother
as someone who as a judge has to review
the actual evidence in these cases and
based on congress's requirement
take into account not only
the sentencing guidelines not only the
recommendations of the parties
but also things like
the stories of the victims
also things like
the nature and circumstances of the
offense and the history and
characteristics of the defendant
congress
is the body that tells sentencing judges
what they're supposed to look at
and congress has said
that a judge is not playing a numbers
game
the judge
is looking
at all of these different factors and
making a determination in every case
based on
a number of different considerations and
in every case
i did my duty
to hold the defendants accountable in
light of the evidence and the
information that was presented to me
in a hundred percent of the cases was
the evidence less than the prosecutors
asked for
senator the evidence in this these cases
are egregious
the evidence in these cases are among
the worst that i have seen and yet
as congress
directs
judges don't just calculate the
guidelines and stop
judges have to take into account the
personal circumstances of the defendant
because that's a requirement of congress
judges have to consider things like
the victims and when i was talking about
making sure that victims
circumstances are heard it was about my
sentencing practices
that i could show victims being heard
with respect
thank you mr chairman
in 2012 the sentencing commission
on a unanimous bipartisan basis
issued a report recommending changes to
sentencing for non-production child
pornography which is the subject at hand
offenses because of widespread concern
among judges and other stakeholders for
example
70 percent of surveyed judges said the
guideline ranges for possession receipt
offenses were too high 71 percent said
the mandatory minimums were too high
notably the report was supported by
every member of the commission i believe
the question which senator texas was
referring to
was part of the proceedings that led to
that commission report unanimous
convention bipartisan basis commission
report
mr chairman very briefly i would ask
unanimous consent that the books i
referenced be entered into the record
without objection
senator coons
thank you chairman durbin ranking member
grassley
judge jackson
good to be with you good to be with you
senator i i'd like to take a few minutes
if i could and just
give you a chance to address some of the
issues just raised
my colleague suggested that you've never
sentenced a defendant in a child
pornography case
consistent with what the government
requested what the prosecution requested
but according to my staff's research
that's just not true
so let me briefly ask you about three
specific sentencing cases do you
remember usv nickerson you sentenced
charles nickerson jr to 10 years in
prison
exactly what the government requested i
do senator do you remember usv fife you
sentenced him to 20 years in prison
exactly what the government requested
i do senator and do you recall usv negin
you sentenced him to 37 months in prison
exactly what the prosecution requested
i do senator so
in these three
cases it's also true that the government
the prosecution requested below
guidelines sentences would that seem
surprising to you at all
it would not
and is that because overwhelmingly
nationwide in 70
of cases and in your district 80 percent
of cases
downward departures from the guidelines
are the norm
that is correct senator so
to the extent there seems to be some
concerted effort to try and uh
characterize you as being soft on crime
or uh somehow
unconcerned about child safety uh i i
just wanted to take another moment um
and give you a chance to respond to that
um as a parent uh as the member of a
family that's had several
members who've served your brother your
uncles in law enforcement
could you share a bit about how having
loved ones who serve as law enforcement
officers in one case a detective on a
sex crimes unit
has had an impact on your sense of the
balance of
uh justice and mercy in the case of
ensuring that we hold to account those
who commit crimes against children
thank you senator
as a mother
these cases involving sex crime crimes
against children
are harrowing
what i think is important to understand
is that trial judges who have to deal
with these cases
are presented with the evidence
or
descriptions graphic descriptions these
are the cases
that wake you up at night
because
you're seeing the worst
of humanity
when
when there are victim statements
that are presented
when people talk about how their lives
have been destroyed as children
how the people who they trusted
to take care of them
were abusing them in this way and then
putting the pictures on the internet for
everyone to see
i sometimes still have nightmares about
the
main witness the the woman i mentioned
earlier who
cannot leave her house
because of
this kind of fear
the vulnerability the isolation
these crimes are are horrible
and so
i take them very seriously just as i
did all of the crimes but especially
crimes against children
so your honor if i could um the the
characterization that was just presented
in a recent column in the national
review a conservative publication
um has
characterized that
view of you as a smear that appears
meritless to the point of demagoguery
and characterizes your approach in
sentencing in these cases
as mainstream and correct
and i'll just remind my colleagues and
those watching that
two of the largest most substantial law
enforcement advocacy organizations in
our country the national fraternal order
of police and the international
association of chiefs of police have
spoken up uh in support of your
qualifications and
your capabilities the fop letter
says there's little doubt you have the
temperament intellect legal experience
and family background to have earned
this appointment
that sentiment was echoed by the iacp
in their letter they said
you believe you have a deep
understanding of an appreciation for the
challenges and complexities confronting
the policing profession
and you have during your time as a judge
displayed your dedication to ensuring
our communities are safe
and that the interests of justice are
served
i find it hard to believe that these
organizations having looked closely at
your judicial decisional record your
sentencing decisions
your lifetime conduct would have taken
those unusual steps to be that forceful
in supporting you if in fact you had
somehow a disturbing record of
coddling child pornographers or being
soft on crime
in fact judge your record in my view
demonstrates you're an even-handed and
impartial judge and i can see that when
i look at cases you ruled on
that involve very
politically charged or partisan
interests
you've delivered rulings on both sides
for plaintiffs and defendants
and in my review of your record you've
put any personal views or concerns aside
you've based your decisions on the
argument of the parties the facts in the
record the applicable law and precedent
and the well-reasoned and thorough
opinions you've written
show to me
a judge striving to make even-handed
decisions based on facts and law
not on some caricature of a
leftist agenda
but don't just take my word for it
we've received an outpouring of support
for your nomination
as we'll hear on thursday a very wide
range of groups and individuals have
sent letters or testimony to this
committee in support of your nomination
it's no surprise to me that your your
legal mind your experience your
temperament
inspires strong support from some of the
best and brightest of our legal
community
and i think it's worth highlighting that
among those many who have written to us
are included well respected conservative
and republican lawyers and republican
appointed judges who agree
with my characterization that you're an
even-handed and impartial judge
we've received a letter from 24
conservative lawyers who held positions
in republican administrations or well
known for their conservative political
or legal views who wrote this committee
to urge your speedy confirmation
they praised your character and
intellect and called you and i quote a
truly excellent person
i'd like to focus though on the way that
these conservative lawyers characterized
your judicial decision-making which is
after all the core
issue before us is whether you are the
sort of judge at the district court
circuit court that should be elevated to
the supreme court and they note in this
letter
that in nearly 10 years on the bench as
a district judge and then the court of
appeals
judge jackson has been involved in
thousands of cases running the full
range of federal law you're
approximately 500 i think it's more than
570 now opinions written during this
time have and i'm quoting demonstrated
complete command of the legal subject
matter a judicious and even-handed
approach
a fine ability to express yourself with
force and great clarity
they've also demonstrated and i'm
quoting another attribute essential for
a judge a sense of empathy for the
situations of others
judicious and even-handed
these prominent conservative lawyers
want this committee to know your
judicious and even-handed and recommend
you for the supreme court without
reservation despite having noted they
differ with you concerning some
political or partisan issues and they're
not alone
judge griffith in a letter to this
committee and then followed up with
personal testimony in your introduction
yesterday
a judge appointed by former president
george w bush enthusiastically supports
your nomination i was struck by his
description of your intellectual
capacity your keen legal mind as well as
your character and judicial approach and
now i'm quoting from his testimony to
this committee yesterday
judge jackson he told us as an
independent jurist who adjudicates based
on the facts and the law not as a
partisan
he went on as justice scalia taught us
an indispensable feature of the republic
the constitution created
is an independent judiciary of judges
who've taken an oath not to a president
or a party but to the american people
and to god that they will be
impartial
and he concluded that you judge jackson
have demonstrated an unwavering
commitment to that oath
that's a conservative judge appointed by
a republican president who told this
committee he's confident you'll decide
cases based on the facts and the law
not as a partisan now i value the
working relationships i have with my
colleagues on both sides of the aisle we
can and do at times have fierce policy
disagreements but we also work together
to try and find ways as lawmakers and
individuals to respect each other and i
take it as a personal sort of badge or
source of pride when someone with whom i
really disagree on one issue is able to
legislate with me on another
and so i imagine your honor it must be
gratifying
to know that a judge who literally sat
in judgment of reviewed
dozens and dozens of europeans in fact i
think you reversed you once oh more then
more than here is someone who closely
read and reviewed your decisions and as
a circuit judge sat in review of
your
work over years as a district hundreds
of opinions as a district court judge
and has such unequivocal praise for the
even-handed impartial thorough and
nonpartisan way
you've approached judicial decision
making
could you just briefly share with me
what it means to you to hear that
someone like judge griffith has such
confidence you would make an excellent
member of our highest court
thank you senator
it means the world to me to have
the support of judge griffith
his coming here yesterday and testifying
on my behalf
was so gratifying
um
i have tried in every respect
to follow my methodology that enables me
to rule impartially in every case and to
understand the limits of my own
judicial authority
and therefore thereby reach decisions
without fear or favor
my record demonstrates
that
i am not proceeding from any sort of
preconceived notion about how a case
comes out
i'm not ruling consistent with any sort
of ideology i'm doing
what impartial
and fair judges do which is to decide
in every case
based only on the facts and the law
of that case and i'm very very pleased
that judge griffith
has seen that in the years that he
supervised me effectively as a court of
appeals judge when i was a district
judge
and i think it it's wonderful that he
was able to come here and testify to
that well judge
for those watching and um for those
following this that they might be
puzzled
because my colleague the junior senator
from the state of texas
has tried to ascribe all sorts of views
to you
in his recent questioning
that
try to paint you as some kind of a of an
activist with a radical agenda
and in my review of your experience and
your record these letters from judges
and scholars i don't see anything that
remotely substantiates
that claim we are here to evaluate
your qualifications your judicial
decision making but so let me get at a
few of these points specifically if i
could
i've heard references to the 1619
project and critical race theory
um but i didn't hear that cited in any
reference to your opinions as a judge in
your nine years on the bench as a
district court judge
more than 570 decisions have you ever
cited the 1619 project no senator in
your nine years on the bench in more
than 570 opinions have you ever cited
the journalist or principal author of
that 16-19 project ms hannah jones i
have not and in your nine years in the
bench in more than 570 decisions have
you ever used employed relied upon
critical race theory to determine the
outcome of any case or to impose any
sentence or as a as a framework for your
decision making no senator
um would you just explain to us briefly
what sort of factors you do in fact
consider in your analysis
senator when i analyze a case
i am looking at the arguments that the
parties
raise in the case
i'm looking at
the record
which is the facts of the case developed
if i'm on the court of appeals developed
below
and i'm looking at the law
i'm looking at any statutes i'm
cueing to the text
i'm looking at constitutional provisions
to the extent that they are applicable
and any precedence
related
to the case at issue
those are the inputs that are
appropriate for a judge to consider
and those are the only things that i use
in my decision making
well
i i appreciate your laying that out and
i i'll just
let me dig into two cases if i can that
i think are also probative here because
i i agree with the wide range of
supporters we've heard from that you've
demonstrated
and even an impartial judicial approach
in your record
but this is true not just in the
hundreds of sort of run-of-the-mill
um quotidian cases that are considered
by a district court judge but in several
that have been highly charged and really
quite political in terms of their
consequences
um i'd like to discuss your opinion in
the center for biological diversity
versus mechalenin do you recall that
case i do senator it was a dispute
between groups advocating for
environmental protection and the trump
administration's department of homeland
security um the dispute was about
president trump's efforts to quickly
construct a physical border wall between
the united states and mexico i'm sure i
don't need to remind you or anyone here
that at the time
democrats were just about unanimous in
thinking that
physically building a wall from coast to
coast was not the
wisest use of resources to secure the
border there were other ways to do it
and with republicans pretty much
unanimously willing to defend it so it
was a
policy matter with some sharp divisions
and some political consequences
you ultimately ruled in favor of the
construction of the wall and against an
attempt by environmental groups to halt
its construction through
legal case through a legal case can you
discuss what you recall just briefly of
the claims presented and how you came to
a decision in favor of the trump
administration
senator the claims in that case
which as you say were brought by an
environmental organization
um
[Music]
related to the administrative procedures
act which is something that
we often
c in the district of columbia
and whether or not the agency
could waive
certain environmental laws pertaining to
the construction of the wall whether or
not the agency's determination to do so
uh was lawful
and i looked at the relevant
circumstances and i ended up i believe
dismissing that case
on threshold grounds
uh before getting to that point in the
analysis but
um consistent with what you said i was
guided
um by my understanding of the law and
what it required and not by anything
else
i could spend a lot of time on the
details of this case um but let me try
and summarize it this way
you analyzed the statute you concluded
congress had clearly blocked the courts
from hearing non-constitutional
challenges
there was no jurisdictional bar to the
constitutional claims to decide them
you considered whether the plaintiff's
claims were viable you looked for
precedent you found one
while not controlling you thought it was
legally sound and persuasive
but there was no controlling circuit
court or supreme court precedent
that stopped you if you were in fact an
activist judge a motivated partisan
determined
to let these plaintiff environmental
groups proceed you certainly could have
there was no clear precedent that barred
that from happening
you analyzed the statute
you applied the best precedent you could
find
and you reached a result
without regard to the political
consequence
that is correct senator so in my view um
i wanted to talk about this case because
it it there's really nothing unusual or
special about it from your perspective
that is correct for those of us up here
there was a lot special and important
about it it was a highly charged
partisan and political issue but you
looked at the statute you found
persuasive precedent you applied it you
went on to the next case
well let me ask about another decision
in a case addressing another very
politically charged issue and
specifically this involves the emails of
former secretary of state hillary
clinton
now the republican national committee or
the rnc is opposing your nomination
publicly accusing you of being a
partisan of a partisan democrat
and they argue you could not possibly be
an impartial justice but ironically back
in 2016 you presided over a case brought
by the rnc
against usaid
related to then presidential candidate
clinton
and you ruled in favor of the rnc
both the substance and the timing of the
case are really quite striking i did
the rnc made freedom of information act
requests for certain emails involving
the former secretary
and despite what the rnc would have us
now believe
um
in this case you reinforced your
deserved reputation for following the
law
not a partisan agenda
because you ordered usaid to produce
thousands of pages of documents related
to secretary clinton do you recall when
you issued that decision that order i
actually don't
well i'll tell you it was just before
the presidential conventions so if there
was a moment when the rnc had a
political objective it was right before
the convention
and you actually issued a ruling that
they were entitled to email production
from the usaid on the basis of legal
arguments presented to you the statute
at issue and the evidence is that
correct that is correct
well your honor i'm you know i'm frankly
really struck um at the fact that you
know for all the
back and forth uh in senate hearings and
uh academic circles about the judicial
philosophy of supreme court nominees
you've shown
what the experience of nearly a decade
overwhelmingly spent on the district
court has produced
a methodology
an approach
that looks at the constitution the
statute the facts the arguments of the
parties and reach as a result
without fear or favor without taking
into account the partisan issue at stake
um
you know i don't believe that a judicial
philosophy
is always all that meaningful
um the judge for whom i clerked on the
third circuit had spent years as a
district court judge and when i asked
her you know what's your judicial
philosophy she looked at me and said
i just call balls and strikes i'm a
judge who rolls in the case performing
exactly the same frame that you offered
a judicial philosophy does not in and of
itself constrain
a judge
what constrains a judge is a judge who
is willing to be constrained
who understands
that the role of the federal judiciary
is a limited one
so the real question i think a president
should consider when they make a
nomination the question that we as
senators need the answer to in order to
perform our function of advice and
consent and the question that i think
resonates best with the american people
who are concerned about
this hearing and this nomination and how
it will impact the country and their
lives is sort of
what kind of justice will you be
we want to know if you'll be fair
we want to know if you'll be faithful to
the constitution and to the rule of law
you've been a judge almost 10 years and
you've written more than 570
opinions
i'd say your record as a judge is the
best answer to the question what kind of
justice you will be
how would you say
your honor
that your approach to judging on the
district court relates to the way you
are now judging on the circuit court
and what approach do you think you will
bring with you if confirmed to the
supreme court
thank you senator
my approach all the way through
is one that i believe is required
by my duties by my oath as a judge
we rule without fear or favor
we are independent
as judges in our responsibilities
we
understand
at the district court level at the court
of appeals level and at the supreme
court
that judges
are restrained are constrained in the
exercise of our power under our
constitutional scheme
my methodology is designed to
help me to make decisions within those
confines
at every level
it's no different now that i'm on the
court of appeals than when i was on the
district court with respect to my
understanding
of the constraints on my authority
and my responsibility
to be impartial in my rulings
and i think it would be no different
at the supreme court
well your honor i i know we've walked
through just a few cases um today now
in some ways we've only scratched the
surface of your decade and the more than
570 opinions you've written
but it's clear to me from what i've
reviewed and from just this sample that
as we also heard from
colleagues from conservative lawyers
from judges who wrote to the committee
that you are judicious and even-handed
that you have a demonstrated record
of excellence that you adjudicate based
on the facts and the law and not as a
advocate activist or partisan
um and i encourage my colleagues who
want to know what kind of a justice
you'll be
to take a fair and even-handed
look at your record at your impartiality
and at your methodology
your experience is extensive and broad
your commitment to follow the law
impartially without the influence of
politics is evident in your record
your keen legal mind judicial
temperament and impeccable character are
plain to all
judge griffith told this committee in a
review of your record makes clear
you've demonstrated that the way you
approach cases is based on the law
and not on some political
agenda
you understand the reason why the robes
of our federal judges are black not red
or blue
the american justice system as many have
said
is rooted in the impartiality the
independence
and the reliability of our federal
judicial system is one of the most
critical bulwarks
of our system of ordered liberty
no wonder that when you came before this
body to be confirmed for the district
court then the circuit court
you earned and received bipartisan
support
i know president biden counts nominating
a supreme court justice among the most
significant decisions of his presidency
and our role here in the senate in
confirming a justice to our highest
court is among our most solemn
obligations and greatest privileges
so in nominating you i believe our
president has met his mission
and it will be my honor to join i hope
the overwhelming majority of my
colleagues in supporting your
confirmation as an associate justice of
the united states supreme court
thank you your honor thank you senator
coons last week the committee received a
letter judge from the national coalition
against domestic violence representing
survivors of domestic violence urging
the senate to swiftly confirm you to the
supreme court committee also received a
letter about your nomination from nine
separate organizations representing both
survivors of domestic violence and
sexual assault the letter said and i
quote judge jackson is highly qualified
for the position as her career and
record demonstrate her historic
confirmation as the supreme court's
first black woman and the sixth woman
overall will represent monumental
progress toward a nation
it is charged to serve and that values
all of its citizens equally the
organizations also noted
jackson's rulings reflect the judicial
consensus i move to enter these letters
into the record without objection they
will be senator sash you're next up but
we're on a cusp of a vote
so i want to be fair to you we're going
to take a break at this point
i'm going to
hope
i thought we were taking a break and
going to go vote but if you want me to
go first i'm good no i think we ought to
go over there and okay pray that it
comes along and we can return quickly so
why don't we declare this break time for
20 minutes 405 back in the room
[Music]
there
okay
[Music]
okay
[Music]
uh
oh
i can't eat it um
okay
yes
[Music]
what
yes
yes
here
um
yes
wow
right
sure
[Music]
okay
oh there you go
you do it
[Music]
[Music]
juliette
oh
okay
she's coming up
oh
oh
yay
[Music]
[Music]
this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that
[Music]
feeling
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
hey
hello
this
awesome
[Music]
foreign
foreign
these
you
um
senator judiciary committee will come to
order the senator from nebraska senator
sass
thank you chairman
judge welcome back um by my quick
eyeballing count of this you are 51 done
as of this moment which feels more like
cursed than blessing but i meant it as a
good thing i think i think i'm number 12
of 22 so you're just past halfway down
on the downhill
thank you as well for spending time with
me in my office and thank you for
answering the questions of the committee
today and tomorrow
what you've said in public matches what
you've said in private and that's
obviously a testimony a testament to
your character um that also
can be helpful to rebuilding public
trust so thank you for the way you've
the ways you've engaged thus far
um judge you are
likely to go on to serve a lifetime
appointment on the supreme court which
means that this is very likely the last
job interview you ever have
and the most public senator yeah
these processes are a lot like a
proctology exam
that means that it's an opportunity uh
for you to explain to the american
people how you view a supreme court
justice's job and the the limits and
bounds on that job so i want to go back
to a topic that you and i have discussed
a few times which is how you approach
cases
you've told this committee and you've
told me in private
that you don't have a judicial
philosophy yet but that you think of
yourself as having more of a judicial
methodology
i'd like to understand that a little bit
more
and i think it would be helpful for the
american people to understand that
argument and that distinction a bit more
as well
earlier today you said that you quote do
not believe there is a living
constitution and you also said that
you're constrained to interpret the text
and that's i think you said sometimes
that's enough to resolve the issue so i
think i've heard you pay partial tribute
uh to the judicial philosophy of
originalism but you've not adopted it or
embraced it as a philosophy or label
that applies to you
so maybe one of the places we could
tease that out a little bit more
is trying to um dig into whose
jurisprudence you most admire um we've
heard many nominees before like like
senator grassley former chairman of this
committee i'm not an attorney uh so the
farming and ranching people where i'm
where i come from uh know that john
kennedy is super smart rhodes lawyer who
kind of pretends to be a you know aw
shucks kind of guy as he picks your
pocket um grassley and i get equal times
chairman
he all he always gets unequal time uh he
always gets bonus time uh but i think it
might be helpful for us to understand
who you most identify with and past
nominees before this committee have
talked about the mold of particular
justices they thought they followed in
and so if you had to tell the american
people who you're closest to
who is that justice or who are those
justices
well thank you for the question senator
and i
um
i must admit that i don't really have a
justice that i've
molded myself after or that i would what
i have is a record
i have
570 plus cases in which i have employed
the methodology that i described
and
that shows people
how i analyze cases
i in every case am proceeding neutrally
from a neutral posture from every in
every case
i describe thoroughly
all of the arguments that are made
in the case to me as a judge because i
want
in my lengthy opinions for people to
understand the inputs this i say is what
i'm considering because i lay out in
very
you know detailed way
everything that people have argued in
all of the cases and then when i'm doing
my interpretation
i am focused
on the text
of any statute or constitutional
provision
i am
looking as appropriate to
the intentions of the people who wrote
the words because i view statutory
interpretation constitutional
interpretation those exercises
consistent with my limited authority
i am conscious of
not
interpreting those
texts consistent with what i believe the
policy should be or what i think
the outcome should be
i am trying in every case that involves
that kind of interpretation
to assess what it is that the parties
the parties wrote the text intended
and
as a result
because my methodology involves um these
various pieces and
um
because of the way in which i do things
i'm reluctant to
establish
or to adopt a particular label
because the idea of how you interpret is
just one part of
the entirety of a judge's responsibility
as i mentioned you know i'm looking at
the
facts in a case and my experience as a
trial judge helps me to assess the facts
from all of the different perspectives
of the parties because i'm
able to
do that i think having heard from
parties in all sorts of cases directly
as they present their arguments that's a
part of the judging
responsibility that isn't really
captured by something like originalism
or living constitution and i believe
that the constitution is fixed in its
meaning
i believe that it's appropriate
to look at the original intent original
public meaning of the words when
one is trying to assess because again
that's a limitation on my authority to
import my own policy views
but there are times when
the meaning
unreasonable searches and seizures
due process
looking at those words
are not enough to tell you what they
actually mean you look at them in the
context of history
you look at the structure of the
constitution
you
look at the circumstances that you're
dealing with in comparison to
what
those words meant at the time that they
were adopted
and
you look at precedents that are related
to this topic
um all of those tools judges use and i
have used is if
if you look at my cases
but when you say that you look at the
intent of the authors of a statute
sometimes courts have to say the people
who wrote this statute whether they
meant to or not have done something that
we the judiciary decides speaking in the
voice of you
is unconstitutional and deciding that
something is unconstitutional requires
an interpretive framework for how you
get there right and so you and i talked
in my office
about the differences between justices
kagan
breyer and sotomayor's judicial
philosophies and you told me that you
needed time to study that issue further
so assuming that you've had a chance to
think about that a bit more i guess i'd
ask you again
what are the differences among the three
of their judicial philosophies
with respect senator i have not actually
had time um with all of my meetings and
with senators and um the work that i've
done to to appear before you today i
would say
that there are differences as you see
from
the various opinions that they have
issued
i'm not sure which one i would
necessarily follow because it depends on
the case i think their differences um
indicate that they are are looking at
different provisions they are using the
various tools that judges use and that i
have used
in my cases
the the idea of
striking down a statute as
unconstitutional is daunting and should
be daunting um i think for any judge or
justice and and had to be would have to
be looked at very carefully because
of the limited nature of the judicial
role and the fact that um the policies
have been adopted by the branch of
government that has that authority under
the constitution
so i i guess i'm surprised after nine
years on the bench that
i mean you're super smart nobody
disputes that um and having worked for
justice briar and knowing of some of the
fights some of the philosophical
arguments he and justice kagan had um it
just seemed surprising that
you wouldn't be able to at least
speculate not speculate but reflect a
little bit on the nature of those
disagreements because to say it depends
on the particular case that's fine but
they have different philosophical and
hermeneutic approaches to the tax so
maybe another way to get at it um i
think
justice breyer again for whom you
clerked and justice scalia used to
travel together and uh have lively um
debate circuit conversations can you
tell the american people a little bit
about what breyer scalia roadshow looked
like what were they arguing about
well my understanding is they were
arguing or at least presenting two
different um
viewpoints as to how the constitution
should be interpreted and i would say
just as an aside before talking about
their positions
that
while i have been on the bench for nine
plus years the issue of constitutional
interpretation in that sense doesn't
come up very often
it comes up to the supreme court for
sure
but it doesn't come up very often in the
lower courts
what justice scalia and justice uh
breyer
i believe were
debating
was
the justice scalia's notion of
originalism meaning
um that the words of the constitution
should be interpreted
as
uh they were written by the founders in
the founding era and that they should
not be considered to
um
essentially to establish principles that
modern justices could now apply based on
their own
view of the needs of society
and that justice breyer's position was
more toward that ladder view that
the idea of um
the constitution needing to
be interpreted
in a way that is consistent with modern
sensibilities about
the principles
that the document reflects
and i would just say that
it appears now that the supreme court
has taken
justice scalia's view that the
prevailing
interpretive
frame
for interpreting the constitution is now
very clearly
looking back through history so we see
that even in
um the heller case where the justices
even even the justices in descent
were all
analyzing the issues in the second
amendment
through a historical lens what what was
meant at the time of the founding so
that is now
the way in which constitutional
interpretation is done
but do you identify with that position
i identify with the position insofar as
that's how
uh the text is interpreted of the
constitution that i am a strong believer
as i said in
uh precedent in starry decisis in
predictability
in the rule of law and the way that the
law now
interprets the constitution is through
this historical frame
um i'm grateful for your last couple of
minutes because i think that it's in the
american civic interest for us to
understand these different schools again
non-lawyer here but my uh simple way of
summarizing some of what i think i heard
you just say is that scalia argues hard
that the constitution has a fixed
meaning and justices aren't really free
to depart from it without a
constitutional amendment passed by the
political branches so that the voters
get to hire and fire the people or
have a role at the state level in the
ratification of a constitutional
amendment and breyer's position seems to
me
and i won't get it precise enough uh in
technical legal terms joe's prudential
terms probably to satisfy him but that
the constitution is speaking to more
abstract principles and therefore
there's a lot more play in the joints of
what a justice's job is and
i think the way you summarized their
debate was pretty fair and i also think
it's fair for us to want to understand
what your position is about it because
you're obviously
as i've said
incredibly uh smart and incredibly
likable and winsome and on the on the
stage for a lot of americans to look up
to i'm at the rah-rah here here side of
that debate um at the level of what is
the supreme court justice's job i think
that's why a lot of us are still trying
to tease out the philosophical
distinction which i think is more than
just a methodology but wanna wanna thank
you for that answer um
you've also brought up the the fourth
amendment a number of times in our
conversation and i would like to talk a
little bit more about the constitution
and whether it's meaning changes and so
i'd like to go back to the fourth
amendment topic you brought up in my
office um you said i think that origin
and correct me if i'm miss summarizing
your position you said that originalism
wouldn't have much to say about the
fourth amendment because the founding
fathers never conceived of a tool a
piece of telecommunications equipment
like this and so i think during our
conversation you said that the original
meaning of the fourth amendment won't
tell you much about what to do with a
new technology my guess is that
originalists and scalia in particular
would disagree
so
what do you do if the text of the fourth
amendment doesn't answer a question
where do you go next
well senator just to clarify what i
intended to say and i may well have
misspoken um
there is an originalist take i think on
the question of what happens with a cell
phone um as the supreme court
held in the riley case there was a way
in which you
assess
principles of the constitution the text
of the constitution and apply it
to modern technology and you have to
because there's no question that cell
phones didn't exist at the time of the
founding so if the originalist principle
is we look only at the constitution as
it relates to things that existed at the
time of the founding there would be no
answer
to what to do about a cell phone and so
what the supreme court has
said and done
is
to determine
that the principle of the fourth
amendment with respect to
searches
is to determine whether there is a
reasonable expectation of privacy
they also have uh looked at
property interests with respect to
whether or not there's an invasion of
privacy
and then determined from history
what that reasonable expectation of
privacy related to
back at the time of the founding
and analogized
to current circumstances related to
things like cell phones
it's it's a method of interpretation
that allows you to
instead of
the the alternative which would be
don't worry about the history just look
at the words in the constitution and say
what do i think is reasonable or
unreasonable with respect to police
officers searching cell phones that's
not the way the supreme court handles it
they try to determine
what was unreasonable
historically
and then given those principles
historically it would be unreasonable
for police officers to enter someone's
home to rifle through their papers and
documents they then analogize to
current circumstances and the fact that
a cell phone is like
your personal file cabinet and they say
okay given what we understood the
framers to have intended about the need
for a warrant or the need for
protection against unreasonable searches
we're going to apply that
to modern circumstances
it's still an originalist way
of analyzing
the current dispute
so are there non-originalist ways
to wrestle through that same question
and what would they be
one could imagine that rather than
referencing history at all
that the court would look at the
constitution it says
no unreasonable searches and seizures
and would just ask in the in
you know in light of modern
sensibilities in light of what we would
think would be reasonable today or what
the court itself would think would be
reasonable today
we'd apply that that modern
understanding
to
the cell phone situation
and the danger i think justice scalia
would say
is that that's a kind of framing
that permits
judges
to
make a determination based on their own
views rather than
cueing themselves as as senator lee said
before that justice barrett pointed out
hewing themselves to the text of the
constitution
and does breyer have a different view
you know i haven't um
i'm just trying to think i i my
understanding of the living
constitutional principle is that it's
closer to
looking at the needs of modern society
but i'm i'm
not well versed in it in part because
the supreme court has now so clearly
taken
the historical perspective
uh the originalist perspective in its
interpretations
you brought up the cell phone example
with me but i know you have others what
are some other areas of life where the
original meaning seems to be
two and a half centuries removed what
are what are places that the
constitution seems to not speak to
well senator i you know i'm
reluctant to s
spell out uh different circumstances
what i will say is that
when you look at the language
in the constitution
um
there are some provisions that are
completely
clear on their face without any question
of what was intended the age of
um
the required age of senators the
required age of the minimum age of the
president these kinds of provisions all
you need is the text
and and there you are
um
but there are provisions of the
constitution
that are broader than that and therefore
some interpretive
frame
is necessary
and to the extent i mean every question
the supreme court gets
that involves new technology for example
that relates to constitutional
provisions
will require some kind of analogy
i think
but you know i can't speak to
to anything more than that
you have described justice breyer's
constitutional approach as pragmatic
what does that mean
i understand it to be
um
and his approach
to be
about
ensuring that the rules
that follow
from the supreme court's determinations
are ones that
make sense and are workable
um
he he said recently
explaining his approach to interpreting
a statute you're not going to go outside
the words but it often doesn't give you
the answer and you look at the history
and you look at its purposes and you
look at the consequences too and you'll
try to evaluate them from that the point
of view of what a reasonable legislature
writing this statute have thought that
these words were there to achieve
do you do you align yourself with that
position
in the broad sense
that what it is that the court
is tasked with
um when statutory interpretation is
um being undertaken
is to achieve
the purposes of the legislature
the text
is
the
uh primary and in most cases soul
indication of what the legislature
intended
as opposed to the court saying
i see this statute but i'm you know
uncomfortable with
how it's going to turn out or what it's
going to mean and so i'm going to import
my own policy perspective
instead the court is constrained to say
regardless of what i think the right
policy objective should be in this with
respect to this law
my purpose my
requirement
is to determine what congress intended
but with respect to legislative intent
when uh a congress of 535 often
distracted people 100 in this body and
435 in the other pass something you know
by a two to one-ish vote
and it's a part of a large piece of
legislation how do you how do you
determine what the intent is when it's
535 people doing something that has many
many different purposes for why somebody
might vote yes
well you you look at the text i mean the
the
the way in which statutes are
interpreted
is based on what the legislature says
there are times in which there are
statutes
in which congress includes a purpose
statement for example
in the actual text of the statute
you look at the text of the provision
if that isn't clear you look at the
structure of the statute
there are cannons of interpretation that
courts use to
evaluate and interpret statutes things
like
the
a word that appears in the section that
you are interpreting
should be defined the same way it is in
another section
you know the same word being used
congress probably intended to
um
for it to have the same meaning
so
there are tools in the law that exist to
help courts to interpret the text but
again the
goal
is to interpret the text
as a means of
understanding and reflecting what
congress intended and of course in
statutory interpretation
um if congress decides that the court
has gotten it wrong
then as this happened many times
congress comes back and clarifies and
tells the court no this is this is what
the statute means
i want to go back to an exchange you had
with senator cornyn uh substantive due
process
is a doctrine that often allows courts
to create new fundamental rights um
what's the test for determining a new
fundamental right
the supreme court has said in the
glecksburg case
that um
the fundamental rights that are
recognized or that are are included in
substantive due process
um are those that are deeply rooted in
the nation's history and tradition
in a case prior to that the court had
defined it
as the rights that are implicit in
the ordered concept of liberty or the
concept of ordered liberty
um
so there are standards for the courts
to use to identify these
these types of rights
so did the supreme court use this test
in row or casey
in roe and casey
i don't know that the court used that
formulation
i know that after casey the court
has determined
not so much that
the right to terminate a woman's
pregnancy is fundamental
the the right exists and
it's subject to the framework in casey
uh that allows for uh regulation
um
so long as there's not an undue burden
on the exercise of the right
pre-viability i think some of what we're
wrestling with here is the question of
and i think what senator cornyn was
driving at is how particular the concept
of deeply rooted goes and how that
really is abound uh on what the
judiciary can do but i want to thank you
we're nearly at time i want to thank you
for engaging in the back and forth i
want to think more about what you've
said and look forward to further
discussion tomorrow it still appears to
me that there's a very basic difference
between a judicial philosophy and a
judicial methodology
into and how you go about applying that
when you're interpreting a law and
making a determination about
constitutionality or non and i
know that you haven't claimed
a judicial philosophy at all but a
judicial philosophy of originalism here
but i do think the fact that you've at
least nodded to it uh in the committee
hearing today is in and of itself a
pretty great testimony to how much of
scalia and bork's
work has has moved to the legal field so
i'm grateful for for the time you're
taking with us i'll look forward to
listening tonight and talking with you
again tomorrow thank you
thank you senator sass senator
blumenthal
thanks mr chairman uh
thank you judge for your
patience and your perseverance uh
i want to begin just
by thanking also for an extraordinary
moment in our history
i think we all as americans
feel excitement and pride
in
really making history here and
the old saying a picture's worth a
thousand words as i look at your parents
and your husband
and your daughters
uh
what i see is america
and the best of america
so i think we should all feel that
excitement and pride in this moment and
the extraordinary journey that has
brought you here
you will
make the court look more like america
but also
think more
like america
in the obstacles and challenges that
you've overcome to be here we don't know
all of them
but
you will provide a
very important perspective indeed a
unique perspective that the court
needs more than ever at this moment in
its history there are a lot of people
who are book smart
there are not as many people who are
person smart and you are both
that kind of emotional intelligence
is what our courts need not just our
supreme court
so i want to really begin by asking you
as a role model for others
to talk a little bit to
the
young women and girls of america
particularly black
young women and girls
about those challenges
and obstacles that you've had to
overcome
to be here and what's helped you do it
thank you senator
i am humbled and honored
to have the opportunity to
serve in this capacity and to be the
first
and only black woman to serve on the
united states supreme court
i
stand on the shoulders of
generations past
who
never had anything close to this
opportunity
who were the first and the only
in a lot of different
fields
my parents as i said were the first in
their families to have the chance to go
to college
i've been the first and the only in
certain aspects of my life so i would
say
that i agree with you that this is a
moment that
all americans should
should be proud
now you've never been a prosecutor
a lot of us on this panel have been
prosecutors i was the u.s attorney the
chief federal prosecutor in connecticut
for four and a half years and then i was
attorney general of my state
for 20 years
but
i would say one of the most meaningful
[Music]
cases in my career was
as a defense counsel
i was asked by the naacp legal defense
fund to represent
a black man on death row in your home
state of florida he had been convicted
of
murder
and rape
had been on death row
for a number of years
and i took the case because i was asked
to do it
and eventually
somewhat to my surprise found in fact he
had never done
the crime
of which he had been convicted
and eventually we won his freedom
because the prosecutor in the case
concealed
evidence which was a violation of his
constitutional rights
and
he was a free man
as a result
your
husband as a surgeon saves lives lawyers
don't do it often
but
i know from personal experience the
importance of having
a good
representative an advocate a council
because in that case he had been denied
it when he originally went to trial and
only after years in both state and
federal courts
was the truth
indicated
so i want you to talk a little bit about
why it is important
for
defendants to be represented by zealous
really aggressive and energetic
advocates who
tell the truth to the court put on the
evidence and present the best possible
case for a
defendant accused of a crime
thank you senator
the idea
is one that is rooted in our
constitution
the framers
were
concerned about government overreach
in a lot of different areas
the provisions of our constitution are
protecting
individual liberty
from
government overreach this is why we have
provisions about limited government
and there are many provisions in the
constitution that are
limiting government action when it comes
to the deprivation of liberty
because the framers understood how
important liberty is
to
our society and so there's the fourth
amendment there's the fifth amendment
there's the sixth amendment there's the
eighth amendment
these provisions are crucial and
it is
zealous defense council
that ensures that the government
is protecting these rights that ensures
that these rights are protected
and that people are getting
due process in the criminal justice
system and that's to all of our benefit
that helps everyone in america
when we ensure
that liberty cannot be denied
without due process
it's defense counsel as i said who are
making arguments and they're not
condoning
the criminal behavior
they're making arguments on behalf of
clients
in defense of the constitution and these
constitutional values and as a judge i
now see
how important it is
for me to be able to
make my decisions
after hearing from both sides
that's crucial we have an adversarial
system which means
that judges are presented with arguments
from both the prosecution and the
defense
and only when i'm able to hear from both
sides can i make
a just
fair determination
and fairness is the hallmark of our
constitutional scheme and it's what
makes us
the best criminal justice system in the
world
and it's not only the reality of
fairness but also the perception of
fairness the public's understanding of
how courts work that is essential to the
credibility that courts have correct
that is correct
and so i feel very strongly
i know that a number of us on the
committee agree that more transparency
more visibility is important for the
public to understand what goes on in the
courtroom
i know you
feel transparency is a good thing
you've been asked about cameras in the
courtroom i'm a supporter of
senator grassley's sunshine in the
courtroom
act as well as
senator durbin's cameras in the
courtroom act
i am hopeful that the court the united
states supreme court actually
will back these proposals because their
support would be very important
tell me how you feel
about the basic principle of
transparency and more visibility
well senator
one of the reasons as i said that i
write such long opinions
is because
i want everybody to know exactly
the arguments i've considered
the facts that i've reviewed
and
in pretty fine detail
the course of my reasoning and i've done
this in
570 opinions
i think it's important
for public confidence as you say
for
people
who are bound by the law
and who are affected by the courts
to know
what the court's views are
with respect to the issue of cameras in
the courtroom i understand that that is
something that is proceeding through
congress and
if i was confirmed i would look forward
to talking with my
colleagues to understand the positions
that people have regarding that issue
i appreciate that response uh one of the
other
areas that i think is important to
transparency and to public trust and
confidence in the court
is visibility as to
its own decisions
which
i think is directly contradicted by the
shadow docket you've been asked about it
before but i just want
folks understand
that some of the
most important decisions the supreme
court have been decided
or at least
issues resolved
without oral argument without briefs
without
any public explanation of
a controversial
travel ban
has gone into effect
the first federal execution in 17 years
was permitted
uh statewide coveted restrictions were
enabled the collection of data in the
2020 united states sense census
and
enforcement of voting restrictions in
the 2020 presidential elections
as well as decisions relating to
immigration and blocking the
biden administration from enforcing
a federal moratorium on evictions
imposed because of the covet 19
epidemic americans have a right to an
open full fair
proceeding with a record
of the court's reasons for making
decisions so
i hope that you will
urge your colleagues when you talk to
them about cameras in the courtroom also
to do less on the shadow docket
and i hope that perhaps
if they don't congress will take some
action
i uh finally want to ask
so far as this issue of transparency is
concerned about
codes of ethics
you have followed a code of ethics as a
district court judge and court of
appeals judge correct
i have
does that code of ethics apply to the
united states supreme court
my understanding is that it does not
correct
um
and uh my hope is that you will perhaps
urge your colleagues as well to support
a code of ethics they haven't done so as
yet but i think we have an obligation
in the congress to set forth a code of
ethics and i hope they'll support it uh
senator durbin and
others of us have supported that that
kind of measure as well
um
and i i would just ask you
whether you'll raise it with your
colleagues if you're confirmed
senator um
certainly if congress is taking anything
up and that requires our review i would
absolutely
um i would absolutely consider it to me
and even if not i would would consider
it
talking to them about it
thank you uh you know the reason i
raised these points is that um
i
respect the united states supreme court
i've argued four cases before it
i was a law clerk to justice blackman
uh who by the way was from minnesota mr
chairman
uh
in fact he was known
as one of the minnesota twins when he
was appointed because he was thought to
be
exactly like
then chief justice warren berger who
also was from minnesota in his very
very conservative views
and as it happened
justice blackman became one of
the most progressive members of
the court
over the years that he served he had a
capacity for growth
and for learning and listening which i
believe you have and i think it is one
of the most important
characteristics of anybody who
serves
on the court
but
i do think the court's crisis of
legitimacy is the result of divisions
within the court
the polarization and politicization that
has drawn lines the process
that has happened in recent years
in confirmation proceedings and so i
really think that consensus building
building bridges with your colleagues
will be immensely important i think
that's one of the reasons that
the president chose you
having talked to him about it
that you have that kind of persuasive
and forceful intellect but also the
personal
charm and
warmth and depth that will enable you to
do it
maybe you can tell this committee about
how you worked on the sentencing
commission for example or in your
previous experiences on that kind of
consensus building
thank you senator
consensus building was one of the things
that
justice breyer was particularly good at
in terms of his
personality in the time that i clerked
for him i witnessed
the way in which he continually reaches
out
to
colleagues continually seeks
common ground
and it's something that i would
hope to be able to emulate if i
were to be confirmed
when i worked on the sentencing
commission the commission is a seven
member body
um
working on sentencing policy
which is at times a pretty
contentious effort because we're talking
about
uh criminal justice
as commissioners we are working on
policy issues related to
uh appropriate sentencings and
um
by statute
the commission is is a bipartisan group
and during my four years as a
commissioner
i was
able to work
well with other members of the
commission
to find common ground to work on issues
to come together and
the vast majority i heard a statistic
that something like 95 or 97 percent of
the votes that the commission took
were unanimous um and that that happened
because of a lot of effort and in
intention on the parties on the part of
all involved
to see if we could work together
and that would be the kind of thing that
um
that i would hope to do
if i was confirmed to the supreme court
you've mentioned in your
previous testimony the challenges of
applying the law to evolving a new
technology
obviously the internet raises exactly
those questions congress passed the
electronic communications privacy act in
1986
when the internet was barely
recognizable it was nascent
just starting
and
now
our nation faces a mental height health
crisis
it is partly
aggravated by the pandemic the isolation
and anxiety that's resulted from but
also by the internet
and by the tech platforms that drive
toxic
content at children
as a result of these black box
algorithms that nobody really
understands literally no one understands
because
the
tech platforms want to keep them
secret
and
we are trying to
upgrade the law and update it
to give parents tools
to have greater visibility as to what
their
children are doing and to give
parents and children
tools
to protect them against some of the
bullying
and
eating disorder content and even
suicidal and substance abuse
stuff that
they are
driven to see
and uh senator blackburn and i have
introduced a bipartisan measure the kids
online safety act
that will
provide a more modern solution to a
modern problem
to update
the law to account for
the role of social media in
[Music]
our ongoing and aggravating
mental health crisis in this country
do you agree that it helps the supreme
court
and judges in general to do
their job when congress updates our
statutes
to account for technological change
thank you senator
the role of the court
is to
interpret statutes when
there are disputes related to the
statutes and
in circumstances in which statutes have
not been updated
i don't think it's surprising um to note
that
there are disputes
about the meaning of the statute about
how it applies
and so to the extent that congress
undertakes to
make amendments and
make the changes
i think it helps
courts maybe there'll be fewer disputes
or
easier disputes to resolve
easier disputes to resolve in the sense
that and
i i've seen it happen a judge will say
i don't know what congress meant to do
in this kind of situation because
this law was written at a time when
none of this stuff now existed i'm sure
you face that
situation i think it's true
of
social media and the dangers to
children as a result of
the toxic content that they often find
and often seemingly are
addicted to use again and again and
again because it's part of the business
model
of those social media and big tech
platforms
yes i have i have faced this situation
um
one of my cases the uh alliance of
artists and recording companies versus
general motors is a case
that i ended up writing a couple of
opinions about
and involved
a statute of congress
related to
digital recording audio devices
and whether or not royalties were
required for
the purchase of those kinds of devices
and it was enacted at a time in which
recording technology was at a different
stage
than it is now
and disputes
arose that came before me regarding
whether or not to
apply the royalty
requirement in that statute to
modern recording devices and in
particular the recording devices that
are now in automobiles
um when you take your cd and you put it
in your own car and record
uh
record onto the hard drive of your car
is that the same thing as putting your
cd in one of those machines that records
from cd to cd
and you give your the the second
recording to all of your friends that
was
that was what the statute was originally
meant to
cover and the question was whether uh
recording to your own car's hard drive
counted
and it was a very interesting
interpretive exercise but again it was
the kind of thing in which
i was focused on
trying to ascertain what
based on the text of the statute and the
definitions in the statute
what congress
intended this statute to cover
and
cars
other devices appliances at home
collect
huge amounts of data don't they and
as consumers we feel we
own that data it's ours
but it can be bought and sold exchanged
and mined
in a way that right now consumers have
no consent over
and it enhances
the dominance of just a few of those
tech companies just a few of the
corporations corporate power
is
emboldened and
enabled in many respects by the amount
of data they collect it's also
enabled by forced arbitration we've had
a reference to it already today
with respect to
complaints about sexual harassment which
fortunately
uh we have addressed i've been
uh proud to work on the
ending forced arbitration of sexual
assault and
sexual harassment act which president
biden signed after we passed it uh just
a
few weeks ago
um
i've heard harrowing stories
from survivors of sexual assault
and victims of workplace
harassment who were silenced and denied
justice by forced arbitration but forced
arbitration applies as well
to
everybody who has a cell phone
you have a forced arbitration agreement
many workers
have forced arbitration agreements
nursing homes have forced arbitration
agreements
the point is that you have dedicated
your life
to access to the courts
the right of a trial the right to a jury
the right to a judge
none of it is possible where there is a
forced arbitration
agreement that's why
i've worked on a measure called the fair
act
that would
make any
forced pre-dispute
arbitration agreement invalid and
unenforceable if both sides want
arbitration that's fine but access to
the courts
should be available to everyone
uh i know that you're limited as to what
you can say about measures and
that are before us and policy issues
but i hope that you
will consider
the trend that the court has adopted
in support of
forced arbitration and denial of rights
like class action
and review whether they are appropriate
uh let me just
finish with a couple of quick points
first of all on the harvard law school
harvard law review article
uh
on um
registration of sex offenders convicted
sex offenders
i must say
i read this article several times
in my view
it is
analysis not advocacy
would you agree
absolutely senator as a law school
student
i was trying to do what law school
students do which is
analyze
a new
set
of legal provisions these laws were new
and i was trying to
um assess
what
criteria courts could use to look at
them i was not making an argument about
them at all
exactly and by the way one of those
statues was in connecticut
it was challenged
on constitutional grounds double
jeopardy
it went to the united states supreme
court
i defended it there
it was upheld
nine to zero
i don't know whether your article was
cited
but uh i would put this
law review article very much in the
category of analysis the distinction
between prevention and
punishment
i would
call it
protection
not
punishment or prevention
that's the argument that i made with
supreme court
i ask that this article will be put in
the record mr chairman
without objection
uh by the way it took me two or three
times to get through it so
uh no disrespect to you or the harvard
law review
um the um
the issue of
child pornography
um
you reckon you you mentioned i think
that in your decisions on these
sentencing cases
involving child sexual abuse material
which by the way i agree is absolutely
horrific
abhorrent
it's the reason that
senator graham and i have actually
sponsored a measure called the earn it
act
that addresses it
but you said that you imposed a sentence
that matched the recommendation
by either the prosecution or the
probation office in
most
of the cases
where you did that sentencing is that is
that right glad that
yes senators uh in looking back at um
the records concerning
my cases
it looks as though i had
14
cases that involved either
child pornography
internet
interstate travel to
meet up with a child for sex the sex
crimes related to to children
and in 10 of those 14 cases i imposed a
sentence that was
consistent with or greater than
what either the government or the
prosecution
uh requested
and the probationary excuse me sorry
the government or the probation office
and let me just ask you the probation
office
is an
independent arm of the court
that investigates the defendant
looks at the crime
the defense background his family
situation all of the relevant factors
involved in sensing including the
sentencing guidelines and then
independently and
impartially
makes a recommendation
presumably to serve the interests of
justice in that particular case based on
the individual facts there is that
roughly a correct description that is
correct senator the probation office
works within the court system
they are independent of the parties and
they
investigate and make recommendations
in cases
concerning what the probation office
thinks is an appropriate sentence
thank you
let me just finish by saying uh
much of america is watching these
proceedings on a split screen
on
one hand they are literally seeing the
death and destruction in ukraine
russia's brutal barbaric
assault on
individual rights
basic freedoms
that we often take for granted here
and we are exercising exercising those
rights right here
you are
a teaching
lesson this proceeding is a
teaching lesson about the importance of
democracy
the people of ukraine are fighting for
it they are dying in their neighborhoods
and streets
and their homes they are huddled
in basements their
men
and women
are
resisting valiantly and braving bravely
against
a huge military
force that russia has unleashed and a
reign of terror from the skies simply
because they believe in the ideals
of freedom and law
that we are seeking to preserve here
and so on this side of that split screen
i think
it's important that we do our best to
honor
the norms and the rules that you've
sought to uphold throughout your life
and i'm
proud and excited
to be here
with
you
and your family
as we go through this process and i look
forward
as i hope
many of us do to
a bipartisan majority in support of your
candidacy thank you thanks mr chairman
thank you thank you senator blumenthal
i'd like to bring everyone up to date we
have several considerations the
remaining senators for questions
the endurance of our witness judge
jackson
votes on the floor
uh request for compassionate release by
a number of people in the audience
uh here is where we stand
we're going to have senator hawley
followed by senator hirono then we're
going to take a 20-minute break
because that's when we think there'll be
some votes on the floor we can take care
of those and get back in 20 minutes then
we will return from that break to
senators cotton and booker then we'll
take a 30 minute break or so for dinner
then it'll be senator kennedy padilla
and tillis
and we're going to start off tomorrow
with our
two
senators ossoff and blackburn
so we should finish in the nine to ten
o'clock hour this evening
god willing so at this point uh i
recognize senator hawley thank you mr
chairman judge nice to see you again
thank you again for being here
congratulations again on your nomination
i i want to start uh where senator
blumenthal left off i want to talk with
you about some of these cases i
mentioned them yesterday so i know you
know which ones i want to talk about the
seven cases child pornography cases in
which you had discretion they came
before you you had discretion to
sentence one way or another in these
seven cases not every case of course do
you have discretion sometimes the law
requires you to impose a sentence
certain sense but in these seven you had
discretion and each of these seven you
chose to depart both from the federal
guidelines and also from the governments
the prosecutor's recommendation senator
lee's asked you a little bit about this
senator cruz has asked you about it he
had a chart with the seven cases on it
before we jump into those i just want to
correct the record on one or two things
senator coons
suggested that in three cases nickerson
win and fife
you actually impose sentences either
within the guidelines or at the same
level the prosecution but in nickerson
you didn't have any discretion that was
an 11 c1c case the law bound you and
wynn wasn't a child porn case and
neither was fife
just one other quick thing to clarify as
to these comments about the probation
office the probation office doesn't
issue national guidelines right i mean
the probation office doesn't issue
sentencing guidelines they're not public
they're not recommended to all judges
the probation office provides advice
to judges case by case usually in
private usually not available to the
public is that right josh
not exactly senator
the probation office
in uh criminal cases
is assigned by the court
to work with respect to
the evaluation of cases
in every case consistent with
congress's requirements
the probation office prepares
a
pre-sentence report
in which they review
all of the statutory factors
concerning sentencing congress has a
statute
for sentencing
it requires uh judges to consider the
nature and circumstances of the offense
the history and characteristics of the
defendant the need for the sentence
imposed to promote various purposes of
punishment
there are many purposes listed in the
statute and the probation office
is the arm of the court
that does factual investigations in
every criminal case unless
there are certain cases in which you can
wave it but the background
is the probation office's assessment
of
the facts related to
a particular
sentence and a particular crime and the
the probation officers report when a
court sentences
actually
uh in most cases becomes the findings of
fact of the court and so the probation
office appears
just like
the
prosecution and the defense the
probation office has written a report
and they
make a recommendation
to the court based on their independent
analysis
related to the facts of a particular
crime and defendant and sentence
understood so they they give the court
counsel understood uh however they don't
issue guidelines
they're not uniform it is by its very
nature a a case-by-case inquiry as you
said the report goes to the judge
as i understand that the the
pre-sentencing report i'm sorry the
probation reports are are not public in
all of the cases that we're talking
about here i'd love to see them if they
are but uh it's not as if there's one
set of guidelines that are federal
sentencing guidelines and then there's
the probation guidelines the probation
office is giving advice to the judge it
varies case by case senator it's not
it's not it's not the same
sorry i thought you were done that's
right let me ask you about a specific
case i mean let's talk about i i listed
these seven cases
in which you had discretion and you did
not follow the prosecutor's
recommendation or the sentencing
guidelines but let's just talk about one
of them because we've talked about some
of them as a group let's talk about
united states versus hawkins i think
that's one you probably remember from
2013 the defendant there was wesley
hawkins he was 18 years old at the time
he uploaded five video files of child
pornography from his computer to youtube
this is how the police got onto him he
then uploaded another 36
depictions of child porn and other lewd
photos of children to his icloud account
when the police executed a search on his
apartment on the premises they found 17
videos on his laptop and 16 images of
child pornography
all of them
very graphic
some of them involving
very young children the 17 videos in
particular this is from the government
sentencing memorandum in this case just
so we understand the facts here are some
of the videos that the government uh
charged that they recovered
there was a 24-6
24-minute six-second video depicting a
12-year-old male
committing a sexual act i'm not gonna
i'm not going to read exactly what it
was
there's a one minute and 57 second
minute video depicting an eight-year-old
committing a sexual act there was an 11
minute and 47 second video depicting an
11 year old
committing
a sexual act and being raped by an adult
male
there was a 15 minute and 19 second
video depicting two 11 year olds
committing sexual acts there was a seven
minute and 51 second video depicting a
12 year old committing a sexual act so
as the government said in this case and
i'm quoting now from the transcript of
the sentencing hearing 17 videos is a
lot
and some of the videos including the
ones that are described in the statement
of the offense and i've just related
some of them are very lengthy and
include numerous images numerous views
sometimes collages sometimes multiple
victims you see the act in progress
the government goes on to describe some
of these as
sadomasochistic
images so this is this is a tough case
this is one of those tough cases you
were referencing earlier you talked
about this morning said these cases are
terrible this is one of them this is
terrible stuff this is not a good guy
who's doing this stuff
guidelines recommendation in the case
was 97 to 121 months so if i'm doing my
math right that's up to 10 years
and
in this case the guidelines
recommendation was essentially written
by congress because in the protect act
of 2003
congress specified what they wanted the
range to be in these kind of cases and
congress also specified what they wanted
the mandatory minimums to be i know you
remember the protect act because you've
talked about it you've you've given
lectures on it
and it was enacted as i said in 2003 was
84-0 was the was the vote here in the
senate
the concern the reason the protect act
was put into place is the senate was
concerned over lenient sentences by
judges in child porn cases
which is what you described you said
about it there was an increasing
perception on capitol hill and within
doj
that liberal judges were to blame for
the downward pressure on federal
sentences and that legislation was
necessary to rein the men
that's you in 2011 describing this
law so congress has set the guidelines
here 84 to enough in the senate i
noticed the chairman voted for it as did
a number of other members of this
committee so that congress sets the
range essentially it's 97 months up to
10 years now the prosecutor in this case
this has been dc of course you're on the
federal district court
prosecutor in this case
it's a a uh a liberal administration i
think it's fair to say it says in the
state of texas see my colleague from
texas next to me here prosecutor in this
case nevertheless still asked for two
full years
in prison
you gave the defendant three months
guidelines called for 10 years
prosecutor wanted at least two
you gave him three months
and when you did you needed you made a
number of arguments and statements in
the record i'd like to go through some
of them because i've read them all
and the first argument you made was that
the federal guidelines that punished
child porn offenders the ones that
congress wrote
were and i'm quoting you now are in many
ways outdated
that's your quote and you went on to say
about why you thought they were outdated
i'm going to quote you again you say and
i quote i don't feel that it's
appropriate
to increase the penalty on the basis of
the number of images or prepubescent
victims meaning little kids as the
guidelines require
because these circumstances exist in
many cases if not most
and don't signal
an especially heinous
or egregious
child pornography offense in quote
i just want to ask you about that
because i just have to tell you i'm
having a hard time wrapping my head
around it we're talking about
eight-year-olds and nine-year-olds and
eleven-year-olds and twelve-year-olds
he's got images of these the government
said added up to over 600 images
gobs of video footage
of these children
but you say this does not signal a
heinous or egregious child pornography
offense
help me understand that what word would
you use if it's not heinous or egregious
how would you describe it
thank you senator for letting me
address
the concern
that you've put forward
based on the record
that you've reviewed
as a judge
who
is a mom and has
been tasked with the responsibility of
actually reviewing the evidence
the evidence that you
would not describe
in polite company
the evidence that you
are pointing to
discussing
addressing in this context is evidence
that i
have seen
in my role as a judge
and it is
heinous it is
egregious
what a judge has to do
is determine
how to sentence defendants
proportionately
consistent
with the elements that the statutes
include
with the requirements that congress
has set forward
unwarranted sentencing disparities is
something that the
sentencing commission has been focused
on for a long time
in regard to child pornography offenses
all of the offenses
are horrible all of the offenses are
egregious
but the guidelines as you pointed out
are being departed from even with
respect to the government's
recommendation
the government
in this case and in others
has asked for a sentence that is
substantially less than the guideline
penalty and so what i
was discussing was that phenomenon that
the guidelines
in this area are not doing the work
of differentiating defendants
as the government itself indicated in
this very case and so
that's what i was talking about but i
want to assure you senator
that i take these cases
very seriously
that these cases
include
the notion by many defendants
that the folks at issue that the
defendants themselves are collecting
these images on the internet
they're terrible things that have
happened but they're
not involved say the defendants they're
not focused on you know what is actually
happening to the children
and so part of my sentencings was about
redirecting the defendant's attention
it's not just about
how much time a person spends in prison
it's about understanding
the harm of this
this behavior it's about
all of the other
kinds of restraints
that sex offenders are ordered rightly
to
live under at the end of the day the
sentences in these cases include not
only prison time
but
restraints on computer use sometimes for
decades
restraints on ability to go near
children sometimes for decades all of
these things
judges consider
in order to affect what congress has
required which is a sentence that is
sufficient but not greater than
necessary let me just promote the
purposes of punishment yeah well let me
just ask you about that last point
because you've said this a couple of
times now the the sentences that
congress require congress wanted the
guidelines to be mandatory
congress wrote the guidelines in this
case
they wanted them to be mandatory
they gave the courts factors to consider
to choose between the sentencing range
congress wanted you to choose between 97
and 121 months
that's what congress wanted the supreme
court in booker
said that the sentence the sentencing
guidelines would be discretionary so the
supreme court gave you the discretion
but if we're talking about what congress
has wanted congress wanted them to be
mandatory my only point in raising that
is just to say that you had discretion
in these
cases
and you use your discretion to to choose
the sentences that you did let me ask
you about some of the things though that
you said because you said this this
morning and i appreciated it how you
want to direct the defendants you want
to get them to own up to what they've
done in these cases i thought that was
powerful and i thought it was right
but let me just ask you about what you
said to this defendant
you said to this defendant through whom
you sentenced to only three months in
prison
that your collection i'm quoting you
your collection at the time that you
were caught was not actually as large as
it seems
the government felt the need to respond
to you on the record they said the
government doesn't believe that it's
appropriate to just disregard the number
of images that the number of images can
be appropriate and indeed in this case
the defendant has amassed an extremely
large collection of child pornography
but you disregarded that you also told
the defendant you said this this seems
to be a case
where you were fascinated by sexual
images involving what were essentially
your peers
and then you went on to say the
defendant was merely trying to satisfy
his curiosity curiosity is your word one
more thing on this same idea you said
you were viewing this is you to the
defendant you were you were viewing sex
acts between children who were not much
younger than you and this whole
discussion is about why you're only
giving him three months
judge he was 18.
these kids are eight
i don't see in what sense their peers
i've got a nine-year-old a seven
material i don't understand you saying
to him that they're peers
and that therefore you were viewing sex
acts between children who are not much
younger than you and that that's
that's somehow a reason to only give him
three months help me understand this
senator i don't have the record of that
entire case in front of me what i recall
with respect to that case
is that unlike the many other
child pornography offenders
that i had seen as a judge and that i
was aware of in my work on the
sentencing commission
this particular defendant
had just graduated from high school
and some of
perhaps not all when you were looking at
the records but some of
the materials that he was looking at
were older
teenagers were older
victims
and
the point
senator is that
you you said before the probation office
is making recommendations and they do so
on a case-by-case basis that is what
congress requires
that if this is not done at the level of
but you had one russian judge you admit
that right i just want to be senator
sentencing is a discretionary act of a
judge
but
it's not a numbers game it's not i
understand that congress
wanted the guidelines to be
mandatory
the supreme court
in 2005 determined that they couldn't be
in an opinion by justice scalia
determined that they couldn't be and
congress since then
has not come back to amend them or to
change them or to make them mandatory
again and so there is discretion at
sentencing and when you look at the
sentencing statutes
congress has
given the judges
not only the discretion to make the
decision
but require judges to do so on an
individualized basis
taking into account not only the
guidelines
but also
various factors including
the age of the defendant
the circumstances of the defendant
the terrible nature of the crime the
harm to the victims
all of these factors are taken into
account and the probation office assists
the court
in
determining
what sentence is sufficient but not
greater than necessary and i appreciate
senator that you
have looked at these from the standpoint
of statistics that you're questioning
whether or not i take them seriously or
i have some uh reason to
handle them in either a different way
than my peers or a different way than
other cases and i assure you that i do
not
that if you were to look at the greater
body of uh not only my more than 100
sentences but also the sentences of
other judges in my district and
nationwide you would see
a very similar
exercise of attempting to do
what it is that judges do
attempting
to take into account all of the relevant
factors and do justice individually in
each case well let's keep talking about
about this case you also said to to this
individual
who is an adult tried as an adult 18
years old you also said to him besides
saying that you thought his victims were
his peers you also said there's no
reason to think that you are a pedophile
and then you went on to say again that's
another reason why you weren't going to
give him you're only going to give him
three months because you had a judge
that he wasn't a pedophile and then you
said and this is something i i really
need your help understanding then you
apologize to him
and i just have to tell you i can't
quite figure this out
you said to him this is a truly
difficult situation
i appreciate that your family's in the
audience i feel so sorry for them and
for you
and for the anguish this has caused all
of you
i feel terrible
about the collateral consequences of
this
conviction
and then you're going to say sex
offenders are truly shunned in our
society
i'm just trying to figure out judge
is he the victim here or the victims the
victims
you're
saying that you are you're apologizing
to him you're saying you're sorry for
the anguish this has caused him there
was a victim impact statement in this
case
it didn't get read into the record but
it was there
i've described the videos that we have
you say earlier in the case you talk
about how heinous these crimes are and
you describe them to your credit you
describe how heinous it is to your
credit and yet here you are giving him
three months
and apologizing to him and saying you
feel sorry for the anguish that's caused
him and also saying you think that sex
offenders are truly shunned in our
society
so just just talk about that help me
understand i mean is he a victim is that
your view here is that why you said this
is that what you meant by senator i
i again don't have the entire record i
remember in that particular case i
considered it to be unusual
in part for the reasons that i described
i remember in that case that defense
was arguing creation
in part
because
he argued
that he had a
very young man
just graduated from high school he
presented all of his diplomas and
certificates and the things that he had
done
and argued
consistent with what i was seeing in the
record
that this particular defendant
had
gotten into this in a way that was i
thought inconsistent with some of the
other cases that i had seen part of what
a judge is doing
as
required by congress
is
thinking about
this case
thinking about unwarranted sentencing
disparities that's in the statute other
cases other determinations that a judge
may have made about this
i don't remember in detail this
particular case but i do recall it being
unusual
and so my my only point to you
is that
judges
are doing the work
of assessing in each case
a number of factors that are set forward
by congress
all against the backdrop
of heinous criminal behavior
but the guidelines are no longer
mandatory congress has not
corrected as you would say the supreme
court's determination about that justice
scalia's decision that the guidelines
are not mandatory congress has not said
that and congress has given
judges
factors to consider
this in my view was an unusual case that
had a number of factors that the
defendant was pointing out the
government was pointing out that the
probation office was pointing out
and i
sent this
18 year old
to three months in federal prison
under circumstances
that were presented in this case because
i wanted him to understand that what he
had done was harmful
that what he had done was unlawful
that what he had done violated the law
and and needed to be
punished
not only by prison but also by all of
the other things that
the law requires of a judge who is
sentencing in this area but but judge
with all due respect and i'm i i i tell
you what i'll be directed to you i am
questioning your discretion your
judgment that's exactly what i'm doing
i'm not questioning you as a person i'm
not questioning your excellence as a
judge frankly but you said it you had
discretion and i that's exactly what i'm
doing i'm questioning how you used your
discretion in these cases and to me
to take a guy who's 18 years old who has
what the government says is an extremely
large collection of prepubescent
pornography
eight-year-olds 10 year olds 11 year
olds we're talking about i mean
gobs of hours of time here that he has
and
you say to him what that you say that
well you know it was it was just a
collection i mean he was just viewing it
and it was you know essentially they
were his peers you say to him that he's
not a pedophile
i don't know how you know that i don't
know why that's relevant to the
guidelines but maybe it is you say he's
not a pedophile um you say that you're
very sorry for him and what he suffered
and then you give him three months when
frankly a liberal prosecutor is asking
for two full years i mean it does seem
like an extraordinary case to me it
would bother me no matter what it really
bothers me when in every case child porn
case you've had you've had discretion
you've sentenced below the guidelines
and below the government's
recommendation and saying that sex
offenders are truly shunned in our
society as you said to him it it reminds
me of echoes which you said as early as
law school on that harvard law review
article senator blumenthal was just
talking about there you say
and i'm quoting you now in the current
climate of fear hatred and revenge
associated with the release of convicted
sex criminals
courts must be especially attentive to
legislative enactments
regarding these sex criminals i guess
like like this the enactment here the
the the protect act that congress
enacted so i want to i want to try to
understand here is it your view that
society is too hard on sex offenders you
say they truly are shunned in society
you wrote that
many of these laws are products of a
climate of fear hatred and revenge
so just is that is that still your view
i mean do you think that these that
these laws
are
too tough that we're too tough on sex
offenders explain what you meant in this
case in 2013 and it seems to be the same
thing you said many years ago
senator it's not the same thing i said
many years ago many years ago as a law
school student i was evaluating a new
set of
legislation state laws about
registration and i was analyzing them as
law students do
wasn't about the sex crime it was about
the characterization of the law
is it a punitive law is it a
prescriptive law and
how would a court go about
determining that that was the frame that
i used then it could have been about
anything it was about
the characterization
of
legislation
i don't i'm sorry i don't mean to
interrupt you i've only got two and a
half minutes left but i just want to
make sure i understand this
this is i'm quoting from your conclusion
now this is on page 17 32
1728
of the of the harvard law review this is
your conclusion
in the current climate of fear
hatred and revenge associated with the
release of convicted sex criminals
courts need to be especially attentive
to legislative enactments so you that's
a conclusory statement you're saying
that there is a climate of fear hatred
and revenge that are informing these
laws and you described some of the laws
earlier i think megan's law and others
senator cruz asked you about some of
those
i i just understand what you meant by
that because you're saying something
similar in the hawkins case you're
saying that society truly shuns our sex
offenders
with all due respect
my uh article is now in the record
people can read it and they can see
that i was evaluating these laws not to
determine their constitutionality not to
say that they shouldn't be enacted but
to talk about
the ways in which courts
make determinations about the character
of the law and all of the consequences
that follow from them in law school i
had not had
any uh experience in in terms of the
criminal justice system and i was doing
what law students do
which is
uh
seeking to analyze in a creative way
new legislation
with respect to mr hawkins i was doing
what judges do
which is
look at the statute 18
usc 3553
exercise discretion as congress has
required us to do
take into account
all of the various aspects of a
particular case and make a determination
consistent with
my authority
my judgment
and understanding fully
the egregious nature of the crime
as you said
even the prosecutors in these cases are
not
recommending guideline sentences
the probation office which is an
independent
looking at these cases and the facts
related to them are not recommending
guideline sentences
this is a particular area
where the commission has seen an
enormous amount
of disparity
and has in fact asked congress to come
back and address
to to help judges
who are looking at these cases to be
able to rely on the guidelines which
congress has declined to do
senator in that case we have the statute
that congress has enacted concerning
penalties and we have judges who are
doing their level best
to make sure
that
people are held accountable as they need
to be in our society in a fair and just
way
mr chairman my time's expired i have
thank you judge uh i have no further
questions at this time
just checking with my staff so the
original statute was passed in 2003
the scalia decision 2005
the booker decision so the original
statute that i'm talking about um i'm
just thinking was i felt like it was in
the 80s
we think it means in 2003 i'm
all right
justice scalia the booker decision
made the guidelines advisory so that
even though judges have to calculate
them they are no longer binding and what
it meant in the statute is that the
guidelines became one
factor among many
that judges consider attention
i'm not going to opine on justice scalia
in
his conduct and decision as it relates
to the overall topic
i hope we all agree that we want to do
everything in our power
reasonably within our power to lessen
the incidence of pornography and
exploitation of children you have made
that clear that is your position too but
i just want to tell you
congress has doesn't have clean hands in
this conversation we haven't touched
this now for 15 16 or 17 years
and
this you aren't the only one who faced
this kind of a challenge with the cases
before you
i said this morning it bears repeating
in united states versus klotz trump
appointed judge sarah pitlik
hawley's choice senator hawley's choice
for the eastern district of missouri
sentenced an individual convicted of
possession of child pornography to only
60 months
well below the
135-168 month sentence recommended by
the guidelines
mr chairman you've mentioned let me
finish i'll finish and then of course
i'll recognize you senator holly you've
said some very powerful things in
support of this judge but clearly she
faced a situation where she decided she
would not follow the guidelines
and took a sentence of less than half of
what they recommended we have created a
situation because of our
inattention and unwillingness to tackle
an extremely controversial area in
congress and left it to the judges
and i think we have to accept some
responsibility for that senator
i just wanted to say
chairman durbin since you mentioned
judge pitlik in the klotz case
she followed the prosecutor's
recommendation in that case
my as i've said over and over part of my
concern with judge jackson is that she
has not followed the prosecutor's
sentences she didn't in the hawkins case
we were just talking about or the
guidelines
and i'm happy we'll we can have a policy
debate about whether or not the
guidelines are too lenient i would argue
in this era of exploding child
pornography they're not too lenient at
all i think you were right the first
time when you voted in 2003 to make them
tougher
i will just say that uh i don't know if
you sponsored a bill to change this i'll
be looking for it but i will tell you
that there isn't a long line of people
waiting to co-sponsor this controversial
issue we if we're going to tackle it we
should but we should concede in the
meantime that we've left judges in the
lurch in many of these situations there
is no clarity in this situation and i
think to hold this judge responsible for
the overall situation is to ignore
our
non-seasons malfeasance whatever it
might be and lack of responsibility in
dealing with this senator hirono
thank you mr chairman
jeff jackson as you may know i ask the
following two preliminary questions of
every nominee who appears before any of
the committees on which i sit so i will
ask you these two questions first since
you became a legal adult have you ever
made unwanted requests for sexual favors
or committed any verbal or physical
harassment or assault over sexual nature
i have not have you ever faced
discipline or entered into a settlement
related to this kind of conduct
i have not
just jackson my colleague from missouri
seems to think that
it's appropriate for federal judges to
sentence individuals below inappropriate
uh to sentence individuals below the
sentencing guidelines in these kinds of
cases horrific cases and so i think it's
important to offer a couple of
clarifications for the record
judge jackson when the u.s sentencing
commission first addressed the issue of
sentencing in the
in this area in
2012 do you remember that only 40
percent of convicted offenders in this
category were receiving sentences within
the guidelines
senator i don't remember exactly the
number but i do know that there was a
great deal of variance from the
guidelines 40
would you be surprised to learn that the
department of justice which prosecutes
these cases sent a letter to the u.s
sentencing commission in 2013
stating that the existing sentencing
guidelines for child pornography
offenses
do not accurately reflect
the current landscape of child
pornography offense conduct
i
don't remember that particular letter
but there was a lot of concern about
this guideline from from all sides
and now the sentencing commission issued
another report just last year on this
topic and do you know that as of that
report an even lower percentage of
convicted offenders were receiving
sentences within within the guidelines
did you know i'm not surprised
it's even less i didn't know but i'm not
surprised
did you know that as of last year it was
just 30
of non-production offenders who were
sentenced within the guidelines
i did not know but i'm not surprised
my republican colleagues made a big show
yesterday of
promising a fair process and to me that
means ensuring that you are treated
no differently than any other federal
judges
that have nominees that have come before
us
see there was an article recently that
highlighted the fact that many of
president trump's circuit court nominees
who were previously district court
judges had also issued below guidelines
sentencing to child pornography cases
judge
ralph erickson who was confirmed to the
8th circuit in 2017 with support from
every republican member of this
committee who was serving in the senate
at the time and there are at least 11
cases where he sentenced people to below
guideline sentences
does that surprise you
it does not senator
i'm not sure if you know judge erickson
but do you have any reason to believe
he's a soft on child pornography based
on these sentences
i don't have any reason to believe
do you think my republican colleagues
are soft on child pornography just
because they voted for judge erickson to
become a federal appellate judge even
after he issued these 11 sentences
senator i'm
not in a position to
um
evaluate whether your your colleagues
are soft on crime because of their votes
i have no reason to believe that
they voted for this person
but um i i think it would probably be
quite unfair to characterize him as
being soft on child pornography
i would also like to talk to you about
judge joseph blanco bianco
who was confirmed to the second circuit
in 2019 with support from every
republican member of this committee who
was serving in the senate at the time
including senator holly
in the case united states be bowen
judge bianco sentenced a defendant to 60
months in prison when his guidelines
range was
151 to 188 months
and here's what judge bianco said in the
sentencing transcript for that case
quote
and the guidelines here are just way
disproportionate under the facts of this
case and i don't view them as
particularly helpful in this case i
believe the probation department got it
right in terms of the statutory
mandatory minimum being sufficient but
not greater than necessary to achieve
the factors of sentencing
quote
i'm not sure if you know judge bianco
but do you have any reason to believe
that he's soft on child pornography
based on that sentence are those
comments i do not senator
do you think my republican colleagues
including senator holly are soft on
child pornography because they voted to
confirm judge bianco to the second
circuit
even after
he issued below guideline sentences and
made these comments
i have no reason to believe that that
here are some of the other circuit
judges that all of my republican
colleagues voted to confirm despite the
fact that they
they sentenced child pornography
defendants to below guidelines sentences
judge amal thopper on the sixth circuit
judge richard sullivan on the second
circuit
judge andrew brasher on the 11th circuit
again i'm not sure if you've ever met
these judges before but do you have any
reason to believe they don't take child
pornography seriously
i do not
i would like to note that senator cruz
referred to a chart
that listed
eight cases
and the government recommendations and
the sentencing guidelines and that
you did not adhere to those sentencing
guidelines
what was not included in the chart was
what the probation recommendations were
and if you add those probation
recommendations
in five of the cases you follow the
probation recommendations in one
instance you were lower and one instance
you were higher than the probation
recommendations mr chairman i would like
to introduce the complete chart
for the record without objection
you've been asked to answer a lot of
questions about your judicial philosophy
some of my colleagues particularly on
the other side
seem dead set
on finding out if you are an originalist
a textualist if you believe in a living
constitution or various other labels
i don't find these labels particularly
useful
take originalism
proponents claim you just have to dig
deeply enough into the historical record
and you'll somehow find the one true
meaning of a constitutional provision
the fallacy of this approach approach is
illustrated in district of columbia
versus heller
there justice scalia's majority opinion
and justice stevenson's dissenting
opinion each applied originalism
justice stevens more effectively in my
opinion
and reach completely different
conclusions about the scope of the
second amendment
take textualism
bostock
judge gorsuch applied textualism to find
that title vii
of the civil rights act protected
employees from discrimination based on
sexual orientation and gender identity
in dissent justice alito mocked justice
gorsuch's
application of textualism and he wrote
the following justice alito
quote the court attempts to pass off its
decision as the inevitable product of
the textureless school of statutory
interpretation
championed by our late colleague justice
scalia
but no one should be fooled
the court's opinion is like a pirate
ship it sails under a textureless flag
but what it actually represents is a
theory of statutory interpretation that
justice scalia excoriated the theory
that courts should update old statutes
so that they better reflect the current
values of society end quote and these
are two justices who are usually in
agreement so so much for labels
so instead of trying to fix some label
on you
i'd rather focus on the fact that you
are fair and objective in your approach
that you are even-handed in your
application of law to the facts and that
you are independent
during your last confirmation hearing
you spoke about judicial independence
about what you learned during the three
clerkships
and you're then eight years on the bench
you said and i quote i know very well
what my obligations are what my duties
are
not to rule with partisan advantage in
mind
not to tailor or craft my decisions in
order to gain influence or anything of
the sort
end quote
well said so my question is the
following
what do you do to ensure that you
maintain independence free of partisan
partisanship when you handle a case
thank you senator
what i do and what i've done in
all of my
570 some odd
uh opinions
is
to apply a methodology that is designed
to
ensure my impartiality
and
to respect the limits of my judicial
role
what it means is that i am receiving
the cases
and at the outset
i am
setting aside any personal views that i
might have about the parties about the
issues as i also said in my dc circuit
confirmation it doesn't matter to me
whether the argument is being made by
the president of the united states or a
death row inmate what i'm doing is
looking at the argument
i'm looking at the facts
i'm applying the law in as neutral and
consistent a manner as i can
because that is the duty and requirement
of the judicial oath
i'm also very conscious of the limits of
judicial authority
of the the restrictions that exist in
the law to prevent me as a judge from
becoming a policy maker
this means that i
carefully scrutinize
my jurisdiction
it means that i
look
at the text and focus on the text and
the intentions of
the legislatures
that
drafted
that provision or the intentions of the
framers
that
put forward that constitutional
principle
it means
i'm looking at precedent
if i was fortunate enough to be
confirmed to the supreme court
i would be upholding the principles of
starry decisis as i consider the
precedence and making sure that the
court is
putting forward consistent and
predictable
rulings as is important to maintain the
rule of law
all of these i see as constraints on
judicial authority that i care deeply
about
in order to maintain my independence as
is necessary
to
ensure public confidence
in my rulings as a judge
judge jackson i have sat on this
committee now for a number of years
and as some of my colleagues continue to
try to pin labels on the nominees who
come before us frankly i find your
methodology
to be as succinct a
definition of what would lead a judge to
come up with fair and objective results
i thank you for that
as a lower court judge you were
generally bound by the supreme courts
and the d.c circus presidents
that certainly won't be the case if you
are confirmed to the supreme court
the supreme court can overturn its own
precedence that's why i found your
analysis and committee on the judiciary
versus mcgann instructive in that case
you had a president committee on the
judiciary v myers that had already
confronted the issues you faced however
it was another district court decision
and you were not bound by it you
nonetheless followed that precedent why
did you find that opinion so persuasive
well senator
in um the law
there are
different kinds of precedent and by that
i mean
um there's vertical precedent which is
what people are most
familiar with there are um
cases that are handed down by higher
courts the appellate court the supreme
court
and those bind the lower courts so that
even if you disagree with them you have
to follow them because they're binding
precedent
but there's also horizontal precedent it
it too is about maintaining consistency
and predictability in the rule of law
and what that means is when you are in a
district
there are many judges
and if someone else in your district has
handled a case
that
comes out or that involves the same
issues and comes out in a certain way
you as the second judge have to contend
with that ruling you can't ignore the
fact
that there is precedent in your district
that handles a case in a particular way
and with respect to the mcgann case
the precedent wasn't just close it was
nearly identical
the the myers case involved
the former white house counsel
and the argument by the executive that
the former white house counsel
had absolute immunity
in
with respect to a request by the
legislature that she provide testimony
my case involved a former white house
counsel
who
was claiming absolute immunity at the
request of the executive
in response to a legislative subpoena in
both cases not only was the absolute
immunity issue on the table but in both
cases the same threshold issues about
whether or not there was jurisdiction
in the court because the legislature had
standing or didn't have standing which
is which was the argument that was being
made
the same question about whether the
court could hear
a dispute between the legislature and
the executive branch
all of those issues had previously been
considered
by my colleague in the district court
and he wrote an extensive i'm talking
about judge bates he wrote an extensive
opinion
analyzing each of the issues and so at a
minimum
as the second judge dealing with these
exact same issues i had to look at what
he did
and decide
was it persuasive did i agree
and i did
judge jackson of course if there had
been a vertical precedent i.e from the
supreme court or the circuit court that
was on point to your mcgann situation
yes you would have had to follow that
precedent but there wasn't and so you
followed a a
reasoning by another district judge that
made a lot of sense to me and that
certainly makes sense to me
you discuss dairy decisis and the
importance of precedent in your opinion
and this is what you wrote quote
it is interesting to note that the
doctrine of starry decisis performs a
limiting function that reflects the
foundational principles
that undergird the federal government's
tripartite constitutional system
this is because deciding a legal issue
anew each time that same question is
presented without any reference to what
has been done before
nudges the court outside of its
established domain
of saying what the law is and into the
realm of legislating what the law should
be
i know that you've been asked say the
questions about the importance of
precedent before but maybe you can just
tell us
one more time why precedent is important
in our judicial system
thank you senator
our judicial system
is one that is designed to uphold the
rule of law
unlike other
systems in other societies some other
societies we believe
that we have a government of laws and
not men and yet there are men and women
who are acting as judges in the context
of our system
what precedent does
is ensure
that there's consistency across the
different
individuals who are tasked with the
solemn responsibility of interpreting
the law
it ensures that
there's public confidence that the law
is what is guiding
judges in their decision making and not
just their own individual views
and so it's it's crucial
for
maintaining public confidence
maintaining stability in the law
establishing a system that has
predictability in it
all of which
supports confidence in the judiciary
which which is the currency
of of the judicial branch
because of the importance of precedence
in promoting confidence etc i mean
people need to know what the law is
and so precedent is important on this on
that score and if you are confirmed to
the supreme court what factors would you
consider before
overturning precedent
well there are many factors that the
supreme court considers and not just
whether they think a prior precedent is
wrong that is one of the factors the
court has said that a precedent
that is egregiously wrong is one that is
subject to
reconsideration
uh but in order to actually make the
determination about overturning it
in addition to it being wrong the court
considers
whether or not
there's been reliance on that precedent
and if so how much
the court considers whether or not
the precedent is workable
sometimes the court will
issue a ruling in a case and it turns
out that it's not actually functioning
in the way that the court intended and
so that might be a reason
to revisit it
the court considers whether or not
other precedents in the area
have shifted
such that the
foundation for the particular precedent
is no longer
uh
sustainable
and the court considers whether there
are changes in the facts
uh that relate to that precedent or a
new understanding of the facts that
relate to a precedent
all of those factors are things that a
court takes into the supreme court takes
into account
when it decides whether or not to
revisit
a precedent
therefore the court should consider all
of those factors i would say reliance
factors loom large as far as i'm
concerned uh before overturning a
precedent but basically if you have five
members of the court deciding to
overturn
uh a president they can do so
right
under our scheme yes under the
constitution
and so we're seeing uh more and more uh
presidents being uh asked to be
overturned an analysis by national
affairs found that since 2017 when
justice gorsuch was appointed to the
court the court has shown
i quote an increasing readiness to
overturn precedent end quote this is
true for both long-standing presidents
and those that are just a few years old
for example in 2018 janna's decision the
court overturned a 41 year old president
called abood that decision weakened
public sector unions
justice alito first signaled that he
wanted conservative anti-union groups to
challenge abood in his 2012 decision
in knox versus s-e-i-u
this is called signaling and justice
alito definitely single signal his
desire
to re-visit the buu decision so yes
these groups they got the message
they brought case after case to meet the
criteria that justice alito laid out
and although they came close in 2016
justice scalia's death left the court
stuck in a 4-4 decision
in a case called frederick's the
california teachers association
basically the minute justice gorsuch was
confirmed the court finally had a
conservative five to four majority to
overturn a boot and the result was janus
i followed these lines of cases very
closely so that is what happened they
waited for justice gorsuch and boom
five to four against unions
another in another example the courts
acknowledged four most conservative
justices thomas alito gorsuch and
kavanaugh dissented in june medical
voting to overturn a precedent banning
burdensome and unnecessary restrictions
placed on abortion providers this
particular president was only four years
old
now the court is poised to overturn roe
v wade even though women
have relied on their constitutional
right to have an abortion for nearly
50
years
of course i'm not suggesting that
supreme supreme court decision or pr
presidents are sacrosanct because i'm
thankful uh the court can and uh did
revisit presidents like classify
ferguson that were wrong the day they
were decided
but justices should not be seen to be
advancing their
individual political or ideological
agendas at the expense of individual
rights and precedence that people have
relied on
one result of the court's new approach
is that people's view of the court is
changing for the worst a recent cue poll
found that 44 percent of americans now
disapprove of the supreme court
this is up 15 points from august
2020 shortly before the late justice
ruth bader ginsburg died and amy comey
barrett was appointed to fill
her seat
i think court watches acknowledge there
is an ideologically ideological split
in this current supreme court
when
we are seeing more cases
decided on ideological bases not on the
facts and the law i think it leads to
the american people questioning
whether the court is a fair and
objective arbiter of cases
and controversy
you were asked earlier today about your
representation of guantanamo detainees
just to make it clear
as a federal public defender you were
assigned to represent guantanamo
detainees is that right that is correct
senator and then while at morrison and
forster you also did pro bono work for
guantanamo guantanamo detainees were you
assigned to do that work as well
so there was one detainee who i had
represented as a federal public defender
who was
brought into my firm's practice
unbeknownst to me
uh and when i arrived at the firm
the
attorneys who were working on that case
recognized that i had previously been a
lawyer who had represented this
particular detainee
and asked if i would help with his
habeas petition at that stage i think
you clarified that earlier
today and you served as council of
record on amicus briefs
related to
detention
i think that was brought out today yes
were you working on behalf of detainees
at that point or were you working on
behalf of other groups or individuals
i was working on behalf of other groups
or individuals in in with respect to
retired judges
um i
yes there were there were three briefs
in total two different cases
and um one of the briefs that i filed
was on behalf of
20 retired federal judges including one
who was a partner at my firm at the time
and who wanted to make a particular
argument to the court
concerning the detention process these
were judges that were nominated by
various presidents it must have been a
diverse group and they asked you to
to the grief
and they did
yes
so as part of your work at the law firm
a responsibility of your employment you
were
assigned to work with this diverse group
of retired judges and to represent
conservative or libertarian
organizations such as the cato institute
and the rutherford
institute to advocate their views
yes the other
two briefs that i filed were at the cert
stage and then at the merit stage of a
case that was eventually
mooted
but my clients in those cases were a
diverse group of organizations including
the cato institute the rutherford
institute and the constitution project
members of this committee know full well
that
lawyers are
we we are
and we have to follow the cause of
professional conduct which says that we
have to zealously represent our clients
and that's what you are doing with
regard to the detainees and i just want
to note that some of the very senators
who are openly questioning you for
representing
defendants or detainees have in the past
made the argument that judicial nominees
should not be opposed for the arguments
they make in the course of representing
clients
i'm going to quote one of my colleagues
i've been a military lawyer for almost
30 years i represented people as a
defense attorney in the military that
were charged with some pretty horrific
ads and i gave them my all the system of
justice that we're so proud of in
america requires the unpopular to have
an adequate and an advocate and every
time a defense lawyer fights to make the
government do their job that defense
lawyer has made us all safer
do you agree with that
i do senator
in 2012 prominent conservative lawyers
signed a letter defending attorneys who
have represented guantanamo detainees in
part the letter said quote
the american tradition of zealous
representation of unpopular clients is
at least as old as john adams's
representation of the british soldiers
charged in the boston massacre
good defense councils is key
to ensuring that military commissions
federal juries and federal judges have
access to the best arguments and most
rigorous factual presentation before
making crucial decisions that affect
both national security and paramount
liberty interests
end quote
so the the quote that i read isn't the
first time that to my
colleagues on the other side of the
aisle have
try to
say that your representation on your
work is a public defender somehow i
don't know disqualifies you or makes you
uh leaning one way or the other so
you've made it very clear
that that is not what you are about i
just have one more question in the
remaining time oh i'm sorry i will
senator i'm sorry we're on a roll call
i'm on such a role
you're on a roll and we're on a roll yes
thank you mr chairman
mr chairman before we break if i could
ask one question of the chairman sure
senator hirono just made reference to
the recommendations of the probation
office and in five of these cases
to the best of my knowledge those
probation recommendations are not in the
record i haven't seen them my staff
hasn't seen them
and and that raises two questions number
one whether the white house is providing
differential material on this nominee's
background to democratic members than
republican members because i don't know
where senator hirono would get access to
them other than from the white house but
secondly regardless of whether it's
differential
would the chairman agree that there is
considerable focus on these cases and
the committee both sides
should have access to the pre-sentence
reports and to see the underlying facts
judge jackson has said she was following
the facts and the factors in those cases
senator you know we've completed
discovery before we started this hearing
mr chairman how did senator romero
i'm not going to entertain this we've
been through discovery do you have
access to them i don't know that i do i
really don't can we ask senator hirono
how she got access to them sorry to
interrupt you senator but i want to make
an announcement we're going to have a
10-minute break members are going to
head to so you're going to keep
differential access to this information
i'm not sure what differential access is
i'll take i'll look it up we have a vote
on the floor to take about 10 minutes so
10 to 15 minutes relax
and then we're going to come back and we
have two senators cotton and booker who
will be recognized and then take a break
for dinner uh and then we're going to
try to still finish tonight uh with two
remaining senators senator osof and tell
us who are going to be first thing in
the morning so we stand in recess
[Music]
again
um
[Music]
i
okay
[Music]
[Music]
i
oh
um
[Music]
um
good job
i'm sorry
pieces
oh
now
thank you
strategic
with everybody
thank you
goodbye
okay
yes
um
foreign
[Music]
you
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
um
it
yes
yes
thank you
okay
thank you
yes